EVERYBODY WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY HOME WATER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISCIPLINE DISTANCING HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE'RE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WALK AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MUST BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
BE DISTANCING MAINTAIN BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WHETHER
IT IS HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. BECAUSE OF
OUR SPACE LIMITATIONS WE HAVE
SOME COULD WELL WE ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY COMMITTEEMEMBER
SITTING IN THE FRONT. OF THE
AUDIENCE SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THAT AND THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS TO
PARTICIPATE FOR THE PUBLIC. FOR
THE PUBLIC WHO IS HERE IN THE
ROOM. WHEN WE REACH THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE AGENDA
ALL ASK THAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. MAINTAINING SOCIALLY
DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM. AND I WOULD ASK THE
PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. SOMEBODY ELSE HAS A MIKE
ON. SOMEBODY THE SERGEANTS
PROBLEM MAYBE IT'S ONE OF THE
WITNESSES JUST TO LET EVERYONE
KNOW YOUR BIKES MIGHT BE ON WE
CAN HEAR YOU IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME PANELISTS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
USE OF ONE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. OR A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND A FEW OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO THAT MEMBERS CAN
WATCH HER TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK QUESTIONS. AND ANYONE
WATCHING AT HOME WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO SEE THEM. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. SO
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING TO GET READY WITH YOUR
PENS THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO SO ONCE
AGAIN 877-692-8950 SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE AND PROVIDE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION YOU DO LEAVE THAT ON
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WE WILL NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG
EACH PERSON HAS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. BECAUSE OF THE-
EXTRA TIME ALL OF THIS TAKES SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE LIMITING ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT TO TWO MINUTES
THAT'S WHETHER YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE OR IN PERSON IT WILL BE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. NOW I'M MOVING
ON TO OUR HEARING INCREASING
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN CALIFORNIA I
WAS GONNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
AND THEN TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO I'M SURE WILL WANT TO ADD
THEIR OWN COMMENTS SO WE ALL
KNOW THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY THIS
YEAR WILDFIRES CONTINUE TO HAVE
HUGE IMPACTS ON ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ARE PRETTY AIR
QUALITY NATURAL RESOURCES
PEOPLE'S VERY LIVES AND OF
COURSE OUR TREASURED OPEN SPACE
AND PARKS- I HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED. A RECENTLY I
PARTICIPATED IN AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING PUT ON BY
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB THREE
ON WILDFIRE MITIGATION
MEASURES. THAT AS FOCUSED ON
WILDFIRE MITIGATION TO THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE. AT
TODAY'S HERE IS GOING TO FOCUS
ON ANOTHER IMPORTANT COMPONENT
IN DEALING WITH CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRE RISK WHICH IS
PRESCRIBED BURNING. INCLUDING
CULTURAL BURNING. ASCRIBE FIRE
USED UNDER THE CORRECT
CONDITIONS CAN RESTORE
RESILIENCE TO OUR FORESTS IN
WAYS THAT WILL REDUCE THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES AND
INDEED IS WE'RE GONNA HERE.
THEY WERE AT ONE POINT A VERY
REGULAR AND NATURAL PART OF OUR
FOREST ECOSYSTEM. IN JUNE OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM ISSUED AN APOLOGY.
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TO HELP TO
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S FOR THE MANY INSTANCES
OF VIOLENCE MISTREATMENT AND
NEGLECT. INFLICTED UPON A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S HISTORY.
PART OF THIS MISTREATMENT WAS
ACTIVELY STOPPING CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS FOR MANAGING
THEIR LAND IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDED FOR THEIR PEOPLE. AND
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE
RISK. HOPEFULLY IN ADDITION TO
OTHER ACTIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND ACCOUNT FOR
HISTORICAL WRONGS. THE STATE
CAN ALSO TAKE MEANINGFUL STEPS
TO SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF
CULTURAL BURNING. IN A WAY THAT
BENEFITS BOTH CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS AND REDUCES OUR
STATE'S WILDFIRE RISK. I WANT
TO THANK MY VICE CHAIR HE FLORA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM WOOD FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
TODAY AS WELLAS ANYBODY WHO
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
AND I WANT TO SEE. IF ANY OF
EITHER OF YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
STATEMENTS. MISTER WOULD. WELL
FIRST OFF THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND TO PARTICIPATE I HAVE
A STRONG INTEREST IN THIS. MY
DISTRICT HAS EXPERIENCED A MORE
THAN ITS SHARE OF WILDFIRES- IN
RECENT YEARS THE TUBBS FIRE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH BECAME
THE LARGEST FIRE IN STATE
HISTORY- AROUND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES. AND NOW THE-
THE AUGUST COMPLEX BUYERS THAT.
I HAVE HAPPENED NOW CLIPS OVER
A MILLION ACRES- IN IN MY
DISTRICT SO HAVE THE DUBIOUS
HONOR OF HAVING SOME OF THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES IN
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE. OF
THAT HAVE TOUCHED THE SECOND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND SO- THE
COULD THE AREA OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME
AND OF GREAT INTEREST- I SPENT-
THE INTERIM- MEETING WITH
PEOPLE- ABOUT PRESCRIBED FIRE-
IT IS CHALLENGING TO DO
PRESCRIBE FIRE IN IT IS- IT IS
CHALLENGING ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS AND- AND I WILL HAVE TO
SAY THAT I THINK PART OF IT IS.
US WE AS GOVERNMENT HAVE GOTTEN
IN THE WAY AND MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO DO PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND WE NEED TO FIND A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY- THIS FRIDAY I'M ACTUALLY
GOING UP INTO- THE NORTHERN
PART OF MY DISTRICT TO VISIT
WITH THE- TROUBLE MEMBERS FROM
THE KARUK TRIBE- WHO DO A LOT
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE- WORK. AND
LEARN TO LEARN FROM THEM TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE IMPEDIMENTS
THEY HAVE- THEY ARE UNIQUELY
SITUATED AND THEN THAT PART OF
THEIR- PART THEY THEY JOINED
NATIONAL FOREST AS WELL AS
STATE LANDS. AND THEY HAVE YET
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND I
WANT TO LEARN FROM THEM AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN BRING BACK
HOPEFULLY IMPLEMENT HERE SO I
JUST I JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE TODAY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
PRESENTATIONS. THANK YOU BUT
YOUR CAR THINK ABOUT YOUR
REPORT THIS- HEARING ON AND
DOCTOR WOULD IT'S BEEN A- YOUR
DISTRICT HAS CERTAINLY GONE
THROUGH A LOT- MY BACKGROUND
COMING PRIOR TO THE LEGISLATOR-
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND THIS
IS BEEN A SUBJECT THAT HAS BEEN
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEART
BECAUSE I DO THINK WE HAVE-
COMPLETELY MESSED UP AS
GOVERNMENT. AND I THINK WE HAVE
A LOT TO LEARN FROM OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN FRIENDS- ON FOR
DECADES HOW THEY CONTROLLED.
THE VEGETATION WITHIN THEIR
TRIBAL LANDS AND I THINK WE
COULD EXPAND ON THAT. SO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THIS HEARING I
THINK IT'S. A GREAT FIRST STEP
FORWARD BECAUSE- FOR YEARS I'M
I LOVE TO STATE TO THE- AND
EIGHT. AND IT WAS OVERGROWN
THEN. AND WE HAVE A DECADE PLUS
TWO YEARS OF GROWTH ON TOP OF
THAT. AND WE STILL HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING EVERY YEAR. OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE FACED WITH
CAREER FIRES. AND NOTHING SEEMS
TO CHANGE SO THIS IS A GREAT
FIRST STEP I'M PROUD TO BE
HERE. AND I'M EXCITED TO WHERE
WE CAN GO FROM HERE BECAUSE WE
DO WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM A
NATIVE AMERICAN FRIENDS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BECAUSE WE HAVE-
SEVERAL PANELS AND A LOT OF
SPEAKERS AND A LOT OF
INFORMATION WE'RE GONNA BE
LIMITING. THE TIME FOR EACH
WITNESS. TO SEVEN MINUTES AND I
WOULD ASK THE WITNESSES TO.
PLEASE TRY TO RESPECT THAT IN
AND- B. AS JUDICIOUS AS YOU CAN
WITH YOUR TIME. SO I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE AND WELCOME OUR FIRST
PANEL TO GIVE US BACKGROUND AN
OVERVIEW ON PRESCRIBED FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES ANYWAY
LIKE- BUT WE WILL HAVE SCOTT
STEVENS PROFESSOR FIRE. SCIENCE
HENRY J. PHELPS DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR IN FOREST POLICY.
MERRY PRINT A KEEP. WHO'S A PHD
AND MD AND DIRECTOR OF AIR
POLLUTION AND HEALTH RESEARCH.
MYSTERON IN PARKER CENTER FOR
ALLERGY AND ASTHMA RESEARCH AND
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. AND LENA
QUINN DAVIDSON WHO'S THE AREA
FIRE ADVISOR FROM UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION- WELCOME TO ALL OF
YOU. AND I BELIEVE MISTER
STEVENS- PROFESSOR STEVENS WILL
BE SPEAKING FIRST. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY. AT THE ARE
MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY- I
APPRECIATE THE- JUNIOR EFFORT
IN THE FIRE AREA. I THINK IF I
COULD PLEASE GET THIS GO TO MY
FIRST LINE IF THAT'S POSSIBLE
ONLY HAVE TO. I THINK IT'S ON
OUR SCREEN WE CAN SEE IT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T SEE
IT SO- HERE'S A PICTURE OF YOUR
RECEIPT CALIFORNIA BLODGETT
FORCE RESEARCH STATION A
PRESCRIBED FIRE I GET SEVERAL
YEARS AGO. AND HERE YOU CAN TO
SEE CERTAINLY SOME OTHER STORY
FLAMES AND SOME THINGS THAT ARE
WORKING FOR US- I WOULD JUST
SAY UP THERE IN THE LEFT CORNER
WE'VE GOT THREE PRESCRIBED FIRE
SCHEDULED FOR THIS FALL BLOCK
IT. WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO- WITH
ROB YORK ANOTHER TO GET THESE
THINGS DONE AND WE'RE STILL
KIND OF IN I'M KIND OF IN THE
QUEUE. AND THE CHALLENGE OF
COURSE IS JUST TRYING TO GET
CONDITIONS ARE GOOD. I'LL TALK
ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
LIKE THE SECOND SLIDE BUT RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T REALLY SEE A
WINDOW OR WE CAN DO OUR THREE
PRESCRIBED FIRES BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT- OUR. WEATHER IS
WORKED OUT THIS YEAR. BUT I
ALSO WOULD SAY THAT. I REALLY
HAVE APPLAUD STATE THE STATE
OKAY. HAS TAKEN. IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. TO BRING THIS FRONT
AND CENTER. THE LAST YEAR THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION INTO THE
NEWS MY MINISTRATION WE'VE SEEN
DRAMATIC. EMPHASIS ON FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I REALLY
APPLAUD THIS EFFORT BECAUSE
FRANKLY MY THIRTY YEAR CAREER
THIS IS NOT HAPPENED AT THE
STATE LEVEL- WE'RE LOOKING MUCH
MORE PROACTIVELY NOW PURSUE
TRYING TO CERTAINLY. FOCUS ON
DEPRESSION AND OTHER THINGS
BUT- I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
STATE'S EFFORTS. AND I THINK
WHAT THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I'M
NOT TALK A COUPLE THINGS ABOUT
WHERE WE'RE HEADED TO MAYBE-
SOME IDEAS AND SOME THINGS TO.
CONSIDER AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO
FIRST YOU SEE ON TOP HER BILLS
WELL I WANT TO BRING VISIBLE UP
FOR A MOMENT IS ALL OF MY
PREDECESSOR UC BERKELEY HE WAS
A- PROFESSOR FIRE. ECOLOGY AT
BERKELEY. YOU GOTTA NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN RETIRED NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO. BY NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT HE HAD BEEN WORKING SEVEN
YEARS PRESCRIBED BURNING IN
CALIFORNIA FORCED. ANYONE TO
PAPER IN FIFTY EIGHT THAT SAID
WE NEED TO START DOING THIS.
IMAGINE NOT NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. SO LAW WAS ACTUALLY
SOMEONE THAT LOOK FORWARD HE
WANTED TO USE FIRE. HE'S WORK
INITIALLY WITH ALL ON- STATE.
AND DON'T SHOOT ME WAS ON
PRIVATE LAND DEFERRED FORCING
HOPE WORKS. AT THE TIME NO
STATE OR FEDERAL. WORK MANAGER.
BURKE SO WE LOOK AT ON KIND OF
THE EARLY PART OF HOW TO
PRESCRIBE BURNING HERE IN. IT
WAS REALLY FIRST DONE ALL
PRIVATE LANDS. SO THERE WAS
STRONG AGREEMENT- ABOUT HOW TO
DO THE SOME OF THIS WORK FROM A
FEW INDIVIDUALS BUT- I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WAS A GIANT
MISSED OPPORTUNITY OF. THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES BY THE MID
NINETEEN SIXTIES BILLS WELL
HAVE BASICALLY COME FORWARD
ASSEMBLY REALLY NEED TO DO THIS
EARNERS BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVE
SOME ISSUES SUCH AS FELS. WE
HAVE A WHILE AGO NEVER FACE
ISSUE AND OTHERS SO I DON'T
WANT TO BELIEVE THAT POINT BUT
I WOULD JUST SAY WE'RE WE'VE
GOT SOME HISTORY ON THIS TOPIC
AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LOT
MORE OPPORTUNITY I THINK
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT MORE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
WORKING COOPERATIVELY FIVE PLOT
THAT. FUNDS UNDER THE WORKFORCE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A FORCE OF
WORKFORCE PRESCRIBED FIRE IN
THIS STATE SOMETHING I THINK WE
REALLY HAVE TO FOCUS ON. BOTH
SIDE OF SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND
SENATOR WYDEN IN THE U. S.
SENATE HAVE BILLS TO ADDRESS
THIS BOTH OF THEM WERE CALLING
FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAINING
CENTER IN THE WESTERN U. S. I
APPLAUD THAT EFFORT.
TALLAHASSEE FLORIDA HAS ONE OF
THOSE ALREADY HAS ACTUALLY
WORKED FOR DECADES TO REALLY
INCREASE THE YOUNG. WORK FORCE.
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE
REALLY HAVE TO DO OUT HERE. WE
NEED TO BURN OUTSIDE THE
WILDFIRE SEASON MY FIRST LINE
ALLUDED TO WE GOT THREE
PRESCRIBED FIRES THIS YEAR IN
THE QUEUE. WE REALLY CAN'T GET
HIM DOWN ON THE EDGE OF THE
WILDFIRE SEASON. BUT WINTER AND
SPRING OUR GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO BURNING IN THE STATE.
OTHERS SAY YOU KNOW FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY NO IT'S NOT THAT
LONG AGO. MAYBE REMEMBER
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY WE NEED
ANY RAIN OR ANY SNOW IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA. TALK ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO PRESCRIBED
BURNING AT SCALE. I THINK THERE
WAS A LOT WE HAVE TO TAE
BECAUSE WE'RE NEVER GONNA DO.
ACRES AND THAT SCALE WE NEED
UNLESS WE REALLY OPEN UP SOME
OF THESE PERIODS TO BURNING.
BECAUSE JUST LIKE RIGHT NOW
WITH OUR THREE FIRES WERE A
LITTLE BIT STYMIED BUT IF YOU
HAVE A WHOLE MONTH IN FEBRUARY
WHEN IT'S RELATIVELY DRY. YOU
CAN REALLY TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY.
AT THAT TIME MOST OF OUR
FIREFIGHTING FORCES ARE
COMPLETELY GONE. YEAH THIS IS
OUTSIDE THE FIRE SEASON THAT'S
WHY WE NEED A DEDICATED
PRESCRIBE FAR WORKING FOR CHRIS
TAKE OPPORTUNITIES. MAYBE ON
THE SCALE 2225% OF OUR
SUPPRESSION FORCE MAYBE THAT
SOUNDS CRAZY BUT IT'S GONNA
TAKE SOME SIGNIFICANT EFFORT.
FLORIDA HAS BEEN A LEADER
PRESCRIBED BURNING FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AND I HAVE TO TIP MY
HAT TO THEM ALSO GEORGIA
ANOTHER. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THEY HAD A VERY BAD
EVENT. PRESCRIBED FIRE WAS DONE
I THOUGHT IT WAS OVER. A FEW
DAYS LATER IT REKINDLED
THUNDERSTORM CAME IN AND
BASICALLY MOVE THIS FAR INTO
URBAN AREA BURNED DOWN THIRTY
SIX HOUSES. ONE THING YOU HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT THIS IS CERTAINLY
A TRAGEDY. BUT ONE THING THAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING. WE DIDN'T
EVEN HEAR ABOUT IT OUT HERE.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS IS THAT. THEY
HAVE SUCH A MATURE PROGRAM
WOULD ENABLE THEM TO GET
THROUGH THAT TRAGIC EVENT. AND
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. CAN
YOU IMAGINE THIRTY SIX HOUSES
NO ONE WAS HURT. NO ONE WAS
KILLED THAT'S GREAT BUT THIRTY
SIX HOUSES BURNED IN A
PRESCRIBED FIRE THAT REKINDLES
AFTER A FEW DAYS AND THE SYSTEM
CONTINUES OPERATES. THEY JUST
HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE STRONG
PROGRAM WITH A LOT OF HISTORY.
THE LIABILITY COVERAGE IS ONE
OF THE KEYS TO FLORIDA'S
PROGRAM. AND EVEN MYSELF IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE I WORKING ON SEVEN
PRESCRIBED FIRES OF BLODGETT
FORCE RESEARCH STATION. TWO
THREE DAYS LATER ONE OF THEM
REKINDLED WE HAVE ESCAPED. THE
FOR SERVER GEORGETOWN RANGER
DISTRICT CAME IN AS A PRESS
THAT FILE WORSE BECAUSE WE HAVE
A CONTINGENCY PLAN. SO THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF EVENTS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN. I JUST THINK
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT AS
WE GO FOR WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THAT TO. REALLY GET TO STYMIE
THE WHOLE PROGRAM OUT THE GATE.
AS WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
PROBLEMS I GUARANTEE IT. WHAT
AUSTRALIA A- AREA OF THE I. OF
THE WORD. WITH THE LARGEST
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROGRAM IN THE
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE. HAS A
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE JUST LIKE
US. RICH NEED JACK IS THE HEAD
OF THE PRESCRIBER PROGRAM YOU
WORKED THERE FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS. THEY BROUGHT UP THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR
ROUND PERTH. HE CAME OVER HERE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO I TOOK HIM UP
AND DOWN THE STATEMENT WITH A
BUNCH OF MANAGERS. HE HAD SOME
OBSERVATIONS- IN QUOTES WE
BEGIN WITH THE MOST DIFFICULT
FUEL LOADED LANDSCAPES. ARE
LANDSCAPE ARE IN TOP CONDITION
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MOSAIC
OF FUEL TO BASE WITH WORK WITH.
AS THEY DO SAY IN WESTERN
AUSTRALIAAND ALSO IN FLORIDA.
SO WE BEGIN AT A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION FROM A LANDSCAPE
PERSPECTIVE. WE ALSO HAVE THE
LOWEST EXPERIENCE AND POLITICAL
SUPPORT THERE'S ANOTHER QUOTE
FROM RICK. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
BRING ALONG BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
ALSO INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT AS
WE HAVE. GROWING PAINS THIS IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO REALLY
ADDRESS. WE CAN USE THE
WILDFIRES THAT HAVE HAPPENED
THE LAST FEW YEARS AS THE MOST
SAY IT. IS NOT THE MOSAIC WE
REALLY WOULD LIKE. BUT WE
CERTAINLY CAN USE THEM TO
ACTUALLY BUILD A PROGRAM ON. I
GAVE A TALK ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO
TO THE NAPA COUNTY VINEYARD
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO. INTERESTED IN ALSO TRYING
TO. REDUCE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
FROM SMOKE TAINT AND OTHER
THINGS. SIERRA NEVADA NORTH
COAST. SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WE GOT
A MOSAIC WE CAN USE.
INTERAGENCY COOPERATION WILL BE
KEY INDIGENOUS BURNING I THINK
IS REALLY AS I'VE HEARD ALREADY
IS A KEY POINT. IN JUST BURNING
COULD BE A- BUNCH OF INNOVATION
IF THE TRIBES CHOSE TO WORK
WITH US IT'S UP TO THEM. BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY AND TO JUST
BRING COULD BE A KEY UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. I SAY ONE TO
TWO DECADES WE GOT ONE TO TWO
DECADES TO REALLY CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY WE DON'T DO THAT.
I'M AFRAID THE WILD LANDS ARE
GONNA CHANGE RIGHT IN FRONT OF
OUR EYES. I'M OPTIMISTIC. BUT
WE HAVE TO MOVE DECISIVELY.
WITHOUT ALL IN MY- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AFTER THE OTHER
PANELISTS SPEAK. NEXT WE. HAVE
DOCTOR PRETTY. THANK YOU I
MIGHT. REYES GO. WE ARE
CHECKING OUT RIGHT NOW GETTING
LOADED. OKAY OKAY OKAY. WHILE
THEY'RE DOING THAT I JUST LIKE
TO THE KNOWLEDGE MY OUR
COLLEAGUE AL MURATSUCHI WHO I
BELIEVE HAS JOINED US OF.
VIRTUAL. OKAY THE SLIDES ARE
UPLOADED. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
WELL THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES PERSIST
PRESCRIBED BURNS- IF WE COULD
GO TO THE SECOND SIDE PLEASE.
AN OBVIOUS CONCERN WITH ANY
TYPE OF FIRE SMOKE INHALATION.
AND HERE IN THE SIDE WE SEE
THAT WILDFIRE SMOKE PLUMES
CONTEST WELL THE CONFLICT
PRIMARILY A FEW KEY POINTS FIVE
AND THESE CLAIMS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO STAY ALOFT AND TRAVEL
DISTANCES. TO COMPARISON TO THE
LARGER PIECES OF ASH THAT
SETTLE TO THE GROUND AND DON'T
TRAVEL THAT'S- HOWEVER. YOU CAN
ON THE PALM THE WHETHER THE PM
TWO POINT FIVE CLOUT POLLUTION
MOVED DOWNWARD IN BETA READING
SPACE. AND WE KNOW ESPECIALLY
HIGH- MORE RECENTLY THE
WILDFIRE SMOKE CAN TRAVEL LARGE
DISTANCES AND INCREASE THE RISK
OF HEALTH AND TAX- WENDY
PARTICULATE MATTER IS INHALED
THE SIZE DETERMINES HOW FAR
IT'S GOING TO GO DOWN YOUR
RESPIRATORY TRACT. THE LARGER
PM TEN ONLY TRAVELS PART WAY
DOWN. BUT THE PM TWO POINT FIVE
AND EVEN SMALLER PARTICLES CAN
TRAVEL ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
LEVEL DALY L. C. A LISTED IS AT
THE BASE OF YOUR LONG. AND
CROSS INTO YOUR CIRCULATION.
RIGHT PLEASE. ON A GLOBAL SCALE
THE POLICE SHOULD BE POPULATION
HEALTH RISK FROM WILDFIRES CAN
RANGE FROM SUBCLINICAL IMPACT-
WITH NO OBVIOUS SYMPTOMS TO
DEATH. AND B. WILDFIRE AND
HEALTH LITERATURE MOST
CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT THERE
WILL BE AN INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA RELATED EVENTS AFTER
WILDFIRE SMOKE EXPOSURE- THIS
IS MAKE CONSISTENTLY
DEMONSTRATED THROUGHOUT THE
GLOBE- THERE'S ALSO INCREASES
AND OTHER RESPIRATORY OUTCOMES
LIKE INCREASES IN OUR EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR COPD AND
RESPIRATORY INFECTIONS.
POSITION VISITS AND ASSOCIATED
MEDICATION USE. IN ADDITION
THERE'S INCREASES IN
CARDIOVASCULAR. SUCH AS HEART
ATTACKS A RADIUS. RT ACT REST
AND EVEN THERE ARE A LOT
OUTCOME SUCH AS SMOKE FIRST
STROKE WHEN WE WHILE TRY SMOKE
IN THE EVENT ARE DEPENDENT ON
THE LAW OF TIME THE SMOKE
INHALE AND THE- OF THE SMOKE.
IN ADDITION TO THE AGE IN THE
PRE EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS
OF AN INDIVIDUAL. SO THE
INTENSITY INTO OF THIS YEAR'S
WILDFIRE BUMPER. AND THERE'S
ACTIVE RESEARCH IN TRYING TO
DETERMINE. THE HEALTH IMPACTS
THAT IT WILL HAPPEN EVERYONE-
ON EVERYONE. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
WHY DID THAT THE IMPACT OF PM
TWO POINT FIVE ACTUALLY COMES
FROM THE AIR CARE THE TRAILER
BACK LET ME JUST WILDFIRE I'M
SORRY DOT EIGHTY OF WILD
DOCTORS DO YOU HAVE A- I JUST
pOF FEEDBACK DO YOU HAVE A
MONITOR THAT'S PLAYING THIS I
CAN HEAR THAT ALSO OKAY. NO I
DON'T OKAY- COLLEGE AND. WE
JUST TRIED CLOSING MY- BUT MAKE
HER CLOSING MY BROWSER IN CASE.
SECOND OKAY LET'S SEE IF THAT
PROVES THAT. SO FROM THE AIR
POLLUTION- LITERATURE WE KNOW
THAT PM TWO POINT FIVE IS
EXTREMELY DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
HEALTH AND ITS ROLE BUT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUTTHE WILDFIRES
BECAUSE OVER 80% OF WILDFIRE
SMOKE IS TYPICALLY PM TWO POINT
FIVE. ONCE THE DINNER THE
ENTERS THE BODY. AND CROSSES IT
AT THE LEVEL BE. OF THE LONG IT
CAN TRAVEL THROUGHOUT BECAUSE
WIDESPREAD IMPACT. SO NOT ONLY
CAN THERE BE RESPIRATORY
CARDIOVASCULAR EVENTS LIKE WE
MENTIONED BUT ALSO- CANCER. AND
ASSOCIATE IMMUNE SYSTEM
DYSFUNCTION IS ASSOCIATED. WITH
EXPOSURE TO PM TWO POINT FIVE
THE ACTUAL BIOLOGY OF THE
POLLUTION EXPOSURE TO IT'S AN
ACTIVE INVESTIGATION. IF WE
COULD GO TO FLIGHT FIVE. FOR
EXAMPLE- GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF PRESCRIBED BURNING A
WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT WE WANTED
TO EXAMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE DIFFERENTIAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES BETWEEN A
PRESCRIBED FIRE VERSIONS OF
WILDFIRE. AND WE HAD ALREADY
COLLECTED SAMPLE BLOOD SAMPLES
FROM CHILDREN LIVING IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND- RETROSPECTIVELY
WE LOOK TO SEE WHETHER SUBJECT-
HAD BEEN EXPOSED TO EITHER A
WILDFIRE OR PRESCRIBED BURNS
ARE. AT LEAST THREE MONTHS
PRIOR TO THE BLOOD DRAW- AND
THE FIRE TO FIRES ARE ABOUT THE
SAME SIZE AND DURATION. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO WHEN WE LOOKED
AT WHAT CHILDREN FIT THE-
CATEGORY WE FOUND THAT THERE
ABOUT THIRTY TO SIXTY EIGHT
YEAR OLDS THAT HAD BEEN EXPOSED
HER SURGERY BURN IN YOUR SO
MANY. AND ABOUT THIRTY SIX
CHILDREN EXPOSED TO WILDFIRE OF
ABOUT THE SAME SIZE AND THEN-
DURATION. THE FIRE SERVICE
WHERE ABOUT SEVENTY MILES AWAY-
THERE WAS ALSO A CONTROL GROUP
FROM THE BAY AREA THE HADN'T
THEY EXPOSED TO ANYTHING- SMOKE
AT ALL. AND WE- ON THE RIGHT
YOU CAN SEE THE GRAFT WE
ANALYZED THE LEVEL OF. PM TWO
POINT FIVE BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER THE PRESCRIBED BURNS IN
THE WILDFIRES- USING SATELLITE
MONITORS- ENTRANCE NO ITSELF.
AND THEN WE DISTRICTS WEIGHTED
THE EXPOSURE BASED ON WHERE THE
PARTICIPANT LIVES. THE GREAT
SHOWS THE AVERAGE AMOUNT PM
POINT. EITHER DURING THE FIRST
ANOTHER WILD. AND AS YOU CAN
SEE THE WILDFIRE PRESUMABLY
GENERATED MORE POLLUTION THAN
THE PRESCRIBED BURN. I SAY
PRESUMABLY BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
SITE MINDERS CAN'T DISCRIMINATE
THE SOURCE OF THE POLLUTION SO
THE SOURCE OF PM TWO POINT FIVE
BUT THE PATTERN- SHOULD THE
TIMING OF THE FIRES THEMSELVES.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WHEN
ANALYZING THE BLOOD WE FOUND
THAT DAY THE EXPOSURE TO THE
WILDFIRE- WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
MORE NEW DYSFUNCTION THAN THOSE
EXPOSED TO EITHER THE
PRESCRIBED BURNS OR- THE
CONTROL GROUP WHICH WERE NOT
EXPOSED TO FIRE AT ALL. THESE
FINDINGS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
OUR FINDINGS FROM AIR POLLUTION
STUDIES. AND IT'S ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH ANOTHER STUDY
WHERE WE LOOKED AT TEENAGERS
FROM PRESS NOW EXPOSED TO A
WILD FIRE- AGAIN IN YOSEMITE
AND WE WERE ABLE TO SEE-
INCREASES AND TWO TYPES OF
INFLAMMATORY MARKERS IN THE
BLOOD- AFTER EXPOSURE- AND BOTH
OF THESE INFLAMMATORY
BIOMARKERS HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED
WITH POLLUTION EXPOSURE PRIOR.
SO WE KNOW THAT SMOKE IMPACTS
THE IMMUNE SYSTEM EVEN IN
CHILDREN. AND THAT THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES ARE STILL NOT
FULLY UNDERSTOOD- WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW FOR THESE CHILDREN
OR TEENAGERS IN THE FUTURE HOW
THIS WILL IMPACT FOR EXAMPLE-
THERE ARE RISKS FOR ADULT
CHRONIC DISEASE. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. CERTIFIED CHOSEN DATA
HARMON JAFFE IN WHICH THEY
COMPARED THE SIZE IN THE
MANICHEAN TWO POINT FIVE
GENERATED FROM ALL FROM
WILDFIRES PERSIST PRESCRIBED
BURNS IN DIFFERENT STATES. AND
AS YOU CAN SEE- RESPECT THE
AREA BURNED. THERE WAS MORE PM
TWO POINT FIVE WHETHER MEASURED
BY A MONTH OR DALY- YEAH
DURING- WILDFIRE STAND
PRESCRIBED BURNS. AND THIS IS
JUST TO- TISSUE THAT WHAT WE
FOUND IN OUR VERY SMALL- STUDY
IS CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF THE
LITERATURE. SO ALTHOUGH THE
AREAS BURNED BY THE PRESCRIBED
FIRES WERE COMPARED BOTH TO THE
WILD FIRE AREAS BURNED IN THE
WEST THE PM TWO POINT FOUR FIVE
EMISSIONS LOWER. ON THE AUTHORS
FEEL THE DIFFERENCES DUE TO
BOTH THE FIELD IN THE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICE THE
SIMPSONS. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE THE
PROFESSOR COMING UP PASS SOME
MINUTES IF YOU CAN TRY TO DO
THIS QUICKLY AND WRAP IT UP.
THANK YOU. OKAY HOW DO I GET
THIS VERY QUICKLY- WE CAN.
PRESCRIBE SIZE ABOUT FIRES
THERE'S SEVERAL DIFFERENT.
FIRST THE COMPOSITION OF THE
POLLUTION- FOR EXAMPLE PM TWO
POINT FIVE DEPENDS ON THE
SOURCE OF WHAT'S BEING BURNED.
SO THAT PAKISTAN WHILE LIBERTY
MAY BE VERY WELL LEFT TOXIC TO
THE HEALTH. AND AN OUT OF
CONTROL WILDFIRE THAT ACTUALLY
BURNING ACCOUNT OF BURNING UP
CLEANING PRODUCTS AND MULTI
PLASTICS. THAT ARE- THERE'S
OBVIOUS DISTANCES AND THE- D.
DEFICIT THAT'S NOT TRAVELS FOR
PRESCRIBERS OF THOSE WILDFIRES
THE TIMING AND STRATEGY- CURLY
IS DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE TWO
TYPES. I THEN THE AN INNER IS
THE FACT THE- FIRES IT'S
POSSIBLE TO PROACTIVELY PLAN
AND MINIMIZE EXPOSURE TO ANY-
POPULATIONS IN ANY
INCONVENIENCE TO THE PUBLIC. SO
MY LAST SLIDE IS THE SUMMARY
SLIDE. IN SUMMARY WILDFIRE
SMOKE- INDEED MANY TOXINS THAT
PREDOMINATES PM TWO POINT FIVE
WE KNOW THAT PM TWO POINT FIVE
MISTER SHADED WITH INCREASED
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY- AND
WE'RE FINDING OUT MORE MORE- AS
WE DO MORE WILDFIRE RESEARCH-
AND IN OUR STUDY WE EVEN SHOW
THE NEW CHILDREN IT CAN BE MORE
DETRIMENTAL TO. YOUR HEALTH-
WILDFIRES CANDY THEN TOOK A
SCRIBE BURKE- KEVIN SUMMARY
PRESCRIBED BURNS IN AND- AND
YOU KNOW BASED ON OUR RESEARCH.
HAS MANY ADVANTAGES OVER- THE-
ALTERNATIVE TO THE COMPLEX OF
WILDFIRES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL COME BACK TO THE
QUESTIONS AFTER THE NEXT A
PANELIST. OKAY AND LEADING
QUINN DAVIDSON WILL BE.
BRINGING THIS PANEL HOME. WE
CAN YOU WELL. OKAY GREAT WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
TODAY MY NAME'S LAINNYA QUINN
DAVIDSON AND I AM THE AREA
FIRED VISOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION UP IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBED
FIRE COUNCIL AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATED WHAT SCOTT HAD TO
SAY I THINK HE DID A GREAT JOB
SETTING UP THE HISTORICAL
CONTEXT OR AT LEAST THE MORE
RECENT HISTORICAL CONTEXT FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE MASSIVE- SCALE OF THE
NEED FOR MORE PRESCRIBED FIRE
ON OUR LANDSCAPES I ALSO REALLY
LIKE TO BE SAID ABOUT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE YEAR IF
YOU'RE AROUND NEED FOR WORK
FORCE ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
REALLY BE FOCUSED ON I AM GOING
TO USE MY TIME TO SPEAK A
LITTLE MORE SPECIFICALLY TO
SOME OF THE BARRIERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I SEE WITH
REGARD TO COMMUNITY BASED-
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND PRIVATE
LANDS ISSUES. AND I GUESS I
WANT TO START OFF JUST BY
TALKING ABOUT THE HUGE
GROUNDSWELL OF INTEREST AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE AT THE
COMMUNITY SCALE THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING IN RECENT YEARS IT'S
REALLY KIND OF UNPRECEDENTED
FOR RECENT DECADES THREE YEARS
AGO WHEN WE STARTED THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY A COMMUNITY
COOPERATIVE FOR PRESCRIBED
FIRE- WE WERETHE FIRST OF OUR
KIND IN THE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE WESTERN U. S. AND-
YOU KNOW WE THERE AT THAT TIME
THERE WERE SOME NGOS- SOME
TRIBES AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
WERE DOING SOME BURNING BUT
REALLY PRESCRIBED FIRE FOR A
LONG TIME HAD BEEN. OWNED BY
FEDERAL AND STATE AGENCIES AND
THERE HADN'T BEEN A LOT OF
SPACE FOR COMMUNITIES FOR
TRIBES- AND FOR PRIVATE FOLKS
TO HAVE A YOU KNOW HAVE A KEY
ROLE IN PRESCRIBED FIRE NOT
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM I'M JUST
THREE YEARS LATER NOW THERE ARE
TWELVE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
BASED PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION STYLE GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE- WE HAVE THESE TYPES
OF GROUPS FORMED UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA FROM HUMBLE AND
SISKIYOU COUNTIES ALLTHE WAY
DOWN TO PHYLLIS OBISPO AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES. AND
FROM CINEMA AND MENDOCINO ALL
THE WAY TO PLUMAS AND SEQUOIA
LAW OF OTHER. IN BETWEEN SO
THERE'S JUST A HUGE. GRANTS
WHAT GROUNDS FULL OF INTEREST
IN THIS KIND OF WORK. AND
TRIBES ARE ALSO REINVIGORATING
THEIR CULTURAL PRACTICES AND
THEIR PRESCRIBED FIRE PROGRAMS
WHICH WE'LL HEAR ABOUT FROM
BILL AND MARGOT A LITTLE LATER
IN THIS HEARING. AND LANDOWNERS
FOR A WIDE VARIETY OF
BACKGROUNDS INCLUDING RANCHERS
AND TIMBER LAND OWNERS AND BACK
TO THE LANDERS AND EVEN
RESIDENTS IN WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AREAS. ARE REALLY
DEMANDING THAT PRESCRIBED FIRE
BE BROUGHT BACK INTO THEIR TOOL
BOX. SO I THINK WE'RE SEEING
THAT THE TIME HAS COME FOR
ACTION AND COMMITMENT AT THE
STATE LEVEL ON THIS ISSUE. AND
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO ENABLE AND EMPOWER
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBES AND- AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO GET MORE
INVOLVED AND TO NOT ONLY BE
PARTNERS BUT REALLY TO BE
LEADERS IN THIS WORK. SO THAT'S
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
PROLIFERATE PRESCRIBED FIRE THE
SCALE THAT'S ACTUALLY.
MEANINGFUL AND- AND CAN RESTORE
OUR ECOLOGICAL AND CULTURAL
VALUES. THEN WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY AND
REALLY POUR SOME ENERGY INTO
IT. AND IF WE LOOK AT THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY PLACES
LIKE FLORIDA AND GEORGIA- WE
SEE THAT THEY HAVE CERTIFIED
BURNER PROGRAMS AND GROSS
NEGLIGENCE LIABILITY LAWS. AND
SOME WESTERN STATES LIKE
WASHINGTON AND COLORADO HAVE
ALSO MORE RECENTLY ADOPTED-
DIFFERENT NEGLIGENCE STANDARDS
THAT GO ALONG WITH CERTIFIED
BURNER PROGRAMS. AND IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE IN CALIFORNIA
PASSED SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY
WHICH MANDATED THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A STATE CERTIFIED BURN BOSS
PROGRAM HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS WAS A REALLY BIG DEAL- I
SERVED ON THE CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE FOR THAT
PROGRAM. AND I'M PRETTY PLEASED
WITH THE LEVEL OF RIGOR AND THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THAT WE
TOOK IN OUR PROGRAM TO
PRESCRIBED FIRE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION- IT WILL ROLL
OUT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PROBABLY IN MID SPRING. NOW THE
STATE CERTIFIED BURN BOSS
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
IS REALLY INTENDED FOR
EXPERIENCED PRESCRIBED FIRE
PRACTITIONERS IT'S NOT ENTRY
LEVEL IT'S GOING TO BE A
RIGOROUS. THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED
ON- ON PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PLAN AND LEAD
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS.
INCLUDING FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL. BURN BOSSES WHO HAVE
RETIRED BUT STILL WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS WORK AND BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION- COMMUNITY
AND TRIBAL LEADERS LIKE ME AND
BILL AND MARGOT AND PROBABLY
OTHERS. INVOLVED IN THIS PANEL-
WHO WISH TO BUILD LOCAL
CAPACITY IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS FOR HIM
THIS COULD BE A NEW NICHE. AS
WELL AS JUST PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
WHO WANT TO FURTHER THEIR OWN
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS ON
THEIR LAND. NOW I REALLY WORRY
THAT THIS PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING IN THAT WE'RE
ROLLING OUT. DOES NOT CONFER
ENOUGH BENEFIT TO THE STATE
CERTIFIED BURN BOSSES- TO
INCENTIVIZE PARTICIPATION OR TO
EXPAND PRESCRIBED FIRE EFFORTS.
ON A MEANINGFUL SCALE- PER SB
TWELVE SIXTY BURN BOSSES WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SHARE
LIABILITY WITH CAL FIRE THROUGH
THE PERMIT PROCESS. I'M HOWEVER
THEY WILL NOT ENJOY A DIFFERENT
LIABILITY STANDARD LIKE THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER STATES.
AND THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO GET
INSURANCE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING I SEE THIS AS A
HUGE PROBLEM. PRESCRIBED FIRE
INSURANCE IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO
SECURE- BASICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
AND IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY A
PROBLEM FOR PRIVATE BURN BOSSES
AS WELL AS FOR ORGANIZATIONS
AND CONTRACTORS WHO ARE LOOKING
TO LEAVE THIS KIND OF WORK. SO
I SEE THESE TWO POINTS THE
LIABILITY PIECE IN THE
INSURANCE PIECE AS TOP
PRIORITIES FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE.
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IF WE
WANTTO SUPPORT EXPAND
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO ACTIVELY PURSUE A
GROSS NEGLIGENCE STANDARD FOR
STATE CERTIFIED BURN BOSSES-
SOMETHING THAT COULD. TIE RIGHT
INTO THE PROGRAM THAT E'RE
ROLLING OUT. AND WE SHOULD ALSO
DEVELOP A CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBED
FIRE INSURANCE CLAIM FUND- THIS
COULD BE MODELED AFTER THE FUN
THAT WAS DEVELOPED FOR THE
UTILITIES- WHERE YOU KNOW.
WHERE THERE'S- I FIND THAT
COVER EXCEPT LOS. FOR A
PRESCRIBED FIRE OVER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT THAT REALLY INCENTIVIZE
IS THE PRIVATE INSURERS TO
PROVIDE OPTIONS POLICY OPTIONS
FOR. PRIVATE BURN BOSSES AND
FOR ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
IMPLEMENTING THIS KIND OF WORK.
SO THOSE THOSE TWO PIECES I
THINK ARE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. THEY'RE ALSO
REGULATORY BARRIERS TO THE
EXPANDED USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND FOR STATE LETTER STATE
FUNDED PROJECTS THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT C.
QUOTE. I'M CAN RESULT IN REALLY
COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING
PLANNING PROCESS. THAT CAN
CREATE DELAYS AND PLANNING COST
CAN OFTEN EXCEED IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS SO. I BELIEVE THAT GIVEN
THE INTEGRAL AND NATURAL ROLE
OF FIRE ON CALIFORNIA'S
LANDSCAPES WE REALLY SHOULD BE
PURSUING SOME KIND OF EXEMPTION
FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE- THAT WOULD
BETTER STREAMLINE AND MAKE AND
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS FOR
TREATING THESE PROJECTS DONE.
AND LASTLY I'D LIKE TO MENTION
AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS IT WAS
GREAT O HEAR THE LAST
PRESENTER REALLY GET THAT AIR
QUALITY PERSPECTIVE ON
PRESCRIBED FIRE- YOU KNOW ASIDE
FROM KIND OF THE ATTAINMENT
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THERE ARE
SOME REAL ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLES TO PRESCRIBED FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA AROUND THE AIR
QUALITY PIECE. ONE PROBLEM IS
THE COST OF AIR QUALITY
PERMITS. IN THE NORTH COAST
UNIFIED AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT WHERE I WORK A THREE
HUNDRED ACRE PRESCRIBED BURN
WOULD COST TWELVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR A PERMIT.
PLUS SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR A
SMOKE MANAGEMENT PLAN- THOSE
COSTS ARE YOU KNOW A DEAL
BREAKER FOR MOST FOLKS ARE
TRYING TO DO THIS PUBLIC
BENEFIT WORK. MEANWHILE AIR
QUALITY PERMITS IN OUR
NEIGHBORING SISKIYOU COUNTY ARE
FREE. SO THE COSTA REALLY
INEQUITABLE ACROSS THE STREET
ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS THE AIR
DISTRICTS MAY REPRESENT A MAJOR
BURDEN FOR LANDOWNERS AND FOR
AGENCIES ALIKE WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO THIS GOOD WORK- I REALLY
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW PUBLIC
BENEFIT WORK LIKE THIS SHOULD
NOT COST US A BUNCH OF MONEY. I
AM IT'S ALSO CLEAR THAT SOME
ERROR DISTRICTS ARE
UNDERSTAFFED AND OVERWHELMED
WITH THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT'S
COMING OUT THEM FROM THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE SIDE. AND
THEY'RE UNABLE TO KEEP UP WITH
THE PERMITTING AND THE SMOKE
MANAGEMENT PLANNING PROCESS IN
A TIMELY FASHION. PERMIT
RENEWAL AND SOME A COMMENCEMENT
IN SOME. TAKE WEEKS MONTHS AND
REALLY DELAY OUR WORK AND FORCE
US TO MISS IMPORTANT WINDOWS.
SO I SEE THESE ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES ON THE AIR QUALITY
SITE IS PRETTY LOW HANGING
FRUIT. AND SOMETHING WE COULD
WE COULD ADDRESS AT THE STATE
LEVEL. SO I GUESS IN CLOSING I
JUST REALLY LIKE TO APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND I
REALLY HOPE WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS IMPORTANT
TIME THAT WE'RE AND- WE HAVE
SOCIAL LICENSE WE HAVE
MOMENTUM. WE HAVE COMMUNITY
EXCITEMENT AROUND PRESCRIBED
FIRE. AND WE REALLY NEED TO
HARNESS THAT ENERGY AND DO SOME
GOOD THINGS TO ENABLE MORE
WORK. AND I'D REALLY LIKE US TO
KEEP A FOCUS ON THE TRIBAL
PEACE AND ON THE COMMUNITY
PEACE AND- YOU KNOW THESE ARE
THE REAL STEWARDS OF THE LAND
LET'S EMPOWER THEM TO HAVE AN
ACTIVE ROLE. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
YOU ACTUALLY- ANSWERED MOST OF
MY QUESTIONS YOU. YOUR
PRESENTATION WAS VERY VERY
THOROUGH BUT I WILL ASK YOU IN
THIS IS- TO MRS QUINN DAVIS
AND- WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
BIGGEST BARRIER. IF I CAN GIVE
YOU WHAT IF YOU CAN JUST TELL
ME WHAT YOU THINK THE BIGGEST
BARRIER IS TO INTRODUCING MORE-
PRESCRIBE BURNS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU MENTIONED A BUNCH OF
BARRIERS BUT WHAT IF YOU WERE
GONNA SAY YOUR TOP THREE. LIST
WILL APPOINT A LOT LIKE THE P.
I MIGHT THREE. WELL DO THINK
THOSE FIRST TWO IN A REALLY
REALLY IN A REAL WAY I DO THINK
THAT LIABILITY PIECE AND THOSE
INSURANCE PIECES ARE OUR- TOP
TWO FOR WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS AS FAR AS
GETTING MORE WORK DONE. AND
THEN WHAT I ALWAYS SAY IS I
REALLY DO THINK THAT ONE OF THE
TOP AREAS WERE DEALING WITH IN
THE WEST AND NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA. IS CULTURAL AND
IT'S AROUND THIS OWNERSHIP
ISSUE AND- AND KIND OF MAKING
ROOM FOR- NON FIRE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE A ROLE IN IN
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND- TO REALLY
RECONNECT PEOPLE WITH THEIR
LANDSCAPE THROUGH THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE SO. I THINK WE
NEED TO QUESTION OUR OUR
CULTURAL NORMS AROUND. HOW WE
THINK OF. PRESCRIBED FIRE AND
WHO GETS TO BE INVOLVED IN WHO
GETS TO LEAD. SO WOULD YOU
SUGGEST THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO. TRY TO INCORPORATE MORE.
YOU KNOW ORDINARY LANDOWNERS
LET'S SAY- JUST LANDOWNERS INTO
THE PROCESS. WOULD YOU THEN-
ENVY HOW WOULD YOU HOW WOULD
YOU ENVISION DOING THAT SAFELY.
WOULD YOU HAVE TO CERTIFY THEM
SOMEHOW OR TRY USING. THEM
SORRY NO GO AHEAD GO AHEAD.
IT'S YEAH IT'S- YOU KNOW I WORK
IN. LOOKS AND SO BIG OF MY- IS
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND
TRAINING. AND I DO SEE TRAINING
AS A BIG PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE
AND IF WE HAVE FUNDING TO
DIRECT TOWARDS MORE TRAINING I
THINK THAT'S GREAT WE SAW THAT
IN THE WIDE IN BILL THAT WAS
INTRODUCED FEDERALLY-
PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAINING
EXCHANGES. WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE TRAINING
FOR AVERAGE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
GET INVOLVED IN THIS AND IT'S
REALLY ABOUT MAKING SPACE FOR
THEM AND PROVIDING FUNDING.
TWELVE SIXTY- I THINK YOU WOULD
REFER TO THAT BILL IN YOUR
PRESENTATION I WILL HOW WOULD
YOU HOW WOULD YOU GET OLD ON
THAT WHAT WOULD YOU DO NOW TO
KIND OF. CONTINUE TO WORK IN
THAT BILL IF YOU WERE GOING TO
INTRODUCE SOMETHING TO- LET'S
SAY MAKE IT EVE EASIER TO
PRESCRIBE FIRE LEGISLATIVELY
BESIDES THE FUNDING PIECE IN
THE TRAINING PIECE. THE FUNDING
HE'S IN THE TRAINING. YEAH WELL
NOT TO SOUND LIKE A BROKEN BUT
I DO THINK THAT THE NEGLIGENCE
PIECE AND THE INSURANCE PIECE
ARE THE NATURAL FOLLOW UP TO SB
TWELVE SIXTY. SB TWELVE SIXTY
CREATED THE STATE CERTIFIED
BURN BOSS PROGRAM WHICH IS
HUGELY IMPORTANT AND MONUMENTAL
REALLY FOR CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S
MISSING THOSE KEY PIECES AND I
DO WORRY IT'LL FALL FLAT
WITHOUT THOSE THOSE FOLLOW UP-
SUPPORTIVE PIECES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M I'M SURE OTHER
PANEL OTHER MEMBERS MIGHT HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT I'M
GOING I'M TURN TO DOCTOR
STEVENS FOR A MOMENT FOR QUITE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS. DOCTOR
STEVENS IF YOU'RE THERE- I CAN
HEAR YOU. GOT THINK. I'M I'M
JUST GOING TO VERY QUICKLY IF
YOU CAN THE TELL US ABOUT THE
FLORIDA LIABILITY PROGRAM AND
JUST IN A NUTSHELL. I HOW
THAT'S WORKING AND HOW YOU
WOULD NOT MAKE THAT WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. NO I WOULD AGREE
WITH US ON LINKEDIN ABOUT HOW
THIS IS BEING SO CRITICAL IN.
FLORIDA THEIR NEGLIGENCE LONGER
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN
OURS AND UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT
A LAWYER SO I CAN'T SPEAK
EXACTLY WHAT THIS IDEA OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE IN FLORIDA. IS IT IS
THE THRESHOLD THAT MEANS IF YOU
ACTUALLY. DO YOUR PRESCRIBED
FIRE YOU CONDUCTED TO THE BEST
OF YOUR ABILITY EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE IS CORRECT AS BEST
AS POSSIBLE. YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM. THEN THE STATE
ACTUALLY STEPS IN AND THEY
BASICALLY WILL COVER LIABILITY
WITH SOME PRIVATE INSURANCE. AS
WELL FROM THE PRESCRIBERS.
FIRELIGHT POINTED TO TWO. EIGHT
IT WAS. ON STATE OF FLORIDA
LAND THAT ACTUALLY WAS DONE BY
A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR THE
CONTRACTOR HAD INSURANCE. THAT
WAS PART OF THE USE OF THE-
TRYING TO GET THOSE PEOPLE HOLD
A THIRTY SIX PEOPLE. IT TURNED
OUT THAT THE HOUSES WERE BURNED
IN A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY. AND
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE ANOTHER
INTERESTING OR SAD ISSUE
BECAUSE THAT COMMUNITY HADN'T
HAD AS MUCH. INVESTMENT IN
TRYING TO MAKE IT MORE FIRE
WIDER FIRE SAFETY WAS MORE
VULNERABLE SURE THERE'S AN
EQUITY ISSUE THERE. SO I WOULD
SAY THAT. YEAH IDEA OF TRYING
TO GET SOME SORT OF
INSTITUTIONAL ABILITY. FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE RELEASED THE
BACKING OF THE STATE AS LONG AS
THEY DO THEIR WORK AS THEY SAY.
THEY DON'TDO SOMETHING
FOOLISH. OKAY LET ME ASK YOU I
LIVE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE
HAVE SOME FOR SOME FOREST BUT
THEY'RE DIFFERENT FARCE THAN
WHAT WE NORMALLY THINK OF
PRESCRIBED FIRES. HOW WOULD
THIS WORK OR WOULDN'T WORK AND
CHAPARRAL AREAS AND IN AREAS
THAT ARE GRASSLAND AREAS- OR IN
SOME OF OUR URBAN- WILDLIFE
AREAS LET'S SAY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. IS THIS STILL IS
SOMETHING. WE SHOULD BE
PURSUING OR HER HOW WOULD LOOK
DIFFERENT. NO I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU'RE UP TO.
RIGHT CHAPARRAL REALLY IS IT A
DAY. PLACE IT IS THAT MORE TO.
BECAUSE IT'S A SYSTEM THAT
BURKE WITH HIGH SEVERITY HIGH
POINTS EVERY FEW DECADES OR
SOMETIMES EVEN EVERY TEN YEARS.
I THINK HERE YOU GET. YEP BE
MORE STRATEGIC. YOU KNOW L. A.
COUNTY FIRE OTHERS VENTURA
COUNTY FIRE DONE SOME REALLY
GOOD WORK OF KIND OF. WONDERING
WHERE IT IN THIS LANDSCAPE OF
PEOPLE AND VEGETATION AND
CHAPARRAL- WE DO SOME WORK TO.
REALLY SET SOMETHING UP TO ONE
OF FIRE DOES HAPPEN WE CAN USE
THAT AS AN ANCHOR USE THAT AS A
WAY TO MAYBE KEEP PEOPLE SAFER.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY IN THE
CHAPARRAL AREA YOU'RE GOING TO
LOOK REALLY STRATEGICALLY
WORKING WITH SUPPRESSION FOLKS.
AND THEN THREE CONDITIONS SOME
AREAS THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
THINK YOU CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
THAT LANDSCAPE. AND IT'S STILL
SOME OF THE DOES PERTAIN TO
THAT. BUT IT'S GONNA BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE NUANCED A
LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING. SO
YOU CAN STILL DO THE PRESCRIBED
BURNS IN THOSE AREAS YOU JUST
HAVE TO. ALTER HOW YOU DO THEM.
YOU CAN'T I'VE GOT A- 35% FIRES
SHOPPERS MICHAEL ONE THING THAT
TAX. I'M BEEN A FAN AND YOU CAN
DO THESE AND WHEN. YOU CAN DO
THE LITERALLY WHENEVER ELSE ON.
BURNED GRASS IS STILL GREEN
YOUR BASE. GOT HIGH BUDGETARY.
OF COURSE A LOT OF PLACES
THOUGHT TO CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
OUR- TO FREQUENTLY. SANTA
MONICA. AND OTHER AREAS WHERE
WE SEEN STRESSED IMPOSED BY
WILDFIRE BURNING TO FREQUENTLY.
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY GOING TO
BE A- COMPLIMENT TO TRY TO.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS IS
WITH. ONE OF IMPORTANCE. TO
ALLOW SUPPRESSION TO ACTUALLY
WORK MORE EFFECTIVELY KEEP
PEOPLE AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU IN AUGUST WE SAW SOME
PRETTY INTENSE LIGHTNING STORMS
AND I'M WONDERING IF THOSE ARE
GOING TO. KIND OF CONTINUE. IN
SORT OF THIS IS THE SORT OF
ABNORMAL WAY AND WHETHER THAT
CHANGES ANY OF THIS EQUATION.
OR AND HOW WE PRIORITIZE. THE
BURNS. KNOW YOUR ACTUAL RIGHT
HERE WE HAD REALLY AND I AND-
LA. STORM IN AUGUST THIS YEAR
IT WAS UP. SYSTEM OF KIND OF UP
SUBTROPICAL SYSTEM IN THE
EQUATOR IT CAME UP TO COME TO
CAL. PASSED ALONG BY LOW
PRESSURE SYSTEM. THE BULLS I
WAS THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE HAD LIGHTNING-
BUST IN CALIFORNIA. THE LAST
THING WE JUNE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THE ONE BEFORE THAT WAS
IN THE LATE SUMMER OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. WE SEEM TO GET
THEM AT LEAST HAS BEEN LAST
HISTORY EVERY TEN TO FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS OR SO. AND THIS
ONE WAS ONE OF THOSE. ONE OF
THE GRANDEST. I THINK. WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE RESEARCH ON
LIGHTNING WE EXPECT LIGHTNING
INCIDENTS INCREASE JUST BECAUSE
OF MORE ENERGY IN THE
ATMOSPHERE FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE MORE
LIGHTNING JUST IN GENERAL. BUT
I JUST I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
REALLY WE CAN'T SAY THAT WE
EXPECT TO HAVE MORE OF THESE
KIND OF STORMS THAT CAME ANAHIT
POSTAL CALIFORNIA SO SEVERELY.
ONE THING I WOULD SAY ABOUT
THAT STORM IT IT SHOWED YOU THE
VULNERABILITY EVER LANDSCAPES
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY LAKE COUNTY NAPA COUNTY.
SIERRA NEVADA IT IS SHOWS JUST
HOW BIG WOULD IF THIS ISSUE IS
JUST LIKE WHAT WORKS NEED JACK
SAID THAT. IT REALLY IS A
LANDSCAPE GLOBAL PROBLEM THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE WILL SEE
MORE LIGHTNING BUT WE'RE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO SEE AS
MANY. YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA GET A BUNCH OF. BIG
LIGHTNING BUS LIKE THE ONE WE
HAD AUGUST WE'RE GONNA GET HIM
AGAIN BUT HOPE PLACE FIFTEEN
YEARS. THANK YOU AND I'M GONNA
TURN TO DR PRETTY KEY. IF WE.
CAN GET HER BACK ON THE LINE.
AND HERE OKAY GREAT. SO I JUST
COUPLE. FOR YOU. YOU DID A
GREAT JOB OF. THE WILDFIRE.
POLLUTION THE PRESCRIBED BURN.
I'M WONDERING HOW THAT FIGURES
COMPARED TO JUST OTHER SOURCES
OF POLLUTION- ARE THEY DWARFED.
IS THE WILDFIRE. POLLUTION THAT
WE SAW FOR INSTANCE IS A DWARF
THE- YOU SHOULD NOT RECEIVE
FROM HIGHWAYS AND OTHER TYPES
OF POLLUTION- KIND OF HOW. HOW
DO WE JUDGE THE PRESCRIBED BURN
POLLUTION AGAINST OTHER.
SOURCES OF POLLUTION IN THE ACT
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. RIGHT SO
TYPICALLY WITH ESPECIALLY THE
WILD CARDS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING READ. DEBT LEVEL
POLLUTION MUCH HIGHER OBVIOUSLY
THAN THE PRESCRIBED BURN AND
EVEN YOU KNOW SEE. THE LARGER
LITERATURE THAT WE HAVE ON ON
ON AIR POLLUTION YOU KNOW FROM
TRAFFIC AND OTHER SOURCES OF
POLLUTION SO WHICH FAR EXCEEDS
THAT AND TO THE POINT THAT-
WE'RE ACTIVELY DOING RESEARCH
IN THAT AREA TO FIND OUT. WITH
THESE VERY LARGE INCREASES AND
PM TWO POINT FIVE FOR THE
LONGER DURATION CHILD THAT DOES
IMPACT HEALTH. WHAT ABOUT THE
PRESCRIBED. SARS WAS IT WHAT
ABOUT THE PRESCRIBED BURN FIRE
I ASSUME WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DATA A LITTLE BIT MORE
YEARS OF DOING THAT HOW DOES
THAT COMPARE TO THE- I MEAN I
WITH THE- THAT WE SAW ON LOS
ANGELES IN THE BAY AREA AND
SACRAMENTO. IT'S UNLIKE
ANYTHING THAT I'VE SEEN
CERTAINLY FOR THE AMOUNT OF
TIME- BUT WE'RE TYPICAL
PRESCRIBER AND I WAS SOON
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT LEVEL. OF
INTENSITY SO HOW DOES THAT-
POLLUTION COMPARED TO JUST YOUR
RUN OF THE MILL POLLUTION.
RIGHT SO THAT THAT THAT THE
POLLUTION LEVELS ARE MUCH
LOWER- AND CHART MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE STATE-
D. CONDUCTED YOU KNOW THEY LET
IT BURN SLOWER AND THEY LET
FEET POLLUTION DISSIPATE UP
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE SO YOU
DON'T GET THAT BIG BUILD UP.
ALL YOU KNOW CLIMATE POLLUTION
AND THEN BASS IMPACTING THE
SURROUNDING POPULATION- SO THE
B. IT MAKES SENSE THAT THEY'RE
SEVERE HEALTH IMPACTS FOR
PRESCRIBED BURNS BECAUSE-
SIMPLY BE. THE AMOUNT OF
POLLUTION IS SO MUCH LAST- WHAT
THE LEVEL OF PM TWO POINT FIVE
IN COMPARISON TO OTHER SOURCES.
THANKS IN GIVEN THAT DO YOU
THINK THAT OUR AIR REGULATORS
SHOULD BE CHANGING OR RE
EVALUATING. HOW THEY'RE
REGULATING PRESCRIBED FIRES IN
MY OPINION YES- BECAUSE-
THERE'S SO MANY ADVANTAGES. TO
HAVING THE PRESCRIBED BURNS-
ESPECIALLY WARMER CONSIDERING
OUR HEALTH- AND BE THE ABILITY
TO CONTROL THAT AND YOU KNOW IF
NEED THE MOST POPULATIONS OUT
OF THE AREA THAT'S REALLY
NECESSARY TO AVOID SMOKE
EXPOSURE- BUT THE PLANNING
ABILITY THE PRESCRIBED BURN.
OUT TO AVOID HEALTH IMPACTS
SEEMS TO BE- SUCH A HUGE FACTOR.
MAKING IT MUCH MORE DESIRABLE
MUCH LESS DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
OVERALL HEALTH. MY LAST
QUESTION I'LL ASK IT TO WHOEVER
WANTS TO ANSWER THAT GIVEN
THERE'S A FEDERAL WILDFIRE
PREVENTION BILL OR IF THERE IS
ONE NEXT YEAR WHAT SHOULD
CALIFORNIA ASKED TO BE IN IT
THAT MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH A
FEDERAL BILL. YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER THAT'S OKAY BUT IF
ANYONE IS COSTS. THIS IS GOT
MAYBE ALL THIS BILL A MOMENT
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORT ON
THE WILD URBAN. AS EIGHT
SEPARATE POINT I THINK THAT'S
GREAT. SOME BILLS KIND OF
FOCUSED MORE JUST ON THAT WHILE
OF LIFE ITSELF OTHERS MAY BE ON
THE WILD LAND I THINK THE ONE
THING WE REALLY NEED IS WE NEED
BOTH SIDES OF THAT COIN. WE CAN
WORK ON THE WILD LANDS WE CAN
DO SOME RESTORATION THERE WOULD
BE PRESCRIBED BURNING THAT CAN
REDUCE THE INTENSITY OF FIRE
THE SPAWNING POTENTIAL WILDFIRE
AND WE CAN ALSO WORK ON THE ONE
HUNDRED INTERFACE THAT'S
CRUCIAL. GET OUR HUMAN
COMMUNITIES BETTER PREPARE FOR
FIRE THAT IS CRUCIAL SO I WOULD
JUST SAY THE FEINSTEIN BILL
DOES THAT THE FEINSTEIN BILL
WORKS ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT
LINE THE WHILE INSIDE. AND ALSO
ON THE ON THE PRIVATE SIDE SO I
WOULD. ENCOURAGE THAT TYPE OF
EFFORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M I HAVE NO OTHER FOR THIS
PANEL THAT'S AND DOCTOR WOULD.
GREAT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CAESAR REALLY REALLY
INTERESTING AND AN IMPORTANT
PRESENTATION SO I WANNA SAY I
APPRECIATE THEM I WANT TO GO
FIRST TO- DOCTOR PER NICKI A
QUICK HOPE I SAID THAT RIGHT.
IF NOT I APOLOGIZE- YOUR- OKAY
THAT'S WE'RE OFF TO A GOOD
START THAT. YOUR YOUR IN YOUR
SUMMARY SLIDE WHICH I'M LOOKING
AT NOW YOU YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW YOUR STUDIES OF THAT
ART THE SHOW THEIR EXPOSURE
WILDFIRES MORE DETRIMENTAL TO
HEALTH- THAN A PRESCRIBED BURN
IN CHILDREN- NOW. I ASSUME ALL
RIGHT MAYBE I SHOULD I ACTUALLY
I'M AWARE THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME OTHER STUDIES THAT ARE
LOOKING AT A PM TWO POINT FIVE
RELEASES. IN THE IN OTHER AREAS
THAT- AND HOW THAT MIGHT AFFECT
OTHER PEOPLE LIKE LIKE LIKE
OLDER PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE OR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE- ALREADY
COMPROMISED- RESPIRATORY
SYSTEMS- IS THAT WHAT WORK
LIKELY ARE YOU AWARE THAT WORK
IS OUT LIKELY TO SHOW. ANYTHING
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN CHILDREN I AM
CURIOUS BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT OF
A LOT OF OLDER PEOPLE WHO WHO
MAY HAVE REST PROBLEMS AND THEN
BEING EXPOSED TO THE KIND OF
SMOKE THAT WE'VE BEEN EXPOSED
TO- THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
I KNOW IT'S EVEN FOR HEALTHY
PEOPLE THAT'S NOT NOT A GOOD
THING. RATES ARE YOU SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY- MCCARTY
PRESCRIBED BURNS I MEAN I CAN
TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT- INJECT WITH
SMOKE EXPOSURE MORE MORE THE-
OLDER POPULATION MORE SMOKE
EXPOSURE BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY
YOU'VE ALREADY YOU'VE ALREADY
TOLD US. THAT THE AMOUNT OF
EXPOSURE AND A PRESCRIBED BURN
VERSUS A REGULAR WILDFIRE IS
LESS SO. SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE WORK AND CONTROLLED OR THE
OR THE WILDFIRE IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT. RIGHT YEAH
I CERTAINLY DO SO- SO WE CAN
TALK ABOUT- THE RESPIRATORY
IMPACTS- CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO
FOUR BUT THEN THOSE ALSO AGE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER OR MORE
RISK- WHEN THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE TO BE SEEN IN
HOSPITAL FOR RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS- IN ADDITION THOSE WHO
HAVE CHRONIC. WHO ALREADY HAVE
PRE EXISTING YOU KNOW
RESPIRATORY ISSUES WILL BE MORE
AT RISK. D. OUR LITERATURE IS
ON THE CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH
IMPACT- FROM EXPOSURE WILDFIRE
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY QUITE.
QUITE SHOCKING- THOSE AGE SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER OR DECREASED
RISK FOR HEART ATTACKS FOR A
READY MEALS. FOR STROKES IN
ADDITION THERE IS A PAPER THAT
CAME OUT LAST YEAR THAT SHOWED
THAT EVEN GOING DOWN AT AGE
THIRTY FIVE AND UP. WHEN THEY
WHEN A COMMUNITY IS EXPOSED TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE THERE IS AN
INCREASED RISK FOR SIDE AND-
CARDIAC ARREST- WHICH IS FOR
SOMEONE JUST. I'M BASICALLY OF
THE HEART STOPPED AND THEY
COLLAPSED AND THEY TYPICALLY
DON'T EVEN MAKE IT TO THE
HOSPITAL- AND SO PRIOR TO- TO
THE STUDY THOSE TYPES OF- SEVEN
CARDIAC ARREST DEATH. YOU KNOW
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN ACCOUNTED
FOR SO. B. B. THE ARE CERTAIN
MUCH MORE AT RISK- STUDIES HAVE
CLEARLY SHOWN THAT AND THEN
THOSE WITH THE PRE EXISTING YOU
KNOW RESPIRATORY CARDIAC
CONDITIONS THERE'S ALSO STUDIES
COMING OUT SHOWING THAT- DOES
WITHIN STAGE- RENAL DISEASE-
HAVE INCREASED DEATH RATES OF
WILDFIRE SMOKE THEIR STUDIES.
SHOWING THAT- PREGNANT WOMEN
ARE AT INCREASED RISK FOR BIRTH
OUTCOMES- SHOW- THERE SEVERAL
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
AVAILABLE POPULATIONS THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT
ABOUT- WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW MITIGATING WILDFIRE
SMOKE EXPOSURE. SO IS IT SAFE
TO SAY THAT- WILDFIRE SMOKE
UNCONTROLLED WILDFIRES POSE A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH RISK
TO CERTAIN POPULATIONS OF
PEOPLE FAIR ENOUGH. A FAIR
ENOUGH AND I'M PROBABLY GENERAL
POPULATION ALSO. MORE ONGOING
RESEARCH YES GREAT CERTAINLY-
STUDIES HAVE SUPPORTED THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GONNA GO TO LET LANIER.
SHE'S IF SHE'S STILL THERE. HI
LONG TIME NO SEE YEP I'M STILL
HERE GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE- IN ALL FAIRNESS WE WERE
TOGETHER A WEEK OR SO AGO I
GUESS- I'VE BEEN- COUNTY. AND
YOU KNOW I. I HEARD YOU KNOW
AND THEN WHAT WHAT I HEARD FROM
YOU TODAY ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE FOR EXAMPLE.
ALL THE MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS
ARE VERY INCONSISTENT IN HOW
THEY CHARGE FEES. SO THEY CAN
HANDLE COUNTY PARTICULAR WE
WERE LOOKING AT A SITE THAT HE
WAS GOING TO BE TWELVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THIRTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOUR HUNDRED ACRES AS I AROUND
A HUNDRED ACRES- IN OTHER AREAS
IT'S NOTHING. YEAH THREE
HUNDRED OKAY THREE ARTICLES BUT
IN OTHER AREAS THAT FIREWOOD
THAT THAT PERMIT WOULD COST
NOTHING- AND THAT. I KIND OF
THAT INCONSISTENCY FINE-
DISTURBING. AND FRUSTRATING FOR
ME AS WELL- AND ALSO TO BE A
DETERRENT. I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM
OTHERS THAT THE SECRET
DOCUMENTS AND I'M TO ANOTHER
FIRE PRESCRIBED FIRE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. HAVING IN SO NOW
MAKING. THE SIX BIKE USE THE C.
WERE DOCKING AND I'M GONNA PUT
ON I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER C.
WHAT. HOWEVER THE DOCTOR. AND
THE STATE DOCUMENTS FOR A
BENEFITS. LANDSCAPE TREATMENT
VISUAL WHICH WE ALL AGREE IS
BENEFICIAL. SHOULD NOT EXCEED
THE COST. OF THE ACTUAL WORK
AND THAT IS HAPPENING PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY AS I FAIR. YOU CAN.
YEAH I THINK SO MMHM AND THAT'S
AND THAT THAT CONCERNS ME AND
THEN THERE YOU ARE AND BECAUSE
OF THAT YOU ARE WHAT YOU HAVE A
YOU ONLY HAVE LIMITED WINDOWS
WHICH YOU CAN ACTUALLY DO THIS
WORK. AND THE DELAYS ON SEQUEL-
AND SOME OF THESE OTHER THINGS
CLOSE THOSE WINDOWS FAIRLY
QUICKLY. CLOSE THOSE WINDOWS
PRETTY QUICKLY THAT FAIR. YEAH
THAT'S TRUE. SO GUY AND WE'VE
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
LIABILITY AND- THE- GROSS
NEGLIGENCE STANDARDS AND I
THINK THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT ISSUES AS
WELL SO I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
I. I KINDA RESTATING WHAT YOU
SAID BUT I WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE WERE BOTH ON THE SAME PAGE I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND AS-
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT HURT MY
EARLY COMMENTS I'M GOING I'M
GOING UP TO HAPPY CAMP. AND
VISITING WITH KARUK ON FRIDAY.
IN THE RAIN TO SEE WHAT. TO SEE
ONCE AGAIN WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND- AND WHAT THEY HAVE PLANNED
AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK. HOW YOU BEEN A
PIONEER IN HELPING GETTING.
MORE AWARENESS ABOUT PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND I. HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS IN EVERY WAY POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR VISIT LAST
WEEK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING MORE. THANK YOU WE HAVE
A QUESTION FROM ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHOSE WITH
THIS REMOTELY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. SO SOMEBODY
CAN OF. I THINK MAYBE SEE ME
NOW. WE SEE YOU MAKE MUCH SENSE
THANK YOU MY QUESTIONS FOR
DOCTOR NEKI- ME I THINK FUNDED
DATA YOU PRESENTED TO US IT'S
CLEAR THAT WILDFIRE- HAS MANY
MORE HEALTH WITH FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PRESCRIBED
FIRES BUT WE STILL HAVE JUST TO
BE CLEAR THEY'RE STILL REAL
HEALTH CONCERNS ALSO ARE HELD
WITH WITH PRESCRIBED FIRES IS
THAT CORRECT. WILD I THINK THE
PRIMARY RISK COULD BE TO THE B.
FIREFIGHTERS DOING THAT
PRESCRIBED BURNING. BUT IF
THERE IS A POPULATION THAT
COULD BE IMPACTED- CERTAINLY IF
YOU'RE GONNA INHALE SMOKE THERE
IS THERE IS A RISK BUT THE-
WITH THE PRESCRIBER AND YOU'RE
ABLE TO. DUPLICATION IF
NECESSARY MASS AIR PURIFIERS
YOU KNOW NOT BEING IN THE AREA
WARNING PEOPLE STEALING UP YOUR
HOUSE WHATEVER IT MAY BE-BUT
IF YOU KNOW ANY TYPE OF SMOKE
SHOULD NOT. BE AN HELD A
POSSIBLE. SO WHAT WHAT I MEAN I
MEAN BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN AND SHOULD BE DOING MORE
PRESCRIBED FIRES I DON'T WANT
TO COME OFF AS ANTAGONISTIC.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE B.
ARENE EQUITABLE AND PROTECTING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AS WE'RE
DOING THIS IN OUR THINKING ALL
ABOARD ON THAT- WHAT KIND OF
MEDICATIONS TO GO ON NOW HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE FILTERS ARE BEING
MOVED OUT. WHEN WE DO DO THESE
PRESCRIBED FIRES. I DON'T THINK
I'M A GOOD ONE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF WHAT'S CURRENTLY
BEING DONE WHEN PRESCRIBED
FIRES OCCUR. BUT YOU KNOW FROM
THE HEALTH LITERATURE WE- WE DO
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT CAN BE.
YOU KNOW DONE THAT TO MEDICATE
ANY CONCERNS- BUT CERTAINLY WE
DO NOW THAT YOU KNOW- EXPOSURE
TO WILDFIRE SMOKE IS TYPICALLY
IN A MUCH GREATER MUCH MORE
DETRIMENTAL- TO THE PRESCRIBED
BURNING. MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE
WOULD BE BETTER ABLE TO ANSWER-
BUT THE CURRENT PRACTICES. WHEN
A PRESCRIBED BURN IT'S GOING TO
OCCUR. ANYONE. I'M NOT HEARING
ANY YEAH I CAN I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT BRIEFLY I THINK I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT
WE DO GO THROUGH PRETTY
RIGOROUS SMOKE MANAGEMENT
PLANNING PROCESS SEES WHEN WE
PLANNED PRESCRIBED FIRES SO- WE
REALLY TRY TO TARGET WINDOWS
WHEN WE GET GOOD DISPERSION ARE
SMOKELESS AND IS CARRIED AWAY
AND NOT SETTLING DOWN ON
COMMUNITIES- SO THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF FOR THOUGHT THAT GOES
INTO THAT AND WE REALLY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH A PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW THE RIGHT
CONDITIONS AND THE RIGHT
WEATHER WINDOWS AND THE RIGHT
WIND DIRECTIONS AND THERE ARE
SO MANY PIECES THAT WE CONSIDER
SO. WE REALLY JUST TRY TO AVOID
THOSE KINDS OF IMPACTS FROM THE
START- THAT SAID WE DO HAVE
TIMES WHEN WE WHEN WE NEED TO
BURN AND IMPACTS ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THAT'S WHEN
DEPENDING ON WHO'S DOING THE
BURN AND WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FILTERS OR DO THINGS LIKE THAT
NOT REALLY IS GOING TO DEPEND
ON WHAT THE ENTITY IS WHO'S
DOING IT WHAT COMMUNITY THERE
AND WHAT KINDS OF SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE SO THAT'S A BIT MORE
VARIABLE BUT THAT SMOKE
MANAGEMENT PLANNING PIECES IS-
NOT IS VERY ABLE TO PROCESS
THAT WE ALL GO THROUGH AND PUT
A LOT OF THOUGHT INTO. STEPHEN
I JUST THAT THE YOU KNOW CREEK
THOMAS AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE SN JOAQUIN
AREA SAN JOAQUIN IS THAT SOME
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEM AIR
QUALITY BUT CREGGAN OTHERS OF
WORK AND DEVELOP THE NETWORK
NOW SO WHEN THEY WANT TO BURN
IN THE SOUTHERN SIERRA THINGS
LIKE COMMUNITY CLINICS ARE
ACTUALLY TOLD ABOUT THIS THEY
CAN THEN ADVISE THERE ARE FOLKS
THAT ARE PERHAPS PART OF THE
PULMONARY AND OTHER ISSUES.
THIS IS COMING SO THEY'VE
REALLY BUILT THIS COOPERATION
BETWEEN A PLACE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AREA WITH SOME OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING TOGETHER BECAUSE OF THE
COOPERATION AND IT IS REAL LIKE
YOU SAY THAT YOU CAN IMPACT
PEOPLE BUT I SEE THIS AREA IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT'S GIVEN
US GREAT HOPE BECAUSE SOME.
GROUPS ARE REALLY. WORKING
TOGETHER TRYING TO LOOK LONG
TERM. THANK YOU FOR THAT DO WE
HAVE ANY SORT OF. TRY IN OUR SO
IF YOU SEE KIND OF A DIFFERENT
ARE DOING THAT MANY AND THEIR
PLANS AND HOW MAY BE SOME
COMMUNITIES MIGHT HAVE BETTER.
I MIGHT BE DOING THINGS BETTER
THAN OTHER COMMUNITIES I'VE
I'VE BEEN. NEAR PRESCRIBED
FIRES WHEN IT'S HAPPENING YOU
KNOW LET THEM TIME TO KIND OF
MAKE OTHERS YOU KNOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE MAP AND THERE'S A
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND I COULD
FEEL IT- YOU KNOW AND I DIDN'T
GET THE INFORMATION AND SO
THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
PUBLIC INFORMATION OUT THERE.
DO WE HAVE SOME SORT OF
PROPERLY KINDA LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER FOR BETTER PRACTICES FOR
THOSE POLITICAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS SCOTT STEVENS AGAIN I
THINK. THE REALLY IS WORKING
MORE AND LIKE YOU SAID AT A
LOCAL COMMUNITY LEVEL MAYBE
THERE COULD BE A WAY TO. HELP
FOSTER THAT BUT YOU KNOW. DRUG
COMMUNICATIONS TO CLINICS THAT
BASICALLY SERVES. PEOPLE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND OTHERS THAT.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT
THIS WORK IS HAPPENING BECAUSE
ONE. WHEN THIS IS HAPPENING THE
SAN JOAQUIN I THINK THE AIR
QUALITY DISTRICT DOWN THERE IS
NOW A GREAT PARTNER. AND A LOOK
AT THIS IS SOMETHING THEY WANT
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH IT
ACTUALLY COOPERATE WITH SO. BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT PROBABLY IT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE AD HOC I WOULD
IMAGINE SO I DON'T KNOW THAT
SYSTEMIC I'M I'M MAYBE OTHERS
ON THE PANEL COULD SAY. SHE. I
NOW HAVE. LAST QUITE. THERE'S A
LOT OF DATA ABOUT. THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO US ON PM TWO POINT
FIVE FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
THERE'S A FEW OTHER THINGS ON
SOME OF THESE FLAGS. THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US. ARE WE
TRACKING OR DO WE HAVE STUDIES
ON GHG EMISSIONS- I MEAN I'M
GOING TO ASSUME THAT MY
ILDFIRES HAVE MUCH MORE
CATASTROPHIC MUCH APPRECIATE
SHE IS BEING ADMITTED. THAT IT
MIGHT PRESCRIBE OUR BUT- AS
WE'RE WORKING ON OUR- REDUCTION
OF GHGS REDDIT. FOR ME IT'S
MORE LIKE. KNOWING WHAT'S THERE
SO I KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO
MITIGATE LATE LATER- YOU KNOW
AS WE AS WE EMBRACE THIS
PRACTICE ART DO WE HAVE ANY OF
THAT THAT'S CURRENTLY GOING ON
AT THE STATE LEVEL. I MIGHT AND
I MIGHT JUST ADD. SOMETHING IN
HERE. AS PART OF. WHAT I
BELIEVE WAS SB NINE A ONE.
WE'VE ASKED THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO ACTUALLY MEASURE-
WILDFIRE EMISSIONS. AND THE
GHGS ASSOCIATE WITH THAT SO I
AM ANXIOUSLY AWAITING TO SEE
pCOMPARES TO OTHER OTHER KINDS
OF POLLUTION. OUT THERE- BUT- I
WOULD I WOULD GUESS THAT THESE
ARE HUGE EMISSIONS I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY FALL ON THE SCALE
OF. WHAT ELSE IS OMITTED FROM
CARS AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT-
HAVING BREATHED A LOT OF THIS
FIRM FOR OVER. MONTHS AND YEARS
NOW- AND SEEING THE EFFECTS OF
MY COMMUNITY. IT'S NOT POSITIVE
AND SO. BUT I DO KNOW WE HAVE
ASKED. FOR MEASUREMENTS ON THAT
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE GET
THAT DATA SOON. AND WHAT I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE IS A
COMPARISON SIDE BY SIDE LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE- ESSENTIALLY WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. HOW DOES
THIS COMPARE TO STATIONARY
POLLUTION HOUSES COMPARED TO.
TAILPIPE POLLUTION. AND HOW
DOES YOU KNOW AND HOW DOES THIS
ALL STACK UP BECAUSE- I JUST
FEEL LIKE WE'RE NOT INVESTING
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO HELP
PREVENT THESE WILD. WILD LARGE
WILDFIRES. AND MY HOPE IS THAT
THE- THAT MAY PUT MY HOPE IS
I'M WRONG BUT I BY MY INSTINCT
IS THAT I'M NOT. AND WE NEED TO
BE PUTTING A LOT MORE RESOURCES
INTO THIS. WOULD ALSO SAY THAT-
BECAUSE PRESCRIBED BURNS ARE
DONE. A LOT OF TIMES BASED.
THE RIGHT WINDOWS. AFTER THERE
HAS BEEN POTENTIALLY RAIN- IN
AN AREA TO HELP SLOW THESE
FIRES DOWN- THE EMISSIONS ARE
GOING TO BE LOWER- THESE
UNCONTROLLED FIRES- LIKE WE HAD
IN FROM THE LIGHTNING COMPLEX.
WHERE THEY WERE LARGE INVERSION
LAYERS THAT LITERALLY SAT THIS
SMOKE DOWN IN DID NOT ALLOW IT
TO GO ANYWHERE. NOW FOR DAYS
AND DAYS UPON END WHERE THE SKY
WAS RED AND WE- IT LOOKS ORANGE
FOR DAYS- HAS TO HAVE. A MUCH
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT. THEIR AND
SO. THAT THESE UNCONTROLLED
FIRES ARE HAPPENING AT TIMES
WHEN THE WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE
NOT FAVORABLE WORSE PRESCRIBED
BURNS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN. BY
OUR OWN REGULATION IN TIMES
WHEN THE WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE
FAVORABLE SO I THINK THAT THE
OFFSET FOR THAT IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT. YEAH I MEAN I WOULD
SAY THAT I EIGHT OF THE SAME
MINDSET THAT THESE A WILDFIRE
EMISSIONS ARE WAY WORSE. THAN
THE PRESCRIBED FIRES- I WOULD
JUST. ONE DAY WE WERE TRACKING
IT AND AS WITHIN THE COMPARISON
THEY WERE INCLUDING BUT THE
COMPARISON OF PRESCRIBED FIRES.
WILDFIRES STATIONARY SOURCES SO
FOR THE BUT ALSO THAT I THINK
IN THAT MAKING SURE WE HAVE.
PROPER I COUNTIES WITH THAT
HAVE PROPER OFFSET TO
MITIGATION FOR THEM I THINK FOR
ME IT'S MORE WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
BE DOING MORE OF THIS AND AS
FAR AWAY. YEAH WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES SO WE
COULD ALSO MITIGATE FOR THAT
AND THINK AHEAD FOR THAT. I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU. MY
CONCERN WE WANTED THIS DATA BUT
WE HAD TO LEGISLATIVE THE ASK
FOR IT- THIS DATA SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE NOW FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THESE FIRES BEEN
GOING ON FOR YEARS. WE HAD TO
PUSH OUR OWN AGENCIES TO HELP
PRODUCES DATA AND I THINK
THAT'S A PROBLEM. ANYTHING ELSE
MISS GARCIA NO THANK YOU OKAY
ARE ANY UP WITH ANY OF THE
OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING DOES ANYBODY ELSE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY AND
THEN I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL
VERY MUCH ARE YOU MAY WANT TO
STAND BY BECAUSE MR FLOOR I HAD
TO LEAVE BUT I THINK HE MAY
HAVE QUESTIONS WHEN HE RETURNED
SO IF YOU ARE ABLE. TO GREAT IF
YOU CAN STAND BY THREE NEXT
PANELS. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR SECOND PANEL ON
STATE PRESCRIBED BY A FIRE
EFFORTS. TOM PORTER WHO WE ALL
KNOW VERY WELL THE DIRECTOR OF
THE PERMANENT FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTON. AND MATT DAVIS
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE PANELISTS AND EVERYBODY
ACTUALLY WHO'S LISTENING TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR- DEVICES ON
MUTE BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING
QUITE A BIT OF BACKGROUND NOISE
AND FEEDBACK- TIME SO EVERYONE
CAN BE MUTED WHEN YOU WERE NOT
SPEAKING. THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
MISTER PORTER. STE WELL GOOD
ACTORS. CHAIR OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY- MY NAME IS TOM
PORTER- AND I AM OF THE STATE
FORESTER AND DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION AS YOU KNOW AND I AM
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE A
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS-
PRESCRIBED FIRE HAND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN CALIFORNIA- AS THE
DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO- BROADLY
ACROSS STATE AGENCIES IN THIS
SPACE. I WILL FOREGO- GIVING
YOU A FIRE SEASON UPDATE WHICH
I OFTEN DO- DURING THESE- THESE
BRIEFINGS- AND HEARINGS BUT
YOUR BACKGROUND PAPER IS VERY
THOROUGH STAFF A GREAT JOB OF
PUTTING THAT TOGETHER. AND I
WILL LEAVE THAT TO. SPEAK TO
THE WHAT THE SEASON HAS BROUGHT
US TO THIS YEAR. SO WHERE'S
THAT TAKE US- WE TRULY ARE-
SEEING THINGS DIFFERENTLY THAN
WE HAVE IN MY CAREER AND MY
CAREER IS THIRTY YEARS AS A
FORESTER- AND FIREWORKS- FIRE
FIGHTERS. WHAT WHAT IS CLEAR IS
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT AND THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO REALLY FURTHER
HAS- THE FORESTRY AND FIRE
COMMUNITY IS THIS ALLOF THE
ABOVE APPROACH THERE IS NO
SILVER BULLET TO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. AND WHILE- WHILST
WILL FOCUS ON I WILL FOCUS ON A
PRESCRIBED FIRE- I WOULD LIKE I
CAN'T LET IT GO UNNOTICED OR
RUN STATED. THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT. ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH WHEN
TALKING ABOUT- FOREST HEALTH
AND REDUCTION OF. RISK TO
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRE THAT
INCLUDES. THAT ALL OF HE ABOVE
APPROACH WE TRULY- IN SOME
AREAS WELL WE NEED TO PUT MORE
FIRE ON THE GROUNDS ARE
PRESCRIBED FIRE- WE CAN'T DO
THAT SAFELY AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE REALLY NEED TO DO-
OTHER FUEL REDUCTION PROJECT
WORK IN ORDER TO MAKE FOR A
SAFE. A REINTRODUCTION FOR FIRE
ON THE LANDSCAPE AS THAT
HAPPENS- TIME WILL WILL PASS
AND WILL HAVE A LANDSCAPE THAT
CAN RECEIVE FIRE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AS NEEDED- ON A RETURN
INTERVAL OF TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
YEARS WHATEVER IT NEEDS TO BE-
WITHOUT ALL OF THAT ADDITIONAL
WORK BUT RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO
ALSO INVEST IN THOSE THINGS-
THAT WILL MAKE IT SAFE TO PUT
FIRE ON THE GROUND. TO THE
SCALE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO.
WE CAN'T FOR THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STILL.
ACROSS THE STATE IN SOME CASES
ARE NOT- THE PLACE WHERE WE
WANT TO PUT PRESCRIBED FIRE-
IT'S TOO DANGEROUS IN SOME
CASES THE WAY THE TOPOGRAPHY
IS. OR THE WAY THE FUELS ARE
AND WE NEED TO DO OTHER TYPES
OF FUEL PROJECTS IN A HIM.
MAINTAIN DEFENSIBLE SPACE-
MAINTAIN. THE AND THE- AREAS
AROUND HOMES AND- DO THE- HOME
HARDENING THAT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT HOMES ARE.
RESISTANT TO HAMBURGERS. SO WE
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF MEMBERS
AND THE SZE AND TYPE OF
MEMBERS COMING IN BY REDUCING
THE FUELS OUTSIDE OF THE
COMMUNITY WE HARDENED
STRUCTURES WE HAVE THE
DISPENSABLE SPACE. WE HAVE A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH THAT TRULY
REDUCES THE RISK OF WILDFIRE
CONSUMING HOMES AND- GOD FOR
BID WHOLE COMMUNITIES. SO
PRESCRIBED. THIS IS THE FUTURE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS. BY FAR THE
MOST ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE WAY
TO TREAT THE LANDSCAPE THAT WE
NEED TO IN ORDER TO RETURN TO A
HEALTHY. ECOSYSTEM IN SOME
CASES BUT ALSO HEALTHY RETURN
RATE OF WILDFIRE ON THE
LANDSCAPE OR JUST BUYER ON THE
LANDSCAPE- TO REDUCE THOSE
RISKS THAT I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY. SO IN THE IN THE
CALIFORNIA FOREST EFFORT SORRY
CALIFORNIA FIRE. CALIFORNIA
CARBON PLAN EXCUSE ME THERE'S
SO MANY PLANS BUT THE CARBON
PLAN IS SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT
HOW DO WE- IN OUR FORESTED
ECOSYSTEMS INCREASES THE
SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON. REDUCE
OUR OUR- OUR EFFECTS ON THE
LAND ARE ON THE AIR AND HANDY
ON THE ON CLIMATE CHANGE ITSELF.
AND SO ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
DO THAT IS IT IS INVEST IN
THINGS THAT WILL SEQUESTERING
CARBON TREES FOREST SOILS SOILS
IN GENERAL- AND VEGETATION ARE
ONE OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE WAYS
TO DO SUCH. AND SO THROUGH
THIS- WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT WE
NEED TO DO ROUGHLY. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES ANNUALLY
OF TREATMENT IN FORESTED
ECOSYSTEMS BUT THAT INCLUDES
CHAPARRAL. OAK WOODLAND- DEEP
DENSE FOREST IN THE HIGHER
ELEVATIONS AS WELL AS THE
MEXICANA FOR IN THE MIDDLE AT
ELEVATIONS ALL OF THAT AREA
NEEDS SOME LEVEL OF FOREST
HEALTH TREATMENT WHAT THAT'LL
DO IS IT'LL INCREASE THE HEALTH
OF THE OF THE VEGETATION THAT
REMAINS ON THE LANDSCAPE
PARTICULARLY THOSE LARGE TREES.
AND THEY WILL SEE PLASTER
CARBON FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
INTO THE FUTURE IF WE DO THIS
RIGHT. SO WHAT WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH IS THE FOR SERVICE
US FOREST SERVICE AND THE OTHER
FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE COMMITTED
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
AS WELL. AND BY THE BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OUR INTENT IS TO
HAVE BOTH OF THOSE SETS OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE
TREATMENTS GOING ON ON THE
LANDSCAPE ANNUALLY- AND- HALF
OF THAT ON FEDERAL LANDS HALF
OF THAT ON THE STATE AND
PRIVATE LANDS. SO AS I
MENTIONED MANY MANY TECHNIQUES
ARE OUT THERE FOR. THE USE OF
FUEL REDUCTION- TO REALLY GET
US TO A BETTER PLACE- THE IN
OUR OUR ABILITY TO- ALLOW FIRE
TO BE UTILIZED ON THE
LANDSCAPE. THE FIRST THAT WE
USE AND SO OTHERS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE SEQUEL COMPONENTS THE
SMOKE MANAGEMENT PLANNING- AND
DOWNED WHAT I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT HERE IS EVERY SINGLE
PRODUCT PROJECT THAT WE DO FOR
PRESCRIBED BURNING REQUIRES A-
VERY DETAILED PLAN AND YES I.
MEMBER WOULD AYE HI HI I AGREE
IN IN SOME CASES IT IS A
LABORIOUS AND EXPENSIVE PROCESS
IN ORDER TO PUT THAT PLAN
TOGETHER- AND- WHAT WE NEED TO
BE SURE TO- REFERENCE THOUGH IS
THE VALUE OF PROTECTING THE-
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE ON THE
LANDSCAPE. SOMETIMES THOSE ARE
CULTURAL SOMETIMES THEY ARE
VEGETATION SOMETIME MEETING
RARE PLANTS- THAT I HAVE SEEN
TOO MUCH FIRE SOMETIMES THEY
ARE MIGRATORY BIRDS OR OTHER-
SLOWER AND FULLER I MEAN FANA
THAT MAY BE SENSITIVE TO- THE
FIRE OUR PRESCRIPTION. NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS AND NEEDS
TO PROTECT THOSE THINGS. ARE
PROTECT THOSE NATURAL RESOURCES
ON THE LANDSCAPE AND SO OR
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A LONG TIME
BUT AS TIME GOES ON AND WE GET
TO AREAS WHERE WE BURNED OVER
TIME I KNOW I WILL BE ABLE TO
TAILOR OUR PRESCRIPTIONS MORE
QUICKLY AND MORE READILY TO
THOSE RESOURCES THAT ARE ON THE
LANDSCAPE. WHERE WE'RE COMING
FROM A PLACE WHERE WE REALLY
DID NOT EMBRACE PRESCRIBED FIRE
FOR THE LAST. WELL IN THE LAST
YEARS WE HAVE. PRIOR TO THAT
THERE WAS ABOUT TWENTY TO
THIRTY YEARS WHERE IT WAS JUST
SIGNIFICANTLY ON THE DOWN OF A
DECLINE AS A TOOL OF USE. WE
ARE. BUILDING THAT BACK. AND
NOT ONLY ARE WE BUILDING THE
EXPERTISE BACK BUT WE'RE ALSO
BUILDING THE DATABASES OF.
INFORMATION THAT REALLY TUNES
OUR USE OF THE OF THIS A VERY
EFFECTIVE TOOL AND NEEDED TOOL
ON THE LANDSCAPE. SO OUR
PRESCRIPTION- THAT'S DEVELOPED
OUT OF THIS PLAN GIVES US A
WINDOW. AND WE'VE HEARD FROM
DOCTOR STEVENS ABOUT. LOOKING
AT WAYS TO INCREASE THE HOW
WIDE THAT WINDOWS OPEN I AM
VERY MUCH FOR THIS PERSPECTIVE
VERY MUCH- WORKING WITH THE
WITH THE PRACTITIONERS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION ALONG WITH OUR
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS BUT I WILL
BE WORKING WITH THE- LOCAL AND
TRIBAL- PRACTITIONERS AS WELL.
THROUGH VERY- APPROPRIATE
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT OPEN THE
WINDOW TO BE ABLE TO BURN AT
DIFFERENT TIMES OF THE YEAR
WHEN WE- WHEN WE HAVE AN OPEN
WINDOW AND SOMETIMES THAT IS-
IT COULD EVEN BE DURING A- WHAT
WE TRADITIONALLY USED TO CALL
THE FIRE SEASON. IF WE HAVE THE
RIGHT CONDITIONS IT MIGHT BE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO TO
ACTUALLY BURKE CHIEF AYE AYE IF
YOU TO PAY HE JUST CUT YOU OFF-
WE'VE GONE UP BEYOND THE SEVEN
MINUTES IF YOU COULD JUST WRAP
UP- THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK
YOU. YES ABSOLUTELY I AM SORRY
FOR GOING A LITTLE BIT LONGER-
I WILL TIGHTEN IT UP TO SOME
EXAMPLES. SO IT OFTEN COMES AS
A AS I HAPPEN TO BE THE STATE
FIRE CHIEF AS WELL IT'S OFTEN
IT WILL HOW ARE THESE THINGS
ACTUALLY HELPING YOU WHEN WE
HAVE WILD FIRES. AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY. CRITICAL THAT WE
HAVE THIS RESILIENT LANDSCAPE
TO FIRE AS I MENTIONED IT
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF AMBER
PRODUCTION. IT REDUCES
INTENSITY AS FIRES COME INTO
COMMUNITIES ON THE CREEK FIRE-
INDIAN- MADERA AND FRESNO
COUNTY THERE WERE FIVE OF THE
THIRTY FIVE- PROJECTS THAT-
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER AND HAND
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM- ASKED ME
TO MAKE SURE WORK DONE LAST
YEAR. FIVE OF THE THIRTY FIVE
WERE UTILIZED ALONG WITH
PRESCRIBED BURNS ON SO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
LANDS. IN AND AROUND SHAVER
LAKE THAT REALLY- SAVE THAT
COMMUNITY- WE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
STRUCTURE LOSS IN THAT AREA BUT
THE CENTRE PIECE OF. SHAVER
LAKE WOULD HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
CONSUMED LIKE PARADISE HAD WE
NOT DONE THOSE PROJECTS. AND
HAD WE NOT HAD THOSE PRESCRIBED
FIRES THAT OCCURRED IN THAT
AREA CAN YOU REMEMBER THAT IS
ALSO IN THE HEART OF THE TREE
MORTALITY. AREA FROM A SEVERAL
YEARS BACK AND- MUCH NEEDED
PROJECT WORK THAT STATE THAT
COMMUNITY- I WILL IT IS. ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AT THE
END I DO HAVE SOME INFORMATION
RELATED TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU'VE ALREADY ASKED
SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COME
BACK TO ANY OF THOSE I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THOSE. AT THAT
TIME THANK YOU WHEN WE COME
BACK AT THE END OF THE PENALTY
GREAT IF YOU HAVE SOME ANSWERS
FROM I'M ASSUMING YOU MEANT
FROM THE PREVIOUS PANEL WE CAN
YOU CAN. WELCOME TO SHARE YOUR
ANSWERS WITH US WE'D LOVE TO
HEAR THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND NOW WILL MOVE TO MATT DEUS.
WELCOME WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE YES I AM THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION AND TODAY IT'S
BEEN A FEW MINUTES WITH YOU TO
TALK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM
AND FOR THE BALANCE OF THIS
PRESENTATION I'LL BE REFERRING
IT TO REFERRING TO THE PROGRAM
AS A CAL VTP. I'M GONNA GIVE
YOU A BRIEF HISTORY OF A JOB
VTP OF THE WAY IN WHICH THIS
PROGRAM WILL SURFACED- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- CHIPPING
HIGHER STANDARDS OUR PACE AND
SCALE AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE AS WELL AS
OTHER VEGETATION TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. OR OTHER TREE OF
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROJECTS.
AS ME THE BACKGROUND. THE
CALIBRATED THE WIRES ARE WORKED
ON BY THE STATE BOARD OF
FORESTRY FIRE PROTECTION FOR.
JUST OVER TEN YEARS AND OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST. YEAR OR
SO OVER OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE MADE A
SIGNIFICANT EFFORT TO PUSH THE
PROJECT OVER THE FINISH LINE IF
YOU WELL AND ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
BOARD DID. APPROVE THE COUNTY
D. P. PROGRAM AS WELL CERTIFIED
TO SUPPORTING PROGRAM E. IR.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR
DEVELOPMENTS OF THE LAST YEAR
DEVELOPMENT ARE WE REALLY
FOCUSED OUR ENERGY WE TOOK A
VERY COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
WORKING WITH. I AM VERY LARGE
PARTNERS STAKEHOLDER GROUP
INCLUDED. MANY OF OUR AGENCY
PARTNERS DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE- CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD STATE WATER BOARDS
REGIONAL WATER BOARD SO ON AND
SO FORTH AS WELL PART OF
PARTNERS. TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM
THIS CAN BE WIDELY SUPPORTED.
THE COLLABORATION THAT WE
ENGAGED IN TRYING TO CHANGE THE
VISION OF THE PROGRAM- IN THAT
WE THE BOARD'S DR JEFFREY WHERE
THE INITIAL. THE INITIAL P. E.
I. R. THE NATIONAL PROGRAM IS
GOING TO BE FOCUSED ON HAVING
CAL FIRE BEAT THE NUMBER ONE
AND ONLY SAW AGENCY THAT WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS UNDER
THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM BUT AS
THE CHANGING WILDFIRE
CONDITIONS IN THE STATE. ALONG
WITH- GOAL SET FORTH I HAVE
TREATMENT ON PRIVATE LANDS TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A
YEAR. WITH ALL THAT IN THE
BACKGROUND- WE CHANGE THE
VISION OF THE PROGRAM TO BE NOT
ONLY OUR PROGRAM BUT TO PAY
BROAD PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO.
ALL RELY UPON. I'M HERE TO
STATE AGENCIES LOCAL AGENCIES
TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE A PROGRAM
TO EFFECTUATE THE CHANGE
NECESSARY- IN THE STATE IS A
LIST OF WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
WITH THE PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
TREAT UP 252-005-0000 ACRES A
YEAR AND THAT WOULD BE ON NON
FEDERAL LANDS TO REPEAT REDUCE
FAR WILDFIRE RISK AND ESTABLISH
MORE NATURAL FIRE REGIMES
ACROSS THE STATE- THE PROGRAM
CONTAINS AN ANALYSIS OF
PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENTS.
IMPLEMENTING VEGETATION
TREATMENTS PROGRAMS AND
THEREFORE. ADVISOR BROUGHT UP
WITH YOU NEED FOR INDIVIDUAL
PROJECT PROPONENTS TO CONDUCT
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AND
EVENT AS REQUIRED BY SEQUINED
AND EFFICIENT MANNER THE COUNTY
T. PROGRAMS INTENDED TO ASSIST
IN INCREASING PACE AND SCALE OF
ALL VEGETATION TREATMENT
PROGRAMS ARE ALL VEGETATION
TREATMENTS INCLUDING.
PRESCRIBED FIRE BUT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL THE WHILE WE'RE LOOKING AT
EFFICIENCY AS IT RELATES TO
SEEK WELL WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
DRIVE ECOLOGICALLY BALANCED
OUTCOMES AS WELL. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE- CHIEF PORTER
INDICATED THIS IS ONE ONE PIECE
OF A BROADER PREVENTION PROGRAM
WHERE VEGETATION TREATMENT IS
CRITICAL BUT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT- DEFENSIBLE SPACE BUILDING
CODES LAND USE DECISIONS AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION. NOW TO BE
CLEAR THE TOP ETP DOES NOT
FOCUS ON THOSE SPECIFICALLY BUT
THE CHALVEY TP DOES SPOKE FOCUS
SOLELY ON VEGETATION. TREATMENT
BY THE BOARD OF COURSE IN FIRE
PROTECTION CLEARLY RECOGNIZES
THAT JUST ONE COMPONENT OF A
LARGER PREVENTION STRATEGY IN
THE STATE. ARE THE PROGRAM
APPLIES. TO TWENTY POINT THREE
MILLION ACRES THERE'S THE
ENVIRONMENT ANALYSIS SUPPORTS
TO WORK ON TWENTY POINT THREE
MILLION ACRES WHICH IS
PRIMARILY WAS IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA. AND IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN FINDING
INFORMATION IS REPLACED FREE
ONE LANDSCAPE WE HAVE A LOT OF
WEBSITE BUILT ON THE BOARD'S
WEB PAGE WHERE YOU CAN SEE OR
VIEW THE TRAVEL LANDSCAPE.
THERE'S THREE PRIMARY THERE ARE
THREE TREATMENT TYPES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR- ANALYSIS UNDER
OR FOR IMPLEMENTATION I SHOULD
SAY THAT'S A WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECT. YOUR BRAKES AND
ECOLOGICAL RESTAURANT
RESTORATION SO IN TERMS OF
TEARING THOSE OF THREE
TREATMENT TYPES. DID SHE WAS
THOSE TREATMENT TYPES THERE'S
ACTUALLY FIVE DIFFERENT
TREATMENT ACTIVITIES WE ARE
PRESCRIBED BURNING MANUAL
VEGETATION MECHANICAL TREATMENT
PRESCRIBED PREPARE RAINY AND
TARGETED BROWN APPLICATION OF
HERBICIDES SO I JUST WANT TO
TOUCH ON TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOCUSED ON PRESCRIBED FIRES ARE
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING I
WON'T ALREADY KNOW MY TESTIMONY
WILL PROVIDE SOME VERY QUICK
AYE TARGETS AS RELATES OUR
GOALS HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED UNDER
THE PROGRAM. AS IT RELATES TO
PRESCRIBE ARE SPECIFICALLY. THE
PROGRAM ITSELF HAS EIGHTY WHAT
IT CALLS ARE. SB FLOOR STAND
ARE PROJECT REQUIREMENTS THE
BEST WAY TO THINK ABOUT THESE
WOULD BE BMPS BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ARE POSSIBLE
MITIGATION MEASURES. AND THOSE
ARE BUILT OFF OF THE Y. LEVEL
OF COLLABORATION THAT THE BOARD
TOOK WILL BE DEVELOPED AS WITH
OUR AGENCY STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL
AS THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
ADDRESSING THE VARIOUS ARE. THE
VARIOUS SUBJECTS THAT ARE
ANALYZED UNDER THE AYE
OURSELVES SO WE'RE FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE A STATIC VISUAL
RESOURCES AREN'T LOGICAL
HISTORICAL IN TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS HYDROLOGY WATER
QUALITY. AND GENERALLY TO A FAX
SO THERE'S ABOUT SEVENTEEN
RESOURCE OBJECTS ARE ANALYZED
MANY OF THOSE HAVE SUPPORTING-
BMPS TO ASSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED- AND-
AND ONE ON ONE SUBJECT I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON VERY QUICKLY THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT. DATA
CONVERSION. AND WHILE I. THINK
THERE ARE WHEN I WAS OF FROM
ONE I THINK OF. I'M SPEAKING
CAN VENT US. ABOUT CONVERSE
BUDGET. TYPES OF THE PROGRAM
KNOWLEDGES A SHORTENED FIRE
RETURN HOLE HAVE THAT SHORTEN
FIRE RETURN INTERVALS. HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A PRIMARY
DRIVER OF CONVERSION ARE
PRIMARILY IN COASTAL SAGE AND
CHAPARRAL VEGETATION TYPES. AND
IF NOT CONDUCTED APPROPRIATELY
THAT PRESCRIBED FIRE COULD
POTENTIALLY RESULT AND TYPE
CONVERSION OF THOSE VEGETATION
TYPES WITH WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT- COMMENT THAT WE
HEARD DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PROGRAM AND HAS BEEN A
DOCTOR HAS BEEN ADDRESSED
WITHIN THE PROGRAM ITSELF. I
NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
CONVERSION OF. ANY VETS TYPE
INCLUDING SHOP ROLLER COASTAL
SAGE IS NOT ALLOWED- IS
DISALLOWED WITHIN THE PROGRAM.
AND IT PROVIDES INFORMATION AND
GUIDANCE TO INDIVIDUAL PROJECT
PROPONENTS THAT WHEN THEY ARE
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY AS THEY ARE WITHIN
THOSE SENSITIVE EVENTS TYPES
THAT THEY NEED TO FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON. REPLICATING
NATURAL FIRE RESERVE. NATURAL
FIRE REGIMES. AND RETURNING
VEGETATION TYPES WITH CONDITION
CLASS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRYING TO. THREE AREAS WHERE
THE DEPARTURE OF A FIRE RETURN
INTERVALS HAS DEVIATED AND TRY
TO BRING IT BACK TO ITS ITS
ORIGINAL PLAT CITY ASSIST YOU
YOU'VE GONE BEYOND SEVEN
MINUTES SO IF YOU CAN PLEASE.
WRAP IT UP THANKS I. WRAP IT UP
RIGHT NOW SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
THAT THERE ARE SOME ONLINE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE I DID SEE A
MAP ONLINE WELL MY COLLEAGUE
WAS SPEAKING MY DIRECTOR PORTER
WAS SPEAKING. AND IN FACT ABOUT
THAT SHOW WHERE THE PROJECTS
ARE CURRENTLY BEING PROPOSED
ACROSS THE STATE UNDER THE
COUNTY TP. AND TO DATE. WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE PROPOSED. KIND OF THE
CALGARY TP. WHAT I HAVE NO
FURTHER. THANK YOU MISTER DO
YOU VERY HELPFUL WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO QUESTIONS NOW I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS TO BEGIN FOR
REPORTER. I'M SORRY TO MAKE YOU
GUYS CHANGE SEATS AGAIN. WE
SHOULD HAVE GONE THE OTHER WAY
TOO LATE. HI CHIEF THANK YOU.
MY FIRST QUESTION FOR YOU IS
WHETHER CAL FIRE HAS A GOAL FOR
THE NUMBER OF BURN BOSSES YOU
WANT TO CERTIFY AND HOW DO YOU
WHAT IS THAT GOAL AND HOW DO
YOU INTEND TO GET THERE. WE
HAVE NOT SET A GOAL FOR NUMBER
OF BURNT BOSSES I THINK WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS. EXPAND AND AN
OPEN THAT PROGRAM AS MUCH AS WE
CAN TO GET AS MANY AS WE CAN.
WITH EXPERIENCE IN DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE STATE AS WELL- I
THINK. SOME AREAS OF THE STATE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MUCH BETTER
LUCK THAN OTHERS IN IN FINDING-
THOSE TO TRAIN. THANK YOU. MY
NEXT QUESTION IS HAVE WHETHER.
HOW CALIFORNIA- IN THE FOREST
SERVICE'S GOING TO SCALE UP TO
TREAT. FEDERAL LANDS GIVEN THE
ONE MILLION ACRE- GOAL BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- STEP BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE FOREST SERVICE
HOW DO YOU PLAN. TO SCALE UP TO
HIT THOSE GOALS. WELL IN. ON
THE STATE LANDS- WE ARE
CURRENTLY SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ANNUALLY WE'VE
BEEN AT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ACRES
THAT WE DO. ASK HELLFIRE BUT
CAL FIRE IS EXPECTED IN THAT-
IN THAT PLAN TO PROVIDE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIXTY AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY. SO THE REST OF THOSE
ACRES ARE GOING TO COME FROM.
OTHER PARTNERS IN PRIVATE-
PRIVATE LANDS- CONSERVANCY
LANDS WERE WORKING WITH OUR OUR
SISTER- DEPARTMENTS IN- IN
RESOURCES TO EXPAND THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE BUT ALSO OTHER
FUELS TREATMENT. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THOSE THOSE- CRITICAL
RESOURCES AS WELL. THANK YOU
I'M BECAUSE OF TIME CONSTRAINTS
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO HAVE A RB AT
THIS HEARING BUT I'M WONDERING
HOW YOU WOULD CHARACTERIZE
QUALIFIERS WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM IN REGARDS TO PER
SCRIPT OR SCRUB FIRE. AND
WHETHER THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR PROVIDED TO LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS WITH THAT ASSISTED
WITH PERMITTING. PRESCRIBED
FIRES. CERTAINLY THAT'S A
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
WILL SAY THAT OUR RELATIONSHIP
HAS HAS BEEN CONTINUALLY
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER-
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE. AND THIS
IS HAVE BEEN HAPPENING FOR THE
PROBABLY THE LAST FIVE YEARS A
CONSISTENT INCREASE IN- TRUST
UP EACH OTHER AND HOW WE'RE-
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE-
BURNING PUBLIC- I MEAN THE
BURNING PROFESSIONALS AND THE
PUBLIC. THANKS AND WHAT ABOUT
GETTING MORE PRESCRIBED FIRE-
INSTITUTED ON LANDS LIKE STATE
PARKS AND DEMONSTRATION FORESTS
ARE THERE ANY PLANS RIGHT NOW
TO DO THAT. ABSOLUTELY AND OF
THE Z. CAL PTP- THAT- THAT MY
COLLEAGUE- JUST TALKED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY- IT WILL BE THE TOOL
THAT ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN IT'S
A TOOL THAT'S NOT JUST CAL
FIGHTER CENTRIC NOR IS IT JUST-
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCY
CENTRIC. IT IS VERY MUCH A TOOL
THAT CAN BE USED FOR THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE AND
PLANNING SO THAT WE DO- THE
RIGHT THINGS TO PUT THE RIGHT
FIRE ON THE RIGHT LANDED AT THE
RIGHT TIME. AND GET THAT
PRESCRIBED FIRE ACREAGE
INCREASED THANK YOU AND I HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MR DS BEFORE THE
WE DO THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
SWITCHING CHAIRS LET'S SEE IF
ANYBODY ELSE HAS QUESTIONS FOR
YOU SPECIFICALLY. OKAY OUR
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU CHIEF
PORTER- AND I SUPPOSE SAY THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOUR AGENCY
IS DONE TO PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTY- I GOT BACK YOU WAITED
AGAIN THIS YEAR AND A FIRE CAME
WITHIN A COUPLE OF MILES OF MY
HOUSE I'M REALLY GRATEFUL. FOR
EVERYTHING YOU GUYS DID SO I
HAVE A HOME TO LIVE IN NOW- BUT
OTHERS WERE NOT QUITE SO LUCKY.
APPRECIATE THAT YOU TOUCHED ON
THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM- TASK. FOR YOU
GUYS TO WORK ON. I THINK THERE
ARE EIGHT DEDICATED CRUISE
TOWARDS THAT ARE OUT I THINK
THEY'RE EIGHT CREWS THEY'RE
SUPPOSED THE WORKING ON FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS. YEAR
ROUND. CONSIDERING THE BACKLOG
OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IS THERE GOING TO BE A MOVE TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF THOSE
CREWS AND- AND THE DISPERSION
OF THEM. I DO UNDERSTAND I
HEARD. A TOTALLY UNDERSTANDABLE
BUT I HEARD THAT. THOSE SOME OF
THOSE CREWS WERE ACTUALLY DEAD
YOU KNOW PULLED OFF THEIR-
THEIR PREVENTION WORKED
ACTUALLY HELP FIGHT FIRES THIS
YEAR. MAYBE I'D MAYBE HURTING
CORRECTLY BUT I BY WAS AN
IMPRESSION THOSE ARE GONNA BE
DEDICATED YEAR ROUND CRUISE.
ONCE AGAIN I RECOGNIZE THIS WAS
AN UNPRECEDENTED YEAR. BUT IT'S
CLEAR THAT EVEN A PRESCRIBED
BURNS THAT I'VE SEEN THAT ARE
BEING SET UP THERE'S A LOT OF
VEGETATION WORK THAT GOES INTO
DOING THOSE BEFORE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DO THE BURN. SO I'M
BIG ON PREVENTION DOLLAR
PREVENTION SAVE SIX DOLLARS ON
TREATMENT- AND SO YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S HEALTHCARE OR
FORESTRY OR WHATEVER- ARE WE
GOING TO SEE MORE RESOURCES PUT
TOWARDS PREVENTION- AND THREE
SPECIFICALLY AROUND SOME OF
THESE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS. WELL REMEMBER WHAT
THAT IS- ABSOLUTELY- A- SPOT ON
QUESTION FOR WHERE WE ARE IN
INCOME YEAH A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS- THE IT'S TEN
ACTUALLY- FUELS DEDICATED FUELS
CREWS- THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
AND- YOU HIT IT I WON'T SAY IT
ANYMORE THAN THE WAY YOU DID WE
DID PUT THOSE FIREFIGHTERS ON-
THE- THE SHORTAGE OF RESOURCES
ON THE AMOUNT OF FIRE THAT WAS-BURNING ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE.
WE BROUGHT THEM BACK OFF OF
THOSE ASSIGNMENTS AS SOON AS WE
COULD THEY WENT BACK TO- DOING
FUELS PROJECT WORK AND JUST FOR
REFERENCE WE WERE BURNING- ON
PROJECTS UP TO THE WEEK BEFORE-
AUGUST FIFTEENTH WHICH IS WHEN
THE WHEN THE LIGHTNING HAPPENS.
AND THEN IN SEPTEMBER WE
ACTUALLY WERE ABLE WE FOUND A
COUPLE OF OPPORTUNITIES TO- DO
SOME OF CLEAN UP BURNING THAT
WE NEEDED TO AND THEN AND THEN
MORAN ON OCTOBER AND WERE
BURNING AS WE SPEAK- AND THOSE
CREWS WERE CRITICAL TO BEING
ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN- WHAT
THE BIGGER PICTURE A IS AND I
WILL BE LABOR IT- BUT OUR- OUR
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
INMATE CREWS THAT WE HAVE. IS
SOMETHING THAT'S ALSO A PART OF
THIS EXPANSION YES WE WANT TO
EXPAND OUR FUELS GROUP PROGRAM-
WE NEED TO BALANCE THAT WITH
WITH OUR- CONSERVATION CAMP
CREWS THAT ARE THAT ARE BOTH
INMATE AND CCC AS WELL AS FUELS
CREWS AND FIND A BALANCE- THAT
WORKS FOR A GETTING THIS WORK
DONE ON THE LANDSCAPE AND ALSO
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
FIREFIGHTERS WHEN WE DO HAVE-
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER. AND ONE
LAST PIECE IS A INMATE- FIRE
FIRE CREWS- WILL ACTUALLY ABOUT
45% OF THE DAYS THAT THEY WORK
THEIR WORK DAYS ABOUT 45% OF
THOSE DAYS ARE ON FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECT WORK- A
FIREFIGHTER HAND CREW IT'S
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE DAYS
OF THEIR- BUT THEIR WORK IS
DONE- I MEAN 75% OF THE TIME IS
ON- FUELS REDUCTION PROJECT
WORK. AND THEN- THE FUELS CREWS
OF COURSE THERE IN THE. 9295%
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU'RE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR CHIEF PORTER. OKAY WELL TO
PORTER ONCE AGAIN THANKS FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND THANKS
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR AGENCY DOES THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOOKS TO
ALL OF YOU IS AS HEROES RIGHT
NOW SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
I DON'T THINK WE CAN BRING
MISTER DE IS BACK. FOR
QUESTIONS. FOR ALL. THANKS OF
MISTER DE IS A SOME OF THE
OTHER PANELISTS MENTIONED THE
TIME THAT SEEK WOULD TAKES. AND
THE BURDEN IT PUTS ON SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS IN TERMS OF COST
AND TIME. AND I'M WONDERING HOW
MUCH TIME. HELLO THAT YOU
EXPECT CAL VTP TO BE ABLE TO
SAVE THE AVERAGE PROJECT IN
COMPLYING WITH SYKORA I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS
TO LOOK AT THAT FIRST OF ALL.
WE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE HAVE
DEDICATED STAFF TO THE MORE
BEING ACCOMPLISHED IN ABOUT
EIGHT WEEKS. TEN WEEKS A SUMMER
LONG OUTLINED TO HALF MONTHS
WHEREAS IN THE PAST. IF YOU'RE
ENGAGED IN THE PREPARATION OF
AN ER TO SUPPORT A PROJECT
THERE COULD BE UPWARDS OF A
YEAR OR MORE SO I THINK THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS VERA. IN
ADDITION TO THAT I THINK
THERE'S ALSO SOME ARE SOME
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO THE FACT THAT. MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES CAN BE CONTEMPLATED
UNDER CALVI TV PROJECT WHERE
THAT IS NOT AN AVAILABLE OPTION
I'M VERY STANDARD SUPER
ANALYSIS SO FOR INSTANCE. A AYE
WELL PLANNED PROJECT THAT
INCLUDES INITIAL TREATMENTS AS
WELL AS MAINTENANCE TREATMENTS
COULD BE EFFECTUATED OVER THE
COURSE OF. YEARS WHERE THOSE
STAIR STEPS OF THERE'S MULTIPLE
STEPS. OF INITIAL TREATMENT AND
MAINTENANCE. ALL RIGHT
TRIGGERED A NECESSITY FOR I.
SEQUENCE SO THE POINT IS
THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
SAVINGS UP FRONT. BUT I DO
BELIEVE THERE'S ALSO
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS IN TERMS OF
WELL PLANNED PROJECTS AS THEY
RELATE TO THE MAINSTREAM IT'S
IN THE FUTURE AS WELL. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WOULD. YEAH THANK
YOU COUPLE QUESTIONS SO WITH
REGARDS TO THAT- JUST THINKING
ABOUT THE SECRET PROCESS- IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT- GROUPS OF.
PEOPLE WITHIN A PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION ALL CONTEMPLATING
DOING SO SMALL BURNS IN AN AREA
COULD BAND TOGETHER TO CREATE A
SINGLE SEQUIN DOCUMENT. THAT
THAT MORE PROGRAMMATIC FOR THE
GENERAL AREA RATHER THAN HAVING
TO DO INDIVIDUAL SECRET
DOCUMENTS FOR PROPERTIES IT MAY
EVEN BE A JOINING TO ONE
ANOTHER IS THAT ENVISIONED
UNDER THE VTP PLAN. I DON'T IS
ENVISIONED IT'S ALSO BEEN
EFFECTUATED IN TERMS OF ONE OF
THE THREE PROJECTS. THIS
PROGRAM IS IN ITS INFANCY TEN
AND A HALF MONTHS ORDER SO. BUT
WE HAVE DO WE DON'T WIND UP
WALK PROJECT- IN YUBA COUNTY
THAT HAS MULTIPLE LANDOWNERS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. AND SO
THAT'S NOT ONLY CONTEMPLATED
IT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENED- SO YES
THE ANSWER IS YES YOUR QUESTION
AND ALSO- WHAT HASN'T BEEN
TOUCHED ON HERE AT ALL IS- THE
POTENTIAL FOR AND BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT TALKING OF WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WE'RE TALKING
MOST ABOUT PRESCRIBED FIRE BUT-
BUT THE USE. OF LET OF A
GRAZING FOR EXAMPLE- ACTIVITIES
TO HELP WITH- SOME OF THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ISSUES SO
FOR EXAMPLE I'LL GIVE YOU. LAST
YEAR. I SAW IT WAS MAY HAVE
BEEN THE YEAR BEFORE AND IT WAS
LAST YEAR- OF THE HOP LINDFIELD
STATION IN MY IN MY DISTRICT.
HAVING HAD A WONDERFUL EXAMPLE
OF WHERE GREAT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH GRAZING ON ONE SIDE OF A
FENCE. AND NOT GRAZING ON ON
THE OTHER. AND THE EFFECT THAT
THE FIRE THAT THE- MENDOCINO
COMPLEX FIRE HAD ON THE LAND.
AND IT WAS STARKLY- SHOULD
STARKLY DIFFERENT THE LAND THAT
HAD GRAZING- WILL WAS ON ITS
WAY TO RECOVERY THE LAND THEY
DID NOT HAVE ANY GRAZING ON IT.
LOOKED DEVASTATED- AND SO AS-
YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK TO THIS AND
I THINK I THINK EVEN THOUGH
GOVERNOR BROWN. HAS GOATS ON
HIS PROPERTY OCCASIONALLY TO
HELP WITH THAT- REMOVING-
BRUSHING THINGS FROM THERE- IT
IS THERE IS THERE ANY ARE
PROVISIONS TO HELP ADVANCE SOME
OF THOSE ACTIVITIES. THAT YOU
KNOW WE MONITOR OBVIOUSLY WANT
THESE GRAZING ACTIVITIES TO BE
SUSTAINABLE AND- RESPECTIVE OF
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE TO THE
LANDSCAPE. THAT THAT THESE THAT
THIS MIGHT BRING IS THAT IS IN
ANYWHERE ASSOCIATE WITH THE VTP
PROCESS. S. WE TALK. THAT THEY
TREATMENT ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
ANALYZE AND AVAILABLE FOR USE
THERE'S FIVE OF THEM.
PRESCRIBED FIRE BEING WINE
WHICH I HIGHLIGHTED TODAY BUT
ALSO TARGETED- BEVERLY OR
TARGETED GRAZING- CROWN
APPLICATION OF HERBICIDES-
MASTICATION EFFORTS WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY EQUIPMENT REMOVING
PRICE. AS WELL AS IMPROVED SO
THERE'S. FIVE TWO TIMES ARE
VERY VERY IS DEFINITELY ONE OF
THEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO WERE WITH US REMOTELY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY HEARING NONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR DS BAILEY
INTERESTING PRESENTATION VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. ARE MOVING
NOW TO OUR LAST. AND LARGEST
PANEL ON CULTURAL AND FIRE
RESILIENCY BURNING. A JOINING
US WILL BE BILL TRIPP DIRECTOR
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY FROM THE
CREW TRIED TO DEPARTMENT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. MARGO
ROBBINS CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CULTURAL
FIRE MANAGEMENT COUNCIL MEMBER
OF YUROK TRIBE. DAN PORTER
FIRST PROPRIETOR DIRECTOR FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
STEPHEN BYRD SENIOR MANAGER
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FORESTRY
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON- MISTER TRIP I BELIEVE
EUROPE FIRST AND I WILL. AGAIN
REMIND ALL OF THE PANELISTS TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR- DEVICES ON
MUTE UNLESS YOU'RE SPEAKING AND
TO PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF THE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER TRIP WELCOME. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. THIS IS MY FIRST ATTEMPT
AT DELIVERING TESTIMONY IN A
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I AM
THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
MANY OF THE RISKS POSED BY
WELFARE TODAY A REALLY APPARENT.
THE FIRE NARRATIVE IN MOST
EVERYTHING WE READ TODAY SEEMS
TO BEGIN WITH INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES HAVE USE FIRE FOR
MILLENNIA. THIS IS TRUE WE HAVE
ALSO FACED A STATE AND FEDERAL
SANCTIONED LEGACY OF
DISPOSSESSION
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AND
DIMINISHMENT OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY THROUGHOUT AN ERA
OF COLONIZATION FIRE EXCLUSION.
THE NATIONAL COHESIVE WILDLAND
FIRE MANAGEMENT STRATEGY ROLLED
OUT AS A DOCTOR IN A FIRE
MANAGEMENT FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. THIS IS THE
FOUNDATION OF WHAT FEDERAL AND
STATE AGENCIES ARE NOW CALLING
SHARED STEWARDSHIP. THIS
STRATEGY VERY SPECIFICALLY
DISCUSSES FEDERAL TRIBAL STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND NGO
PARTNERS AS AN ORDER OF
OPERATIONS OF SORTS A TEARING
OF RESPONSIBILITY WHEN IT COMES
TO THE RELATIONSHIPS AMONG
SOVEREIGNS. JURISDICTIONS IN
ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE PUBLIC AND
TRAVEL TRUS. HE TRIED TO REMAIN
AN AFTERTHOUGHT WE'RE CONTINUE
TO BE REQUIRED TO WAIVE THEIR
SOVEREIGNTY IF THEY WISHTO
RECEIVE FUNDING BE CONSIDERED
QUALIFIED TO BURN. OR HAVE THE
MEANS TO PARTICIPATE THE LOAN
LEAD. CALIFORNIA IS NOW ONE OF
THE STATE'S THAT CARRIES A
STEWARDSHIP AGREEMENT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE CREW
TRIBE ALSO HAS A STEWARDSHIP
AGREEMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE MAINTAIN A
VARIETY OF GRANTS AGREEMENTS
CONTRACTS AND COMPAQ'S. WE ARE
DEMONSTRATING HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO GET TO MEANINGFUL
SCALE WELL USING OUR STRENGTHS
TO OVERCOME EACH OTHER'S
WEAKNESSES MAKING US ALL
STRONGER AS WE LEARN TO WORK
BETTER TOGETHER. A FEW YEARS
AGO THE LEADER IN QUALIFIER ASK
ME WHAT IS TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
I WAS SO SHOCKED AT THE
QUESTION I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
ANSWER IT. THIS IS WHERE WE
STILL ARE AT AT THE
CONVERSATION TODAY. SIMPLY PUT
SOVEREIGNS IN CONTEMPORARY
SOCIETY HAVE CONSTITUTIONS THE
HOUSE LINE HER GOVERNANCE
SYSTEMS ARE JURISDICTIONAL
AUTHORITIES ARE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS OF SOCIAL POLITICAL
INFLUENCES THE PRINCIPLES THAT
WE OPERATE WITHIN. WHEN ONE
BEGINS TO TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT
SOVEREIGNTY IS THEY BEGIN TO
REALIZE THAT BEING FORCED FROM
AN INDIGENOUS GOVERNANCE SYSTEM
TO OPERATE UNDER AN OFFICIAL
CONSTITUTION AND IT'S A IS IN
ITSELF AN ACT OF SUFFERING
DIMINISHMENT. THE SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICES INVOLVED IN OUR
CURRENT REALITIES ARE
ASTOUNDING. YOU MAY BE THINKING
HOW DOES THIS EQUATE TO
ADDRESSING WILDFIRE RISK WELL
EXPANDING THE USE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE INCLUDING CULTURAL BURNING.
IN SEVEN MINUTES ALL I CAN DO
IS START THE CONVERSATION. WHAT
IS A RISK TO THE CURRENT PEOPLE
IS OUR VERY OWN INDIGENOUS
IDENTITY. OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
FIRE IS ONE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE NATURAL TO PLACE.
REVITALIZING OUR HUMAN FOR
RELATIONSHIPS IS PARAMOUNT TO
THIS THE PRESERVATION OF OUR
CULTURAL CULTURAL IDENTITY.
THIS IS WHY WE SEPARATE
PRESCRIBED FIRE FROM CULTURAL
BURNING IN THE DISCUSSION. WE
CAN PRESCRIBE ALL OF OUR WE
WANT AND WE CAN USE IT AS A
GREAT SHARED STEWARDSHIP. AND
SHARED LEARNING TOOL. BUT UNTIL
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH FIRE
RESUMES ITS PLACE AS A CULTURAL
PROCESS THAT ALIGNS WITH THE
INDIGENOUS SOCIAL ECOLOGICAL
FUNCTIONS RELEVANT TO OUR
HOMELANDS. WE WILL NOT EVEN
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF
IN HERE OF A FIRE SOLUTION
COUPLED WITH THE CHANGING
CLIMATE. THIS LATER FIRE JUST
BURNED ABOUT HALF THE HOUSES IN
HAPPY CAMP. THE CORRECT NAME
FOR HAPPY CAMP MEANS THE PLACE
WHERE HAZEL CREEK FLOWS THROUGH.
THAT TELLS A STORY IN ITSELF AS
TO THE CULTURAL VEGETATION
CHARACTERISTICS ONCE ABUNDANT
ON THE LANDSCAPE. A GOOD
PORTION OF THIS AREA WAS
CONVERTED BY THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE FOR THE PERPETUAL
PRODUCTION OF TIMBER. AT ONE
TIME WE WERE AND EXTENSIVELY IN
THE FIRST TWO MILES FROM OUR
VILLAGES. SPOTTING ON THE
SLITTER FIR WERE CONSISTENTLY
REPORTED AS OCCURRING TWO MILES
IN FRONT OF THE FIRE. THIS IS
NOT COINCIDENCE. WE'RE STARTING
OVER THERE NOW AND WE NEED TO
INTEGRATE OUR INDIGENOUS AND
WESTERN SCIENCES TO RESTORE
THESE LANDSCAPES BACK TO A
SOCIALLY ECOLOGICALLY RESILIENT
STATE. AS OPPOSED TO
APPROACHING. THE SITUATION FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY ALONE. THE
LATTER WILL CREATE CONDITIONS
THE BURN A HIGH SEVERITY AGAIN
AND AGAIN AT EXTREMELY HIGH
COSTS. THE CURRENT CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLAN BEGINS TO CALL
OUT WE USED TO START DOWN THIS
PATH OF ECO CULTURAL
REVITALIZATION. IT INTRODUCES
SOME OUTSIDE THE BOX THINKING
WHEN IT COMES TO ECONOMIC
MODELS CAPABLE OF PROVIDING FOR
SUSTAINABILITY AND CONSERVATION
WITHOUT CREATING MECHANISM FOR
SOCIAL ECONOMICS TO TRUMP
SOCIALLY ECOLOGICALLY SOUND
OUTCOMES. THE CALLS FOR THE
RECOGNITION OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND FOCUSED
ATTENTION ON WATER TO FISH
WILDLIFE PLANTS AND THE PEOPLE.
BUT THIS IN ITSELF IS JUST A
FOUNDATION A POSITIVE FUTURE
STILL NEEDS TO BE BUILT.
CREATING RELIABLE FUNDING
STREAMS DRESSING LIABILITY
ISSUES HONORING SOVEREIGNTY AND
RETHINKING APPROACHES TO
OVERCOME THE SUITE OF BARRIERS
WE FACE ARE ALL PART OF THE
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE TO SAY BUT
NO TIME TODAY. WE ARE WORKING
TO BUILD A GREATER COALITION
WORKING TO EXPAND UPON
COLLECTED THE A COLLECTIVE
INDIGENOUS VOICE AND WORKING TO
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
ON THE GROUND ACTION IN OUR
ANCESTRAL HOMELANDS AT THE SAME
TIME. WE SEE CREWS FUNDED FOR
PRESCRIBED BURNING BUT DON'T
SEE THEM COME HELP US WITH OUR
BURNS. WE CAN'T ASK FOR PERMITS
WITHOUT DIMINISHING OUR
SOVEREIGNTY. OUR PARTNERS CAN'T
GET PERMITS WHEN SELLING
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE HEIGHT OF
FIRE SEASON. WE CAN'T MAINTAIN
CONSISTENT CAPACITY BECAUSE WE
RELY ON GRANTS. WE ARE LIMITED
TO THE GRANTS WE CAN PURSUE
BECAUSE STATE LAW POLICY AND
REGULATION HAS NOT CONSIDERED
THE NEEDS LET ALONE THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES. THERE ARE MANY SUCH
TOPICS THAT ARE RIPE FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION. THIS
TESTIMONY IS A CALL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMOVE ANY UP
POSSIBLE OBSTACLES THAT LIMIT
TRAVEL BURNING PRACTICES AND
FOR THE STATE TO FULL SUPPORT
AND LEARN FROM OUR CULTURAL
BURNING PRINCIPLES. THE STATE
SHOULD NOT BE PROPPING. THE
STATE SHOULD BE PROPPING UP
TRAVEL CAPACITY NOT LIMITING IT
THANK YOU FOR STARTING THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU MISTER
TRIP AND IF YOU DON'T MIND-
STAYING AROUND UNTIL THE END OF
THE PANEL FOR QUESTIONS. AND
BEFORE WE GO TO THE NEXT
PANELIST I DO JUST WANT TO SAY-
THAT YOU'RE RIGHT THAT SEVEN
MINUTES IS CERTAINLY NOT ENOUGH
TIME FOR US TO A FULLY ENGAGED
IN ALL OF THESE ISSUES BUT I
ALSO WILL COMMIT TO CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION WITH YOU-
AFTER- THIS PANEL'S COMMENCED
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT YEAR- NEXT
WILL GO TO MARGO ROBBINS.
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. I CREATE NEXT NOW MARGO
ROBBINS KEYCHAIN ACTOR YOU ARE
TRIBAL MEMBER CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CULTURAL FIRE MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL AS WELL AS KOHLI FOR
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE BURN
NETWORK. I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO BE HERE TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE A LITTLE INFORMATION
TO GIVE YOU A SMALL GLIMPSE
INTO WHAT FIRE MEANS TO US AS
NATIVE PEOPLE AND HOW THE
CULTURAL FIRE MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT
SUCCESSFUL IN SAFELY RETURNING
FIRE TO THE LAND. THE CULTURAL
FIRE MANAGEMENT COUNCIL SEE FMC
IS A COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION LOCATED ON THE
YUROK RESERVATION IN FAR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. OUR
COMMUNITY IDENTIFIED FIRE AS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING.
ON THE USE OF FIRE THE
COMMUNITY IS ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF FUEL BUILDUP ON
THE LAND WILL OUR ELDERS BE
ABLE TO ESCAPE IF THERE'S A
WILDFIRE. THE C. A B. M. C. WAS
FORMED AS A MEANS TO REINSTATE
TRADITIONAL BURN PRACTICES AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY FROM
WILDFIRE. ARE THE SLIDE SHOWING
COULD SOMEBODY YES THEY ARE FLY
YES YES YOU'RE NOW ON THE I
THINK THE SECOND SLIDE OUT
WANTED NUMBER TWO PLEASE.
NATIVE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN BURNING
FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS FIRE IS
A NATURAL PART OF THE ECOSYSTEM
AND WE AS HUMANS ARE PART OF
NATURE. OUR LAND SISTERS LIVED
IN A SPIRITUALLY BALANCED
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE LAND AND
FIRE WAS A CRITICAL PART OF
MAINTAINING THIS BALANCE. IN
ORDER TO MEET OUR SACRED
OBLIGATION TO CARE FOR THE LAND
AND THE PLANTS AND ANIMALS THAT
LIVE THERE WE MUST USE BUYERS
TO METHODICALLY BURN FROM THE
COASTLINE TO THE HIGH COUNTRY.
THIS LAND EVOLVED WITH FIRE
SOME PLANTS ARE FIRE DEPENDENT
WHILE OTHERS BENEFIT FROM FIRE.
TRADITIONALLY EACH FAMILY EACH.
TRIBE TOOK PERSONAL RESPONSE.
FOR ME THE LAND WITH BUYER.
NATIVE PEOPLE HAVE AN INTERNET
CONNECTION TO THE LAND AND
INTRICATE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ELEMENT THAT AFFECT THE USE OF
BUYER SO MUCH SO OUR ANCESTORS
WERE ABLE TO BURN YEAR ROUND.
IT'S TIME TO RETURN TO THIS
TRADITIONAL PRACTICE OF CARING
FOR THE LAND. IT'S TIME FOR
TRIBES GOVERNMENT AGENCIES NGOS
AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO JOIN
FORCES TO RETURN THE CYCLES OF
BURNING FROM THE COASTLINE TO
THE HIGH COUNTRY. PRESCRIBED
FIRE CAN BE USED TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD AND IMPACT OF WILDFIRE
AND AS A LAND RESTORATION TOOL.
THE CULTURAL FIRE MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL THE YUROK AND KARUK
TRIBES HAVE BEEN. DOING
CULTURAL BURNS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW WE'VE ADAPTED
TRADITIONAL FIRE PRACTICES. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE CHANGING
LANDSCAPE AND LAWS WE NOW LIVE
WITH. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. TWICE
A YEAR ONCE IN THE SPRING AND
ONCE IN THE FALL SEE FMC IN THE
YUROK TRIBE PLANS AND
IMPLEMENTS A CULTURAL BURN
TRAINING EXCHANGE TRACKS ON THE
UPPER YUROK RESERVATION WE BURN
ON PRIVATE VIEW LAND AS WELL AS
LAND OWNED BY THE YUROK TRIBE.
FIREFIGHTERS FROM ACROSS THE US
AND ABROAD COME HELP US BURN
OUR LAND WHILE INCREASING THEIR
FIREFIGHTER QUALIFICATIONS.
TRICKS EVENTS LAST BETWEEN ONE
TO TWO WEEKS AND PROVIDE HANDS
ON EXPERIENCE IN PRESCRIBED
FIRE AN ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION
WHILE CREATING FIRE BREAKS FOR
WILDFIRE PROTECTION. THESE LOW
INTENSITY CONTROLLED BURNS ARE
GOOD FOR THE LAND WATER PLANTS
ANIMALS AND THE PEOPLE. AS
NATIVE PEOPLE WE DEPEND ON FIRE
FOR THE CONTINUANCE OF OUR
CULTURE. SOME OF THE PLANTS WE
ON FOR BASKET WEAVING NEED FIRE
IN ORDER TO REPRODUCE OUR
TRADITIONAL SOURCES SUCH AS
DEER SALMON ACORNS AND BERRIES
ALL BENEFIT FROM FIRE. FIRE
IMPROVES ANIMAL HABITAT
INCREASES FOREST RESILIENCE AND
BIO DIVERSITY THE BIO CHAR LEFT
IN ITS WAKE MAKES THE SOIL MORE
FERTILE PURIFIES THE WATER AND
SHE QUAESTORS CARBON IN THE
SOIL. A BY PRODUCT OF
TRADITIONAL BURN PRACTICES IS
WILDFIRE PROTECTION. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SOMETIMES DURING TRACKS
IT RAINS AND WE CAN'T DO
BROADCAST BURNS THIS IS ONE
PILE BURNS COME IN HANDY. C.
FMC DOESN'T GENERALLY PREFER
PILE BURNING AS IT BURNS REALLY
HOT IN ONE PLACE FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME AND MAY KILL THE
SOIL. SOMETIMES IT'S THE ONLY
OPTION GO. PILE BURNING REDUCES
THE FUEL LOAD BUT DOES NOT HAVE
ALL THE BENEFITS OF BROADCAST
BURNS. NEXT SLIDE. C. FMC IN
THE KAROO TRIBE HAVE STARTED A
FAMILY LED BURN PROGRAM TO
BRING BACK THIS TRADITIONAL WAY
OF BURNING WE HELP FAMILIES
BURN AROUND THEIR HOMES AND
GATHERING AREAS FROM MID
OCTOBER THROUGH APRIL THIRTY
FIRST CALIFORNIA DOESN'T IT
THIS IS DURING THE TIME CAL
FIRE DOESN'T REQUIRE OR PERMIT
OR A BURN PLAN. WE HOST
COMMUNITY CLASSES ON SAFE BURN
PRACTICES HELP PEOPLE PREP
THEIR LAND SO THE FIRE STAYS
INSIDE THE INTENDED BURN AREA
AND BRING OUR FIRE ENGINE A
STAND BY ON THE DAY OF THE BURN
MORE AND MORE FAMILIES ARE
STARTING TO USE FIRE AGAIN. CFO
M. C. ALSO HAS A PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN WE USE MORE
MULTIPLE MEDIA SOURCES. TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF PRESCRIBED BURNS WE
ALSO HAVE A PROGRAM IN THE
SCHOOLS TO TEACH. STUDENTS
ABOUT GOOD FIRE BEFORE THE
CUPBOARD PANDEMIC THE LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOL OFFERED A BASIC
THIRTY TWO FIREFIGHTING CLASS.
TWO OF THE STUDENTS THAT
GRADUATED WITHIN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS YEARS ARE NOW ON THE
YUROK TRIBE FIRE CREW. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. THE WORLD IS
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE MEGA FIRES
AND PROP PRESCRIBED FIRE IS
COMING TO THE FORE IS ONE OF
THE PRIMARY STRATEGIES. THE
ISSUE OF SMOKE IS OFTEN A
STICKING POINT AND THERE IS A
NEED TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THEIR SMOKE OPTIONS.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A NO
SMOKE OPTION. WE WILL EITHER
HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF WOOD
SMOKE FROM PRESCRIBED BURNS OR
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF TOXIC SMOKE
FROM WILDFIRES MUCH CHOOSE
THEIR SMOKE. TODAY I'M SHARING
THE STRATEGIES THAT WE AS A
NONCE SMALL AS A WE AS A SMALL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION HAVE
USED TO BRING FIRE BACK TO THE
LAND TO LET OTHERS KNOW THAT IF
WE CAN DO IT OTHERS CAN TOO.
OUR EFFORTS ARE REPLICABLE IN
OTHER PLACES. PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS ARE CONSTANTLY
REACHING OUT TO US ASKING US TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO SAFELY BURN
THEIR LAND. BUYER MUST BE
RETURNED TO THE HANDS OF THE
PEOPLE SO THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PROTECT THEIR HOMES FROM
WILDFIRE AND REAP THE BENEFITS
FIRE PROVIDES. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. CAL FIRE IS GEARING UP
TO IMPLEMENT A BURN BOSS
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS SEE FMC
PLANS TO DESIGN A TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR LANDOWNERS TO GAIN
THE PRACTICAL KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE TO ATTAIN THIS
CERTIFICATION THIS WILL HELP
PUT FIRE BACK INTO THE HANDS OF
THE PEOPLE. PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
CAN BURN THEIR LAND WHILE
TRIBES GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
NGOS BURN AT A LANDSCAPE LEVEL
WE SHOULD BE DOING LANDSCAPE
LEVEL BACK BURN AND BEFORE
WHILE SUCH BUYERS SEASON STARTS
AS A METHOD OF WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. IF WE WANT TO
EXPAND THE USE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE WE MUST UTILIZE EVERY
AVAILABLE RESOURCE IN EVERY
AVAILABLE BURN WINDOW TO
REINSTITUTE TRADITIONAL FIRE
REGIMES WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
BUILD A CULTURE OF UYERS THAT
IS INCLUSIVE OF ALL ETHNICITIES
AND SOCIAL ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF
CALIFORNIA IN FACT ALL STATES
HAD A GROSS NEGLIGENCE STANDARD
FOR PRESCRIBED BURN LIABILITY.
PRESCRIBED BURN PROGRAMS NEED
TO BE FULLY FUNDED AND STAFFED
CULTURAL BURN SHOULD BE EXEMPT
FROM AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS
AND FINALLY WE NEED TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE ABOUT FIRE THERE
IS SUCH A THING AS GOOD FIRE IT
IS A NECESSARY PART OF THE
ECOSYSTEM. EVERY DAY IS A GOOD
DAY TO BURN SOMEWHERE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
DON'T MIND- STAYING AROUND
UNTIL AFTER FOR QUESTIONS
PRESHEAF THE POWER POINT. I
NEXT WE HAVE DAN PORTER FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN
PORTER I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY. JUST SHARE
WHY WE THINK PRESCRIBED FIRE
TOGETHER WITH ECOLOGICALLY
BASED THAN IN OUR FORESTS IS
CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE. BEGAN APPLYING PRESCRIBED
FIRE TO ITS NATURE PRESERVES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. AND NOW
LEADS THE LARGEST NON
GOVERNMENTAL PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM IN THE NATION. TODAY
OUR SCIENTISTS AND FIRE
PRACTITIONERS CONVENE AND
PARTICIPATE IN DOZENS OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAININGS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY EVERY YEAR.
FOR THE RECORD I'M SUBMITTING
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY'S CASE
FOR ECOLOGICAL FORESTRY THIS
EIGHT PAGE PUBLICATION
SUMMARIZES HOW SELECTIVE
THINNING AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
WHEN USED TOGETHER CAN RESTORE
FOREST BIODIVERSITY. AND
MODERATE THE RISK OF HIGH
INTENSITY WILDFIRES. REGARDING
THE SCIENCE I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT THREE KEY
FINDINGS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FIRST WHEN THEIR NAME IN FORCES
FOLLOWED BY PRESCRIBED FIRE THE
RISK OF FLAMES REACHING THE
TOPS OF TREES OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CROWN FIRE. IS REDUCED.
SECOND THE BENEFITS OF THINNING
SERVICE ON LADDER FUELS IN
FOREST LAST LONGER. WHEN
FOLLOWED UP WITH PRESCRIBED
FIRE. THIRD THEN IN A
PRESCRIBED FIRE TOGETHER IS
BROADLY EFFECTIVE IN MANY
WESTERN FIRE ADAPTED FOR US AND
AS A AS HAS BEEN TOUCHED ON
EARLIER IS ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO REDUCE FOREST
FUELS. AND FINALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS RESEARCH APPLIES TO FIRE
ADOPTED FOREST COMMUNITIES.
OTHER HABITAT TYPES MAY REQUIRE
ALTERNATIVE METHODS SUCH AS
MECHANICAL RESTAURANT.
REDUCTION AND THE CREATION OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. DESPITE THE
OVERWHELMING BENEFITS A
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND RECENT
INCREASES IN STATE FUNDING WE
CONTINUE TO FALL VERY SHORT OF
OUR PRESCRIBED FIRE ANNUAL
ACREAGE TARGETS. MORE FUNDING
WILL CERTAINLY HELP GET US TO
SCALE BUT ONLY IF WE ADDRESS
OTHER BARRIERS CURRENTLY
LIMITING THE EXPANDED USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE. THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IS WORKING ON WITH
ITS PARTNERS TO ADDRESS TWO
SUCH PLAYERS THAT'LL COVER NEXT.
AND THESE HAVE BEEN TOUCHED ON
BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AS WELL.
GROWING SKILLED WORKFORCE IN
ADDITION TO PRESCRIBE OUR
TRAININGS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY'S CALIFORNIA
OFFICE STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
EFFORTS TO RAPIDLY EXPAND THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE WORKFORCE A
GREAT EXAMPLE IS OCCURRING THE
TAHOE NATIONAL FOREST WE ARE
WHERE WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO PLAN PRESCRIBED
FIRE ACROSS SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED ACRES. OF FIRE PRONE
FOREST AS PART OF THE FRENCH
MEADOWS PROJECT IN THE AMERICAN
RIVER WATERSHED. BY USING A
COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT WITH THE
FOREST SERVICE THE CONSERVANCY
IS ABLE TO RAISE FUNDS FOR A
VARIETY OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SOURCES. AND HIRE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS TO ADVANCE THE WORK.
A KEY INGREDIENT TO OUR SUCCESS
HAS BEEN A HIGH QUALITY WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS. THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED A SKILL CONTRACTORS
WHO LEAD OR BACKSTOPS. HE
FUNCTIONS AND HE PRESCRIBED
FIRE ROLES FOR EXAMPLE THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IS WORKING
WITH FIRESTORM. A FULL SERVICE
PRESCRIBE OUR CONTRACTOR WHO
CAN DEPLOY HUNDREDS OF
PRESCRIBED PARK REMEMBERS AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE. THE SECOND
LARGE BARRIER THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH THE STATE
DIRECTLY IS TO ENSURE. THE
BERMAN WINDOWS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE CAN BE USED IN
CAPITALIZE ON. TO ENSURE A
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS ARE
SAFE WE WORK WITH EXPERIENCE
FIRE PROFESSIONALS
METEOROLOGIST AMERICA ALL THE
REGULATORS. TO PRECISELY TIME
ARE PERMITS OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE BYRD WINDOWS. EFRAIN OWENS
DON'T COOPERATE FOR A
PARTICULAR PROJECT LOCATION FOR
SAFETY SAKE WE MUST MAKE A NO
GO DECISION. SUCH CIRCUMSTANCES
CAN EXPEND PRECIOUS RESOURCES
AND DELAY PROJECTS FOR YEARS.
RECENTLY A NO GO DECISION IN
THE SIERRA NEVADA MOTIVATED THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND CAL. TO
DEVELOP A NEW FORM OF FUNDING
AGREEMENT THAT GIVES ARE
PRESCRIBED FIRE TEAMS MORE
OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY. BY
DEFINING MULTIPLE ELIGIBLE FIRE
LANDSCAPES INSTEAD OF JUST ONE
PROJECT SITE. AND MONITORING
FOR FAVORABLE BURN WINDOWS
ACROSS ALL ELIGIBLE LANDSCAPE
SIMULTANEOUSLY. WE ARE
INCREASING OUR ODDS OF
CAPTURING ONE OR MORE BURN
WINDOWS DURING THE BURNING
SEASON. WE THINK THAT THIS KIND
OF FLEXIBLE FUNDING ARRANGEMENT
WILL BE CRITICAL TO EXPAND
INDIA'S FIRST PRIVATE HIRE IN
THE FUTURE. SO IN SUMMARY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IS A LEADER
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE SCIENCE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
ACROSS NORTH AMERICA IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S OVERLY
DENSE FORESTS WIDESPREAD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LARGE
POPULATION CENTERS MAKE
EXPANDING THE USE OF ECOLOGICAL
FORESTRY AND PRESCRIBED FIRE.
AND PRESCRIBED FIRE IN OUR
FORCE CHALLENGING. BUT AMONG
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE ECOLOGICAL
THINNING PRESCRIBED FIRE ARE
THE BEST HOPE WE HAVE FOR
GETTING OUT OF OUR CURRENT
BALLPARK PRICES. DO YOU DOES
THAT AND THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
INTENDS TO CONTINUE ITS WORK
WITH ITS PARTNERS. ON THREE
FRONTS NUMBER ONE WILL CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR INCREASED
FUNDING BOTH ON THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVEL FREE EAT PRESCRIBED
PHARMACOLOGICAL FORESTRY.
SECOND WE WILL REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS TO GROW A HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKFORCE INCLUDING
STATE FEDERAL. AND PRIVATE FIRE
PROFESSIONALS AND THIRDS WILL
DEVELOP NEW POLICIES AND
PRACTICES CURRENTLY LIMITING
PRESCRIBED FIRE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAVING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PORTER
WILL COME BACK TO AFTER THE
NEXT SPEAKER FOR QUESTIONS
PRESHEAF THE A PRESENTATION.
NEXT AND LAST WE HAVE SOME
STUFF IN BIRD. WE CAN. MISTER
BYRD ARE YOU THERE. I THINK
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO REACH OUR
WITNESS RIGHT NOW. I THINK THAT
WHILE WE TRIED TO REACH HIM WHY
DON'T WE SEE IF ANY. WHY DON'T
WE BRING- THIS BACK TO THE
PANEL TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. NOT RIGHT NOW.
ARE
WE THERE YET. HI IS THIS WE ARE
NOT IN THE MALL MISTER BYRD ARE
YOU THERE. YEAH ALL RIGHT HERE
NOW SORRY ABOUT THAT WE CAN
HEAR YOU OKAY WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY YOU HAVE SEVEN MINUTES
PLEASE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. EXCELLENT THANK YOU ALL
TRY TO KEEP A GREAT BUT THANK
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY I APPRECIATE. ALL THE
OPTIMISM AND HOPE FROM OUR
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS- THAT IS
GREAT AND- MISTER PORTER SET
THAT UP VERY NICELY SO- BY
PROFESSION I'VE BEEN A WILDLIFE
BIOLOGIST MICHAEL DURING MY
CAREER. AND BEEN HERE ON THESE
LANDS FOR ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
YEARS NOW- WE HAVE TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRES THAT WE MANAGE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS YEAR
NATIONAL FOREST. WHICH SITS
RIGHT IN BETWEEN YOU SEVENTY
NATIONAL PARK IN SEQUOIA KINGS
CANYON NATIONAL PARK. AND WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED- UNEVEN AGE
MANAGEMENT SINGLE TREE
SELECTION WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
CHAMBER AND WE HAVE BEEN
PRESCRIBED BURNING. FOR ABOUT
THIRTY YEARS NOW. OUT WITH
QUITE A SMALL STAFF AND- THOSE
EFFORTS STARTED WITH THE
POOREST YOUR NAME JOHN BOUT AND
THEY HAVE JUST CONTINUED. WITH
ALL OF US THAT ARE HERE TODAY.
AND WE- RIGHT THE MID. OF THE
CREEK FIRE SO ON FRIDAY NIGHT
SEPTEMBER FOURTH THE CREEK FIRE
STARTED. BY GATHERED A MORNING
IT WAS. HEADING DIRECTLY
TOWARDS OUR NORTHERN BOUNDARY
OF OUR PROPERTY WE WERE
DIRECTLY IN THE PATH OF THAT
FIRE. AND ON SATURDAY THAT WAS
SEPTEMBER FIFTH. THE FIRE
WEATHER WAS JUST TERRIBLE THAT
DAY IT WAS- QUITE HOT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING SOME- DOWN CANYON
WINDS ALL DAY SOME WHAT WE
WOULD CALL A MOTOR WINDS DOWN
SOUTH YOU CALLED SANTA ANA
WINDS.THEY WORK SEVERE LIKE
FANTA WINS BUT THEY WERE STILL
WARM AND DRY AND THE FIRE
BEHAVIOR THAT WE WERE
WITNESSING THAT DAY WAS PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY- IT WAS CONSUMING
LAND AT A RAPID RATE-
ULTIMATELY BECAME. MAYBE THE
BIGGEST SINGLE FIRE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND WE
ALSO MEASURED THE HIGHEST LOOP.
IN THE HISTORY OF FIRESIDE I
HEARD- OFFICIAL TELL ME THAT
THEY MEASURE THIS WOMB AT FIFTY
THOUSAND FEET IN ELEVATION AND
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO GET A MOVE
LIKE THAT. WOULD YOU HAVE
INTENSE FIRE BEHAVIOUR COUPLED.
WITH THE- VERY YOUR LOOKING AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAD ON THE NASH
FOREST ALL THE US FOR US. WE
HAD CONDUCTED. PROBABLY FOR THE
PAST THREE YEARS SOME
PRESCRIBED BURNING AND SOME
PILE BERNIE ALL ALONG THE NORTH
BOUNDARY OF OUR PROPERTY AND SO
WHEN THE CREEK FIRE ROARED UP
OUT OF THE BIG CREEK CANYON. IT
HIT OUR PROPERTY BOUNDARY AND
JUST SAT RIGHT DOWN ON THE
GROUND AND CAL FIRE WAS ABLE TO
STOP IT THEY'RE REALLY ON A
SINGLE LANE DIRT ROAD IN THE
MIDDLE THE POOREST. PRETTY THEY
COULDN'T STOP BACKFIRE ANYWHERE
ELSE ON DAY ONE TWO AND THREE
EXCEPT ON OUR LAND THAT FORCED
IT TO ROTATE AROUND OUR LAND.
WHICH GAVE YOU- CAL FIRE IN
SOME OF OUR PERSONNEL ABOUT AN
EXTRA TWENTY FOUR HOURS. TO
PREPARE THE PALACE SHAVER LAKE.
AND LIKE TOM MENTIONED EARLIER
THERE WERE FIVE PROJECTS THAT
WERE DONE IN FRESNO MADERA
COUNTY THAT WERE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S LEFT. AND SO REALLY
IT THE FACT THAT WE STOPPED
THAT BUYERS FORGET AROUND OUR
PROPERTY ON DAY TWO. COUPLED
WITH ALL THOSE YOUR BREAK
PROJECT THAT HAD TAKEN PLACE IN
AND AROUND OUR LANDS AND OTHER
PRIVATE LANDS AROUND THE COUNTY
SHAVER LAKE AND THEN JUST- A
PRETTY HER WROTE EFFORT ON THE
PART OF FIREFIGHTERS. IT WAS
THE COMBIATION OF THOSE THREE
THINGS. THAT REALLY STAYED THE
COUNTY CHEVROLET ANY ONE OF
THOSE THREE THINGS ARE TAKEN
OUT OF THE EQUATION I REALLY
DOUBT THAT THE TOWNSHIP RELATED
HERE TODAY. SO REALLY WE STAND
HERE AS- I THINK A PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE ESTIMATES. THAT
YOU'LL MANAGEMENT. ARE
PRESCRIBED BURNING ARE THESE
KINDS OF PRACTICES. AND NAY
LANDSCAPES. FROM REALLY
AGGRESSIVE- WILDFIRES IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO ENGAGE IN IN CALIFORNIA
I APPRECIATE SO MANY THINK THAT
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT LIKE. WE HAVE
TO USE EVERY TOOL THAT WE HAVE
AT OUR DISPOSAL TO TRY AND
COMBAT THIS OP PROBLEM WE HAVE
DUG A HOLE. FOR OURSELVES IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST
HUNDRED YEARS WE'VE ALLOWED OUR
WILD LANDSCAPES TO BECOME MORE
AND. MORE DANCE AND WE'RE
SEEING THESE BY. THAT WE WAITED
BROKE EVERYTHING AT THEM AND
YET WE COULD NOT IT THEM OR
SLOW THE DOWN UNLESS WE'VE DONE.
SOME THAT YOU MAY. IT GOING TO
TAKE UP. A COUPLE DECADES
YOU'RE SEE SOME- YOU REALLY
NEED TO RETURN ON OUR
INVESTMENT BUT I HOPE THAT ALL
OF US HERE IN CALIFORNIA CAN
START MOVING OUR FORESTS AND
OUR WILD LANDSCAPES. IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. FOR US WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS JUST TRYING
TO CREATE THE NUMBER OF TREES
PER ACRE DOUBTS WILL MORE
NATURAL MORE HISTORIC LEVEL. ON
OUR LANDS WE PROBABLY HAD A
HUNDRED FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TREES PER ACRE ON
ADJACENT FEDERAL LANDS WE WERE
LOOKING AT SIX SEVEN EIGHT
HUNDRED TREES PER ACRE AND 60%
OF THOSE TREES WERE DEBT. SO
THERE WAS REALLY NO CHANCE- TO
STOP THIS FIRE OUT IN OF COURSE
LANDSCAPE. THAT LOOKS LIKE THAT
THAT MORE THAN HALF DEBT. SO
ANYWAY I COULD GO ON FOR HOURS
WHAT I WOULD RATHER GET STOP
RIGHT THERE AND ALLOW QUESTIONS
TO BE- TALK TO THE PANEL AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS I HAVE I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS I'LL KICK IT OFF-
FIRST FOR MISTER TRIP IF WE CAN
BRING HIM BACK UP PERHAPS IN
THE VIDEO- AND MAYBE- MAYBE MR
PORTER ALSO ONCE TRIED TO
ANSWER THIS WHICH IS. I'M
WONDERING HOW MUCH OF THE STATE
TRADITIONALLY HAD CULTURAL
BURNS WAS THAT THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- OR CERTAIN
REGIONS ONLY. AND YOU KNOW OF
COURSE GOING BACK THE STATE WAS
A LOT LESS POPULATED THAN IT IS
NOW AND I'M WONDERING WHETHER
THERE WERE. IT WOULD WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS OF ACRES
A YEAR THOUSANDS OF ACRES A
YEAR YOU KNOW WHAT WERE THE
TRADITIONAL CULTURAL BURN
PATTERNS WITH THAT OF LOOKED
LIKE A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. GOOD QUESTION- HI I
CAN'T REALLY SPEAK FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE STATE. I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INDIGENOUS CULTURES-
ORIGINATING- THROUGHOUT- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT IN OUR
AREA I'M IN A IN THE
NORTHWESTERN CORNER OF THE
STATE- WE LIVED IN PERMANENT
HOUSES MADE OUT OF SPLIT PORT
ORFORD CEDAR PLANKS. SO WE LIVE
IN PERMANENT WOODEN STRUCTURES-
MY MUCH LIKE WE DO TODAY AND WE
EMPLOYED FIRE A VAST SCALE
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE. VERY
INTENSIVELY WITHIN THE FIRST
TWO MILES LIKE I SPOKE TO
EARLIER. BUT ALSO ALONG THE
STRATEGIC RIDGELINES WHERE WE
WOULD BE DEPENDING ON ON.
HUNTING FOR LARGE GAME AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND SO THE
ALSO WE HAD CEREMONIAL BURNING
PRACTICES THAT OCCURRED IN THE
SAME PLACE- EVERY YEAR- THAT
WERE LANDSCAPE. SCALE WERE YOU
KNOW ONE NOW RIGHT INDICATOR
SHOWED ITSELF- FIRES WOULD BE
LET AND THEY WOULD BURN. FOR
THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR. OUR
AREA BEING SURROUNDED BY
MULTIPLE WILDERNESS AREAS IS.
IS THE TYPE OF PLACE WHERE A
PERSON COULD PROBABLY-
REINSTATE A LOT OF THIS
TRADITIONAL TIMING- DUE TO THE
FACT THAT IS ONLY TWO PERCENT-
DEVELOPED AND MOST OF THAT
BEING DOWN IN THE RIVER
CORRIDOR LIKE WE WERE
TRADITIONALLY- HOWEVER. IN
OTHER AREAS YOU KNOW ITS THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT- DEFINITELY-
CREATES CHALLENGES WHERE'S IF
PERHAPS MAYBE THE INDIGENOUS
CULTURE WAS MORE OF A NOMADIC
IN NATURE- PERHAPS DEPENDING ON
THE SEASONALITY OF THE USE OF
THE RESOURCES EMPLOYED IN A
GIVEN AREA- MAYBE THE PEOPLE OF
THE POLICE WOULD LIKE TO FIRE
ON THEIR WAY OUT. AND WALK AWAY
FOR THE SEASON. THAT BEHAVING
THAT WAY WOULD BE DIFFICULT
TODAY IF THERE'S A TOWN BUILT
THEIR BUT YOU KNOW EMPLOYING SO
MORE FOCUSED- PRESCRIBED FIRE-
PRACTICES- YOU KNOW WITH SOME
OF THE TOOLS WE DIDN'T HAVE
BEFORE LIKE FIRE ENGINES. AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. MEANS THAT WE
STILL COULD EMPLOY SOME
BURNING- TWO CHIEFS OF SIMILAR
OBJECTIVES AND PROTECT HOMES M.
IN THOSE AREAS AS WELL IT WOULD
JUST HAVE TO BE- MUCH MORE
PLANNED- AND CARRIED OUT. A LOT
MORE STRATEGICALLY. RIGHT. I'M
SORRY I DID UP MY MICROPHONE ON
SO I'M ASSUMING THAT THE BURNS
OF CULTURAL BRANDS WERE MOSTLY
HAPPENING RIGHT AROUND A NEAR
WHERE PEOPLE WERE LIVING AND
THEN AND FURTHER DEEP INTO THE
WILDERNESS IT WOULD BE ONLY A
LIGHTNING STRIKE THAT SORT OF
EVENT SO THERE MIGHT BE PARTS
THAT THE FORCE THAT ONE WERE
AND BURNING. TO MUCH. I'M I'M
WONDERING. YOU MENTIONED A FEW
OF THE WAYS THAT WE COULD HELP
REMOVE SOME OF THE VERY
BARRIERS THAT YOU FACE ARE
THERE OTHER WAYS THAT THE STATE
COULD BE A PARTNER WITH YOU AND
OTHER TRIBES IN THE CULTURAL
BURNS. YES YEAH I WOULD GO
AHEAD AND CLARIFY THAT FURTHER
OUT IN THE WILDERNESS- BURNING
WAS OCCURRING- IT JUST MOSTLY
WAS STRATEGIC IN NATURE SO THE
WITH LIGHTNING MISSIONS WOULD
BE CONFINED TO SMALLER AREAS
BUMPING UP AGAINST RECENT OUR
FOOTPRINTS. ALONG THE RIDGE
SYSTEMS. A WORD WORD LIGHTNING
GENERAL STRIKES- BUT- AND WE
HAVE A LOT A LOT OF INSTANCES
WHERE WHERE THAT IS HELD IN OUR
ORAL- KNOWLEDGE TRANSMISSION.
BUT THERE WHEN IT COMES TO
PARTNERING WITH THE STATE TO
OVERCOME BARRIERS THERE THERE
ARE A LOT OF WAYS WE CAN DO
THAT- WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING WITH
MAGUIRE'S OFFICE- ABOUT-
DEVELOPING A FUNDING SOURCE-
STARTING AT ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR- TO.
TO BE ABLE TO WORK TO PARTNER
WITH TRIBES I'M MORE OF A
NEGOTIATED BASIS ON A SOVEREIGN
TO SOVEREIGN LEVEL- TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH SOME WAYS- TO
ACTUALLY WORK TOGETHER- AS
SOVEREIGNS TO OVERCOME THESE
ISSUES YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES
TO THINGS LIKE- AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT. YOU KNOW THERE ARE
THERE ARE SOME STRENGTHS YOU
KNOW I SPOKE A LOT TO USING
STRENGTH TO OVERCOME
WEAKNESSES- THERE ARE SOME
STRINGS TO THINGS LIKE TO
TRAVEL AUTHORITY RULE- IN THE
CLEAN AIR ACT- TO WHERE TRIBES
CAN ACTUALLY DEVELOP THEIR OWN
PLANS TO MAGIC MANAGER QUALITY.
IF EVERYONE CAN AGREE TO IT
THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW THERE'S
THE WESTERN REGIONAL AIR
PARTNERSHIP PUBLISHED SOME
GUIDANCE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
OR TWO THAN FIVE AROUND THE-
REGIONAL HAZE RULE DISCUSSING A
PATHWAY FOR CAT CLASSIFYING-
NATURAL VERSES ANTIGENIC
COMMISSION SOURCES AND THEY
FOUND PATHWAYS TO IDENTIFY.
ULTRA BURNING AS PART OF THE
NATURAL BACKGROUND IN A NATURAL
EMISSIONS SOURCE YOU KNOW A LOT
OF TIMES WE INTERPRET WELL IT'S
NOT ALWAYS A LAWLER POLICY THAT
BECOMES A BARRIER BUT THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW IN
THE CREATION OF THE POLICY THAT
BECOMES A BARRIER. AND YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU REALLY LOOK AT THE WAY
WE VIEW FAR TODAY WE LOOK AT
THE IGNITION AS THE CAUSE OR
THE EMISSIONS SOURCE HE MAY BE
IN A HUMAN OR AN ANTHROPOGENIC
IGNITION. BUT IT'S A FUEL
ACCUMULATION THAT ACTUALLY IS
CREATES THE LEVEL OF IMPACT
RELATED TO THE MISSION ITSELF.
AND SO IN IN THAT ASPECT. ONE
COULD BEGIN TO INTERPRET
CULTURE BURNING AND PRESCRIBED
FIRE AS A NATURAL EMISSIONS
SOURCE BECAUSE IT IS THE FUEL
ITSELF AND SPENT THE THAT IS A
MEETING THE CRITERIA POLLUTANT
NOT THE FACT THAT SOMEONE WOULD.
THAT SAID YOU KNOW THERE'S
THERE ARE A LOT MORE- OF THOSE
TYPES OF EXAMPLES OUT THERE
WITH WITH DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE LETTER HOLDING
US UP TODAY- YOU KNOW THERE'S
SO. TRADE STRUCTURE TEXAN
TRADES THAT TAKE PLACE BETWEEN-
THE BA AND KALIFORNIA FOR
SERVICE WILL TRIBES CAN COMPACT
THAT RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE
FIT FROM THE VA IF WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO MAINTAIN A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF TRAINING AND
QUALIFICATION AND BASELINE
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT POSITIONS
SO IF WE CAN MEET SOME OF THOSE
STANDARDS AND CRITERIA. WE CAN
THEN BECOME. ANOTHER PARTY TO
THOSE AGREEMENTS AND ACTUALLY-
TRADE DIRECT PROTECTION AREAS
AND ACTUALLY YOU KNOW. THE FOR
SERVICE ISSUES CAL FIRE PERMITS
THROUGH THOSE AGREEMENTS AND
TRIBES CAN DO THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS TOO AND SO I'M SURE EACH
TRIBE. MAY WANT TO DO THINGS A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY- BUT THAT
SAYS THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
THINGS THAT COULD BE DISCUSSED
FURTHER. IF WE'RE GOING TO
EXPAND- CULTURAL BURNING IN
CALIFORNIA DO YOU FEEL THAT.
SORT OF THE KNOWLEDGE BASES
THERE WITHIN THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY- OR DO YOU THINK THAT
BEFORE WE DID THAT WE'D HAVE
TO. KIND OF DO SOME PREPARATION
IN SOME PLACES. FROM THE
KNOWLEDGE BASE IS PRESIDENT IN
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO FIND THE
PERSON TOOK TO PULL IT PULL IT
OUT OF OR THE ORGANIZATION- TO
BE- TAKING THE POINT OF THE
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES ARE
REALLY WANTING TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN ARE ARE REALLY LETTING
THEMSELVES KNOWN AND THERE ARE
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW OUT
THERE. I THINK THAT ARE READY
TO BEGIN TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
THIS CAN BE DONE I'VE BEEN
ACTUALLY- TALKING WITH SOME
FOLKS THAT MAY BE ABLE TO HELP
WITH SOME OF THIS- SPECIFICALLY
AROUND- THE UC SYSTEM. AND I'VE
LEARNED TO THAT THE UC SYSTEM
IS ACTUALLY A COMPONENT OF THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. I HAVEN'T
RESEARCH- THAT VERY VERY DEEPLY
YET BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
COMMON INTERESTS. I'M AROUND-
THE AGRICULTURAL MECHANICAL
ARTS AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES- THE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ENGAGE IN IN
THE BLENDING OF. OF OUR
INDIGENOUS AND WESTERN
SCIENCES- TO OVERCOME OUR
CURRENT OBSTACLES. THERE'S A
PATHWAY THERE MAY NOT EVEN TAKE
ANY LEGISLATIVE- FUNDING ANY
NEW MONEY YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
TALKING WITH SOME OF THE FOLKS-
IN THE UC SYSTEM ABOUT SOME OF
ITS POTENTIAL AND HAVE BEEN HIT
THERE'S BEEN SOME INDICATION.
THAT YOU KNOW IF THE ENABLING
CONDITIONS WERE SET UP. AND A
BROAD LEVEL OF SUPPORT FROM THE
TRIBAL. CONSTITUENCY CAME
FORWARD TO SAY- YES WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO- TAKE 1% OF- THE
REVENUE GENERATED BY THE UC
ENDOWMENT. AND INVEST IT IN IN
THE ACTIVITIES WERE SPEAKING OF
RIGHT NOW IN IN IN THREE OR
FOUR INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES-
TWO PILOTS SOME OF THESE THINGS.
THEN THEN YOU KNOW THAT COULD
THAT COULD SET UP- SOME
PERMANENT FUNDING BASIS- IN
AND- FOR SOME OF THESE PLACE
BASED SOLUTIONS. SOME FAIRLY
QUICKLY IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
DOESN'T EVEN TAKE A LEGISLATIVE
ACTION FOR UC SYSTEM TO MAKE A
DECISION IN THAT CONTEXT BUT
WHEN YOU DID READ THE MORAL ACT
THAT CREATED THE LAND. THE. THE
SYSTEMS OF THE LAND. I CAN'T
MEMBER TAKE ON THE LAND BASED
UNIVERSITIES AND- IT SAYS THAT.
THAT IT'S UP TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE WHAT KIND
OF EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS CAN BE
ESTABLISHED AND SO IT MAY ONLY
TAKE AS MUCH AS SOME
ENCOURAGEMENT BY THE ROAD
LEGISLATURE OR MAYBE EVEN AN
AUTHORITY TO DONATE TO A
TRIBALLY DRIVEN ENDOWMENT FUND
OF FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
THE MECHANIC THEIR CULTURAL
MECHANICAL ARTS- TO REALLY MOVE
THE NEEDLE IN GETTING US THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GOING
TO MOVE ON- TO MARGOT TO ASK A
QUESTION SHE STILL THERE- WHICH
IS A SIMILAR QUESTION ABOUT WE
USE THAT YOU THINK THE STATE
COULD PARTNER- WITH YOUR TRIBE
OF A BIT BETTER TO. TO EXPAND
TO OTHER CULTURAL BRANDS BOTH
WITH YOU IN OTHER COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE SOME SOME BARRIERS
REGARDING PERMITTING AND THE
YUROK TRIBE ACTUALLY HAS AND-
IN AIR AIR QUALITY DIVISION.
AND ONE WE DO BURNSWE'RE
ACTUALLY GET A PERMIT FROM THE
TRIBE AS WELL AS THE NORTH
COAST AIR QUALITY. AND SO THE
TRIBE IS SET UP TO- TO FULLY.
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE AIR
QUALITY PARK AND SO THAT WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE ONE THING THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR THEM TO
TAKE THAT OVER THE OTHER THING
THAT- SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE SINCE
THE SEQUEL A PROCESS. THAT WHEN
TRIBES ARE BURNING ON THEIR OWN
LAND BASE THEY SHOULD BE THE
ONES TO BE GIVEN THE APPROVAL
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS. THE ARE THE EXPERTS
IN THAT AREA SO WHAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE FOR THE STATE TO ARM TO
CONSIDER TURNING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY- OVER TWO TRIBES
AND IF IT IS- AND MORE THAN
LIKELY WOULD WOULD- ARE. BE A
GOOD SUM OF MONEY TO- TO ASSUME
THAT RESPONSIBILITY WITH
TURNING THAT OVER WOULD ALSO
COME SOME DOLLARS- I AM A YUROK
TRIBAL MEMBER BUT I'M NOT PART
OF THE FORMAL TRIBAL STRUCTURE.
THE CULTURAL PRIOR MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL IS A NON PROFIT AND SO
I CAN'T LIKE REALLY SPEAK FOR
THE TRIBE BUT AS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WORKS WITH FIRE ON THE
RESERVATION THOSE TWO THINGS
ARE WHAT COME TO MIND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
INPUT FROM I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR- DAN PORTER PORTER. DAN ARE
YOU THERE.
SO YOU DAM. I THINK
I'M HERE NOW OKAY GREAT HELLO
WELCOME THANK YOU MY QUESTION
FOR YOU IS WHAT ARE THE
ECOLOGICAL COAL BENEFITS A
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND IF THERE'S
A WAY THAT THE STATE COULD
SOMEHOW BETTER VALUE WERE
QUANTIFIED. THOSE BENEFITS.
GREAT QUESTION SO- THERE ARE SO
MANY ECOLOGICAL GO BENEFITS OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE- THE FIRST ONE
THAT COMES TO MIND. IS THE
RECYCLING OF NUTRIENTS BACK
INTO THE FOREST FLOOR- MUCH OF
CALIFORNIA'S A FOREST HAVE BEEN
CUT OVER AND SOME OF THE SOILS
HAVE WASHED AWAY AND ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF. RECOVERY THAT
TAKES- DECADES- AT TIMES
DEPENDING ON THE SITE-
PRESCRIBED FIRE ACHIEVES TWO
THINGS AT ONCE IT REMOVES THE
SURFACE AND WATER FUELS AND
RECYCLE THOSE NUTRIENTS RIGHT
BACK INTO THE SOIL- BENEFITTING
THE SMALL THINGS THAT REALLY.
AREN'T RUN- NATURE- ANOTHER BIG
HOPE BENEFIT OF COURSE IS A
CARBON SEQUESTRATION- THAT MAY
BE THOUGHT OF AS MOSTLY AS A
HUMAN BENEFIT WHICH IT IS FOR
CLIMATE MITIGATION- BUT IT'S
ALSO- AND ECOLOGICAL BENEFIT IN
THAT- THE SIERRA FORESTS IN THE
FOREST IN THE REDWOOD RANGE.
ARE SOME OF THE MOST CARBON
DENSE FORESTS ON THE PLANET- IN
THEIR OLD GROWTH FORESTS- AND
GET FIRED UP FOR US THAT MEANS
IN THEIR FIRE RESILIENT FORM.
SO WHAT WE ARE. TALKING ABOUT
RECREATING IS- BY DOING THE
THINGS RECOMMENDED HERE TODAY
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST-
TERRESTRIAL CARBON RESERVOIRS-
ON THE PLANET THAT IS FAR
RESILIENCE AND SUPPORTS A HIGH
DEGREE OF BIODIVERSITY. WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER AND MY
LAST QUESTION IS ACTUALLY FOR
STEVEN. ARE YOU STILL THERE.
YEP I'M HEREGREAT MY QUESTION
IS WHETHER AS SIENESE GOING TO
EXPAND THE USE OF FIRE ON ITS
LANDS AFTER SHAVER LAKE IF
YOU'RE IF THAT'S CHANGE YOUR
GOALS OR YOUR OPERATIONS AT ALL
THAT EXPERIENCE. I HELP HELP
THE CREEK FIRE- CHANGED OUR
GOAL ON OUR LAND THAT THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO BE CHANGING ANY OF
YOUR PROGRAM TO INCREASE
PRESCRIBED FIRE OR CHANGE HOW
YOU DO IT OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WELL IF ANYTHING IT WOULD
MOTIVATE US TO. INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DEBT MANAGEMENT AND-
THE AMOUNT OF PRESCRIBED
BURNING THAT WE DO ON OUR
LANDS- IN YEARS PAST WE HAVE
HAD A GOAL OF TRYING TO GET.
ABOUT A THOUSAND ACRES PER YEAR
ON OUR TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR. TWO
THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR BUT- A
VARIETY OF THINGS AND READ
MAINLY REGULATIONS- SLOW THAT
DOWN AND KEEP US FROM ACHIEVING
THAT BUT WE HAVE- CREATED A
VERY GOOD PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL
FIRE DURING THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. AND I THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO HELP BUT- AT TIMES
THEY COME ON OUR LAND. WILL
BURN TOGETHER THEY'LL BURN ONE
UNIT- MY STAFF WILL BURN
ANOTHER UNIT AND SO I THINK
THAT'S GONNA ALLOW US TO RAMP
UP- THE AMOUNT OF ACREAGE THAT
WE CONDUCT PRESCRIBED BURNS ON.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THOUGH NO WE
WERE ALWAYS TRYING TO RESTORE
OUR POOREST. BACK TO A NATURAL
HISTORIC LOOKING AND HISTORIC
FUNCTIONING. WORKING FOR IT.
AND SO THAT'S STILL GOING TO BE
OUR GOAL- WILL BE WILL BE DOING
A LITTLE BIT MORE PLANTING IN
SOME AREAS- WHERE THE FIRE WHAT
IF YOUR OWNER PROPERTY WE'VE
GOT ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ACRES. THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DO SOME REHAB WE'VE GOT ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ACRES- ON
OUR PROPERTY WITH A FIRE WALKED
ONTO OUR PROPERTY BUT ACTUALLY
DID A VERY GOOD JOB THAT
PRESCRIBED BURNING. SOME OF OUR
LAND AGAIN I ACTUALLY FELT KIND
OF GUILTY- PROBABLY DAY FOR THE
FIRE LOOKING ON THE EAST SIDE
OF OUR PROPERTY. THANK YOU
WHILE THIS BUYERS ACTUALLY
DOING A PRETTY GOOD. UNDER
BIRDS ON SOME OF OUR LAND HERE
WHILE IT WAS WREAKING HAVOC AND
DESTRUCTION IN OTHER PLACES SO.
OUR GOALS HAVE NOT CHANGED- WE
HAVE ALWAYS TRIED TO RE
INTRODUCE FIRE. BACK. INTO THE
SYSTEM. I BERNIE. WHICH IS JUST
MEN. NAT HIS FOR. IS THE NUMBER
ONE PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE.
AGAINST CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING IN MAPS
ALL OVER THE STATE- NOT ONLY
DOES IT IMPROVE WATER QUALITY
BUT IT INCREASES WATER
QUANTITY. GOING DOWNSTREAM
WOULD YOU HAVE TO PROPERLY
MANAGE. OKAY HAVE THANK YOU I
THINK WE ARE YOUR NUMBERS TO
TREAT THE PROPER LEVELS. OKAY
THANKS NO THAT'S FINE THANK YOU
FOR THE ANSWER I'M GOING TO
MOVE NOW TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
I'M GONNA GO TO THE DOCTOR
WOULD. LOOK YES SOME- I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE FOR DAN
AND THEN ALSO WON FOR- MISTER
TRIP FROM. OUR KERR CORRECT
REPRESENTATIVE SO- WHOEVER'S
AVAILABLE. THE. OKAY OKAY MR
TRIPP HI PRECIADO APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND- JUST A
QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU- FOR YOU
HOW DO YOU COMPARE AND CONTRAST
HOW THE TRIBE'S RELATIONSHIP.
WITH REGARDING FIRED PRESCRIBED
FIRE CULTURAL BURNING RECALL
CULTURAL BURNING WITH THE IS
THERE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND THE COOPERATION
YOU GET FOR YOUR FREE FOR THE
WORK YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. YES
THERE IS- WE'VE WE'VE MADE
GREAT STRIDES WORKING WITH TO
STAY IN RECENT YEARS. YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN BURNING- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
PRESCRIBED FIRE COUNCIL'S AND-
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS OF FOR THE
HIM BETTER PART OF A COUPLE
DECADES NOW ON VERY SMALL
SCALES. MMHM BUT YOU KNOW
RECENTLY WITH OUR KAMATH RIVER
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE TRAINING
EXCHANGE ACTIVITIES. MMHM WE'VE
REALLY SCALED UP. THAT ACTIVITY
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH STATE- WE
STILL ARE TO THAT POINT TO
WHERE- WE'RE GETTING ANY
MEANINGFUL OF BURNING DONE ON
THE FOR SERVICE SIDE OF THE
LINE- WE STILL DON'T HAVE. ANY
SIGN BURN PLANTS FROM THE VA.
AND SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TROUBLED TRUST PARCELS AND THE
NATIONAL FOREST SYSTEM LANDS-
WE'RE JUST NOT GETTING THERE.
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF PRE
TREATMENT DONE. ON THOSE LANDS
WE'RE WE'RE GETTING MAKE A LOT
OF PILES. WERE EVEN CHALLENGE
BURNING THOSE FILES- BUT- AND
WHEN THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEND SOME SOME TREES- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT ALWAYS SEEMS TO
BECOME THE PRIORITY. BUT YOU
KNOW THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR IN
THE TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE IS
CLEAR IT NEEDS TO BE ABOUT
GETTING THE FIRE ON THE GROUND
EVEN WHEN YOU DO THOSE THINGS
OR OR YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE. GREAT WELL THANK YOU
AND I AND I AND I DID HEAR ALSO
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE HAVING
IS A STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
TO BE ABLE TO PUSH FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES SENSE. THAT THAT'S
CORRECT. YES WE'VE BEEN YOU
KNOW LUCKY ENOUGH TO. TO
RECEIVE SOME THREE YEAR GRANTS-
TO BUILD SOME CAPACITY- BUT-
THOSE THREE YEAR GRANTS- ARE
COMING TO THEIR HAND- AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ON THE VERGE
OF LOSING A LOT OF OUR- OUR
BILL TO PASS CITY IN. AND SO
WERE WERE YOU KNOW OF COURSE IN
THE SHORT TERM GONNA GONNA TRY
TO TRY TO- SUSTAIN WHAT WE CAN.
BY SUBMITTING SOME RATS BUT
ULTIMATELY- THESE THINGS KIND
OF KIND OF NEED TO HAVE
SUSTAINABLE SOURCES- BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T MAINTAIN THEM YOUR
INITIAL INVESTMENT IS JUST A
WASTE OF TIME AND MONEY. THANK
YOU AND HOW HOW MANY ACRES
ALTOGETHER- ARE CONSIDERED
COULD PROVE. HOW TRIBAL LAND
RIGHT NOW. ROUGHLY HOME I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT IT OCCURRED TO
US THAT ARE CONSIDERED GROUP
TRIBAL LAND IT'S YOU KNOW IN
THE LOW THOUSANDS IF NOT
HUNDREDS TWO THOUSAND. BUT AND
IS SPREAD ACROSS YOU KNOW.
MILLIONS OF ACRES AND SO-
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
GETTING TO THE POINT OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY IN RECOGNIZING
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY IS BECAUSE
OUR CONSTITUTION- THAT-ESTABLISHES OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNANCE SYSTEMS. SOME SHOWS
THAT ARE JURISDICTION- OVER US
SUCH THINGS SUCH AS ECOLOGICAL
PROCESS AND FUNCTION. SOME ARE
HARD TO FIND TO BE APPLICABLE
AT THE TERRITORIAL SCALE AND SO
WE REALLY ARE LOOKING AT HAVING
AN OVERLAPPING JURISDICTION
BASED ON OUR CONSTITUTION SAYS
AND THAT'S THE SKILL WE OPERATE
UNDER- WITH OUR DEPARTMENT AND
THAT'S RESOURCES OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU. AND
THEN I HAVE A QUESTION FOR DAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YES- THIS IS-
ACTUALLY- MAYBE TALK QUESTION
MAYBE ON A QUESTION STATEMENT
YOU KNOW BACK AND FORTH ON THIS
SO- APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT YOU'RE CREATING WITH YOUR-
YOUR BERMAN YOUR PRESCRIBER
AND- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
NOBODY HAS HIT UPON THAT- I'VE
MET EXPERIENCE WITH THE- MY-
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY NOW
SENATOR DOLLY- VISITING. HIS
HIS- DISTRICT- IT COUPLE OF
TIMES ACTUALLY ON ON TRIPS OUT
INTO THE FOREST. THE VALUE TO
OUR WATERSHEDS OF THESE
PRESCRIBED BURNS OVER THE LONG
HAUL AND BY THAT I MEAN.
COMBINED WITH THE PRETREATMENT
OF THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
AND THEN THE PRESCRIBED BURN.
ALL THAT VEGETATION THAT IS
OVERGROWN THOSE INDIVIDUAL
STRAWS IN THE GROUND. THE FACT
THEY ALL DRAW WATER. AND THEY
AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
WATERSHEDS TO BE HEALTHY- IS
YOU KNOW IT NATURE CONSERVANCY
OBVIOUSLY HUGELY RESPECTED AND
BY ME AND SO MANY OTHERS- IS
THERE BEEN HAVE YOU DONE
RESEARCH INTO. THE VALUE OF THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ON ON
WATER SUPPLY AND WATERSHED
HEALTH. WE HAVE THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- SO I THINK IT
WAS- YOUR PREVIOUS COMMENT. IT
DOES IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK
RELEVANT HERE I DOLLARS AND
PREVENTION- TO GET A GREAT TO
SIX DOLLARS- AND AVOIDED COSTS
WITH RESPECT TO- WHILE
FIREFIGHTING AND RECOVERY-
EFFORTS AND- THAT. THAT IDEA IS
EMBODIED IN A STUDY THAT WE
COMPLETED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WITH SOME PARTNERS CALLED THE
COLONY OF WAITED COST STUDY-
WHERE. A SERIES OF AUTHORS
QUANTIFIED- THE AVOIDED COSTS
OF. HOW HIGH INTENSITY
WILDFIRES- BY VIRTUE OF THE
PREVENTATIVE WORK THAT THAT
COULD BE DONE. TO THE QUESTION
OF- WATER BENEFITS IN A NUMBER
OF- STUDIES- DONE ALONG THOSE
LINES SOME BY US. A LEADER IN
THIS FIELD IS YOU SEE SAID THE
WORK OF DR ROGER BALES- WHO IS
PART OF OUR FRENCH MEADOWS
PARTNERSHIP- THE WATER CYCLE
ITSELF IS COMPLICATED ARE
PREDICTING WATER YIELD IN
RELATION TO FOREST MANAGEMENT
EVEN MORE SO. THERE DOES SEEM
TO BE SOME. DOMINO GAINES AND
WATER YIELD ASSOCIATED WITH-
ANY BUT I THINK FURTHER STUDY
IS NEEDED- AND I'D I'D REFER
YOU TO DR BAILES WORK AND OTHER
HYDROLOGISTS WHO ARE FAR MORE
QUALIFIED THAN I AM- BUT
CERTAINLY- THE WATERSHED
BENEFITS OVERALL. IN TERMS OF
AVOIDING- HIGH INTENSITY
WILDFIRES THAT RESULT IN A
HIGHLY RUNNABLE SOILS. CLOGGING
UP RESERVOIRS FOR YEARS AND
ADDING TO THEIR ANNUAL
MAINTENANCE COSTS- ALONG WITH
IMPACTS TO THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES LIKE- VERY
SOME FABIAN SPECIES THE RELYING
CLEAN COLD WATER- ALL ADD UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ACTUALLY MISTER PORTER I HAD A
QUESTION FOR YOU AS WELL AS I
SEE YOUR CHAIR SPENDING I
DIDN'T CATCH YOU QUICK ENOUGH.
THAT'S FINE I'M BACK. WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
KIND OF PARTNERSHIPS AND I WAS
JUST CURIOUS FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE EVERY YEAR
UTILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT TO THE CQC VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PLAN HOW CAN- STATE
AGENCIES AND WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE HANG UPS WITH STATED SHE'S
ON PARTNERING WITH UTILITIES TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS TO MAKE-
MAKE IT A PRIORITY ON STATE
LANDS. CAN YOU CLARIFY STATE
LANDS WHAT ARE YOU REFERRING
SPECIFICALLY PRIVATE PLANS OR-
THOSE WITHIN COUNTY
JURISDICTION. CERTAINLY NOT
PRIVATE I THINK BY BILLIONS AS
ITS OWN SEPARATE YOU KNOW ISSUE
BUT WAS FAR AS LIKE THE STATE
RESPONSE AREA- AS IT RUNS INTO
YOU KNOW- LOCALIZED URBAN
INTERFACE BUT STATE RESPONSE
HERE IT PRIMARILY. OKAY SO I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TOUCHING ON
IS- THE IDEA AND THE NEED AT
THE END IT'S A BIG NEED FOR-
CROSS JURISDICTIONAL- PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION WOULD THAT
BE CORRECT. CERTAINLY YES BUT
IT IS. WHEN YOU APPLY FOR A
PERMIT SAY WHETHER IT'S
WHATEVER UTILITY THEY WANT TO
DO SOMETHING. THERE TENDS TO BE
A HANG UP WITH STATE AGENCIES
ON THOSE PERMITTING BECAUSE
THEY GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS
AND BY THE TIME THAT WE GET ALL
OF THIS DONE. WERE EITHER OUT
OF THE SEASON OR I MEAN WE FOR
THE TRIBAL MEMBERS TALK ABOUT
IT WE JUST RAN OUT OF TIME TO
DO THIS SO IS THERE A WAY IN
YOUR MIND WE COULD STREAMLINE
SOME OF THAT SO WHEN UTILITIES
OR TRIBE IS WANTING TO DO THESE
THINGS- TILE SEQUENCE INCHES
IN THOSE TYPES OF THINGS. WHAT
CAN WE DO TO STREAMLINE THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL WITHIN THE
STATE AGENCIES. OKAY GOT IT SO
I THINK THAT. EXEMPTIONS ARE IN
AND OF THEMSELVES- BUT IT TOOL
IN SOME SITUATIONS- YOU MAY BE
AWARE THAT WITH SB NINE A ONE-
IF A FUELS MANAGEMENT- ACTIVITY
IS ALREADY COVERED BY NEPA ON
FEDERAL LANDS NATIONAL FIREMEN
ALL POLICY ACT THEN- THOSE SAME
PROJECTS CAN BE CLASSIFIED AS
EXEMPTED FROM SEQUEL HAVING
ALREADY GONE THROUGH AN
ENVIRONMENTAL EVALUATION FOR
THE FEDERAL PROCESS SO. THAT
THOSE KIND OF EXEMPTIONS WORK
WELL WHEREVER YOU'RE- TAKING A
LOOK AT AND REMOVING-
REDUNDANCIES IN THE SYSTEM- I
THINK YOU KNOW TO DIRECTOR
PORTERS- PREVIOUS COMMENT. IT
THEY'RE ARE A LOT OF RESOURCES
OUT THERE THAT NEED TO BE KNOWN
IT AND DISCLOSED- BEFORE
ASSERTING THAT THERE IS NO
HARM- CERTAINLY THERE ARE WAYS
ON THE GROUND THAT CAN BE. USED
TO MAKE THAT PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT- BUT I THINK FRANKLY
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO IS
FORMING THOSE CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL PARTNERSHIPS- WE
HAVE A VERY SUCCESSFUL ONE FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE PLASTER COUNTY
WATER AGENCY. PLASTER COUNTY
THE US FOREST SERVICE
KALIFORNIA SEVERAL OTHER
PARTNERS WHERE WE SIT DOWN
AHEAD OF TIME DEFINE OUR GOALS.
RAISE FUNDS FOR THOSE GOALS.
SHEPHERDED FIREMAN ALL
PERMITTING. AWESOME SO THAT
WERE FULLY AWARE OF WHAT'S
AVAILABLE- IN TERMS OF NATURAL
CULTURE RESOURCE OUT THERE- AS
WE GET INTO FUNDING PROJECTS
AND BY DOING THAT WE END UP
AVOIDING UP MOST NOT ALL BUT
MOST OF THE DELAYS THAT THAT-
FOLKS EXPERIENCE BUT IT IS A
VERY RESOURCE INTENSIVE PROCESS.
NO ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE I THINK I
MEAN IN THIS ENTIRE HEARING
TODAY WE'VE WE'VE HEARD THE
IMPORTANCE OF USING. FIRE AS A
TOOL TO RESTRICT USE OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AS YOU
WELL KNOW YOU KNOW THERE'S
THREE THINGS TO SUSTAIN FIRE IT
OXYGEN FUEL AND IGNITION RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS REDUCING THE FUEL LOAD
AND FIRE IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT. AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
USE OUR TRIBAL FRIENDS- TO GET
THIS THING MOVING FORWARD. BUT
IF IT IS GOOD ON TRIBAL LAND.
IT SHOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
ENTIRE FOR SYSTEM. AND SO I
THINK IT'S WE'RE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS. HOW DO WE ALLOW
PRIVATE INDUSTRIES PRIVATE
ENTITIES. TO USE THE SAME.
HELLO THE SAME. METHODS THAT
ARE GOOD ON TRIBAL LANDS BUT
CAN READ REDUCE SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS BECAUSE I FIND THAT WE
GET HUNG UP- AT THE STATE LEVEL
BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. AND NOBODY
REALLY WANTS TO LIKE LET THE
OTHER GUYS HANNAH COOKIE JAR
RIGHT WE ALL CAN WERE VERY
TERRITORIAL OF THAT. AND SO
THAT IS MY FEAR IS WHERE WE ARE
IDENTIFYINGTHAT THIS IS A
GREAT TOOL. HOW DO WE USE IT IN
TRIBAL LANDS TO BE SHORT AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW MAYBE MORE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC STATE LANDS
AS WELL. SO THAT'S KIND OF. MY
CONCERN WITH ALL THIS. YEAH I
KNOW IT'S A- COULD. AND I THINK
TO THE DEGREE THAT CAN THIS
WON'T BE A SIMPLE SOLUTION BUT
I THINK CENTRALIZING- THE PLAN
IN THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
STAYS- AS MUCH AS THEY CAN OR
AT LEAST COORDINATING THEM
WOULD BE. HELPFUL ONE ONE GROUP
THAT I. MENTIONED IN MY
PREVIOUS ANSWER IS. IT ARE THAT
THEY ARE DISTRICTS AND
CAPITOLA- THEY'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE PARTNERS.
IN OUR IN OUR COLLABORATIVE AS
WELL- AND SO IF YOU CAN TAKE
THOSE FLEDGLING EFFORTS WHETHER
IT BE BY THE TRIBES OR BY THE
NGO COMMUNITY. AND SEE WHAT
WORKS WITHIN THOSE
COLLABORATIVES- I THINK YOU
MIGHT HAVE THE INGREDIENTS FOR
YOU KNOW SOME BROADER
SYSTEMATIC CHANGE THAT YOU THAT
YOU HAVE IN MIND. PERJURY MUCH
THANK YOU. ABOUT THANK YOU I'M
ARE THEY ANY. FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY I'M NOT
HEARING ANY I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE WITNESSES FROM ALL OF
THE PANELS WERE REALLY REALLY.
IMPORTANT I'M HEARING A LOT OF
WONDERFUL INFORMATION AND NOW
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN THE ROOM. AND
I WILL JUST GIVE NOTICE TO THE
UP TELEPHONE OPERATOR THAT
AFTER THIS WILL BE MOVING TO-
THE TELEPHONE- COMMENTARY SO
YOU MAY WANT TO START QUEUING
UP TO THOSE WITNESSES. AND THEY
WILL BE TWO MINUTES I REPEAT
TWO MINUTES ONLY PER INDIVIDUAL
PER SPEAKER PLEASE. A MAP IS IT
ON YES WE CAN ARE YOU ME THANK
YOU MATT CHAIR MEMBER CHRIS MY
KALEY I BEHALF OF THE HUMBLE
AND THEN MENDOZA REDWOOD
COMPANY WE HAD WITH A LOT OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE.
PROVIDED THIS AFTERNOON BY YOUR
DIFFERENT PANELISTS IN
PARTICULAR OUR FIRM BELIEF IS
THAT WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE WE
REALLY HAVE TO ADDRESS BOTH.
IMITATION ON LIABILITY. ABSENT
OF COURSE SOME SORT OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE. IN ORDER TO ALLOW
THOSE TO BE INSURABLE ACTIONS
WITHOUT INSURANCE WITHOUT SOME
SORT OF LIMITATION ON LIABILITY
WE'RE NOT GONNA GET PRESCRIBED
FIRE TO SCALE. WE ALSO OF
COURSE NEED TO CONTINUE
THINNING EFFORTS BUT THERE ARE
TWO OTHER ITEMS I WANT TO BRING
TO THE- COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION
MADAM CHAIR FIRST IS WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE ONE
INDIVIDUAL IN CHARGE- DIRECTING
THESE LARGE SCALE PROJECTS WITH
THE GOAL OF. A HALF A MILLION
ACRES A YEAR TO TREAT AND OVER
THIRTY THREE MILLION- FOREST
LANDS ACRES OF FOREST LAND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
REALLY HAVE TO HAVE A SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL IN CHARGE THE OTHER
THING IS WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
WITH THAT MATERIAL- WE THINK
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO INVOLVE
BIOMASS. YOU BASICALLY HAVE TWO
OPTIONS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
TREAT THAT SORT OF A LARGE
SCALE NUMBER OF ACRES EITHER UP
OPEN PILE BURNS FOR BIOMASS AND
IF YOU BELIEVE THE PLASTER
COUNTY AIRPORT STUDY. WE SEE
DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS IN THE
EMISSIONS PART OF OUR MATTER
IT'S SEVERAL THE LAST ITEM IS
I'M REMINDED OF A SAYING THAT
THE CHAIRMAN OF OUR BOARD WHO
HAS OFTEN MADE IT'S ACTUALLY A
SIMILAR TO WHAT MISS ROBBINS
SAID ON YOUR LAST PANEL SHE
SAID. PEOPLE MUST CHOOSE THEIR
SMOKE. AND MICHAEL THAT YOU'RE
OF OUR OFTEN SAYS. WE CAN
EITHER HAVE FIRE WHEN WE WANT
IT. OR WHEN MOTHER NATURE WANTS
IT AND WE'VE SEEN THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON WHEN
MOTHER NATURE DOES IT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. YOU VERY MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
COME UP NOW TO THE MICROPHONE
PLEASE ONE OF THE TIME JUST GO
AHEAD SOMEBODY GO AHEAD. GO
AHEAD THANK. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME IN TWO MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FIND A TODAY MADAM CHAIR- FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND A THE
COMMITTEE- I SHOULD I FIND IT
TODAY IN HAVE GROUND BASED WITH
YOU I CERTAINLY ADMIRE COURAGE
YOUR- YOUR CLARITY. AND I'LL
TRY TO BE AS CLEAR I CAN ALL.
YOU KNOW FIRE YOU KNOW I JUST
FEEL A- THEM IT'S BEAUTIFUL
IT'S SO WHY I MEAN SOME IT'S SO
WARM INVITING AND FEEL SO
WONDERFUL ESPECIALLY ON YOUR
THIS DR SERVICE SAID AROUND
FIVE AND TALKING THINGS MOTION.
TO US LAW IN FAMILY COMMUNITY.
AND TO AND CHILDREN I THINK
THAT SOMETIMES FIRES CAN BURN A
LOT OUT OF CONTROL AND THEY'RE
MEANT TO BE WATCHED IN TO BE
FED GOOD THINGS GOOD A GOOD
WORDS AND LOVE THAT AMONGST
EACH OTHER FEEDING THE FIRES IN
OUR HEARTS. AND SOMETIMES IN
FIRES GET OUT OF CONTROL
BECAUSE OF THE NOT BEING WASHER.
YOU KNOW LIKE A PROBLEM THAT
THAT YOU ASSUME IS GREATER THAN
A GREATER PROBLEM IT REALLY IS-
I'M SORRY- THAT I DON'T KNOW A
WHOLE LOT ABOUT- FIRES AND
STUFF LIKE THAT. BUT I DO THINK
THERE'S A FIRE BURNING OUT OF
CONTROL RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
BASICALLY. YOU KNOW
NANOTECHNOLOGY- I KNOW THAT I'M
SORRY FOR YOU KNOW BUT I FEEL
JUST YOU KNOW I HAVE TO SAY
SOMETHING BECAUSE OF WHAT I'VE
BEEN THROUGH- BASICALLY
SOMEONE'S REALLY BEEN GIVING ME
A HARD TIME AND I CAN'T SAY
EXACTLY WHO IT IS- BECAUSE I
SHOULDN'T. BUT BUT I BASICALLY
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN TORTURED FOR
ELEVEN STRAIGHT TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN- I'VE BEEN TORTURED SIX
MONTHS RATE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
WITH PEOPLE YOU KNOW SPEAKING
TO ME THESE DARN ANNA RADIOS
AND DEVICES AND WHATNOT. AND
IT'S BEEN TERRIBLE I'M FIVE
MONTHS STRAIGHT NEEDS TORMENT
THESE PAST FIVE MONTHS AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S  LOT
TO BE HAPPY AND I DON'T BLAME
ANYBODY YOU KNOW I GOT NOTHING
BUT COMPASSION FOR EVERYBODY. I
THINK THAT- WE'RE ALL PERFECT
JUST THE WAY GOD MADE US EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US ON DOCTORS
TO DOCTORS FOR SURE. EVERYONE
IN- I AND I AND I STILL LIKE
YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE IT'S
READING FOR ME TO DO TO STAY
THAT YOU KNOW IT MY HEART HAVE
A CHILD. YOU KNOW BECAUSE I
KNOW THIS THIS STUFF GOING ON
AREN'T AND A AND R. YOU KNOW
I'M JUST YOU KNOW I'M SO THAT I
MIGHT BE A FULL TIME JUST YOU
KNOW I DON'T TO MAKE ABOUT YOU
KNOW SYMBOL FOR MAILING. BUT
YOU KNOW WE ALL CARE OF
FAMILIES AND SHALL AND I SAW DO
TO MORE ANYTHING THAT'S ALL I
BEEN TRYING TO DO. SO I'M LIKE
WHAT THE HECK IS HAPPENING ME
AND YOU KNOW I FEEL I SAID YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE SAY THAT IT'S A
GREATER FOR REYES YOU KNOW I'M
HOPE I'M OUT I'M OUT. YOU KNOW
THEY ASK ME WHAT I'M WHAT I
WOULD EXPECT TO DO STUFF LIKE
THAT I HAD A JOB WORKING HARD
FOR ALL THIS THAT HAPPENED YOU
KNOW- SERVING DINNER TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE LESS FORTUNATE. BUT I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO YOU KNOW
THINGS I WANT TO DO BECAUSE OF
THAT BUT YOU KNOW IF THEY ASK
ME AGAIN I WOULD SAY ABSOLUTELY
REFUSE I'M NOT INTERESTED
PLEASE DON'T ASK ME AGAIN
PLEASE DON'T TALK TO ME TO
THESE DARN ADVISES AGAIN. AND I
JUST WANT TO KNOW I THINK
YOU'RE PRETTY. THE WAY GOD MADE
JONES. I'M SORRY FOR SAYING BUT
I DO THINK THAT CHILDREN ARE
WORTH IT YOU KNOW I'M- MAYBE
I'M JUST A- NUMBERS AND SPECIAL
I MEAN BUT I DO THINK IT'S ALL
GOING TO BE DEBATING THE MAGIC
IN A LOT OF OUR LIVES AND I
HOPE THAT YOU DON'T KNOW YOUR
PRINT I GOT MAJOR. UNION
FAMILIES THIS FOR SURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU. MONEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WISH OUR. THE
CHILDREN ARE WORTH IT THAT'S MY
TAKE AWAY FROM THE LAST
COMMONER. MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM AND I HAVE MY THREE
CHILDREN WITH ME TODAY. SO
BASED ON THE FACT THAT I AM NOW
ZOOM SCHOOLING THEM I THINK
THAT GIVES US AS A FAMILY OF
FOUR EIGHT MINUTES. NO IT'S TWO
MINUTES PER PERSON THAT'S. ALL
TWO MINUTES PER PERSON WHO ARE.
THANK YOU AND YOUR USE FIFTY OF
THOSE SACK. WE'LL GIVE YOU THE
FIFTEEN SECONDS BACK. HOW
GENEROUS OF YOU BECAUSE WHERE
DISPLACED PEOPLE FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE. I'VE TALKED WITH JIM WOOD
IN PERSON ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
AND I CAN PROMISE YOU THAT
WAKING UP WITH MY CITY ON FIRE
IN THE YEAR OF SEVENTEEN WAS
ONE OF THE SCARIEST THINGS THAT
HAS EVER HAPPENED TO ME AND THE
FACT THAT YOU WILL NIT PICK ME.
IS YET ANOTHER INDICATOR TO ME
OF THE SHAMEFUL ACTS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE IT SEEMS TO ME THIS
HEARING IS DECADES TOO LATE.
FROM YOUR BLOOD MONEY THAT YOU
ACCEPT FROM PG&E. WHY WOULD I
TRUST YOU TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
NOW. I'M ENCOURAGED BY SOME OF
WHAT I HEARD IN THIS HEARING
TODAY. BY THIS PERSON MARGO
ROBBINS. BILL TRAP TRIP. BUT
YOU YOU'VE ALREADY SHOWN
YOURSELF TO BE UNRELIABLE ON
RESPONSIBLE ONE WORTHY OF
SITTING IN THOSE SEATS. I'M A
DISPLACED PERSON I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. NOW BECAUSE
I FLED WITH MY CITY IN FLAMES.
AND YOU WON'T GIVE ME THE FULL
EIGHT MINUTES. YOU'LL LET MY
CHILDREN COME UP. THEY WERE
THERE. TO AND THIS KEEPS
HAPPENING BIZARRE THE FIRE I'M
A YEAR OLD JUST DIED AND SO DID
HER MOTHER MY SEVENTY YEAR OLD
FRIEND JUST LOST EVERYTHING IN
HAPPY CAMP. AND YOU'RE GOING TO
QUIBBLE ABOUT MINUTES. IT'S
DISGUSTING.
SO TO BUY CHILDREN
GET TO SPEAK. YES THEY CAN
SPEAK YOU SAID WE ALL GET TWO
MINUTES CORRECT.
MY NAME IS
AUDREY MAY CANON AND I WHAT WAS
12-1 DURING THE TUBBS FIRE I
REMEMBER- I'M GOING TO SHARE
HER FRIEND'S HOUSE AND HAVING
TO LEAVE THE ANIMALS AT OUR
HOUSE. THANK YOU. HI I'M FIVE
MARGOT MY CANON. AND I WAS.
NINE HERE DURING THE TUBBS FIRE
AND. AND I REMEMBER. WELL MY
TEACHER'S HOUSE BURNED DOWN AND
SHE SHE ALL THIS ABOUT HOW SOME
OF HER NEIGHBORS DIED THAT
KENYA. THANK YOU MARCO VERY
WELL DONE SIR ANYBODY ELSE
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK. HE WALKED.
SPECIFICALLY YOUR NAME OF YOUR
TELEPHONE NUMBER THE ACTION.
HOW TO SAY IT. MY NAME IS GAVIN
MCCANN AND I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD
DURING THE TUBBS FIRE AND I
REMEMBER A LOT OF ASH FALLING
FROM THE SKY. CONSENT THANK YOU
GAVIN GOOD JOB IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IT SEEMS TO ME
YOU COULD LET ME FINISH SINCE
I'M THE MOTHER NOW EVERYBODY
GETS TWO MINUTES MA'AM THANK
YOU. OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE CALLS. OPERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT YEP IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT PRESS ONE MINUTE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN THE ONE
THEN ZERO FOR ANY COMMENTS. AND
NOW BE JUST A MOMENT. AND AN
OPERATOR HAS ALREADY GIVING YOU
A LINE NUMBER YOU CAN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
IN THE QUEUE LOCAL TO LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HEATON
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND I APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING
THIS HEARING WE ARE OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORTED AND- NOT ONLY TO
PRACTICE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE BUT
INCREASING THE PACE AND SCALE
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE CALIFORNIA
BOTH ON STATE AND FEDERAL
LANDS. AND PRIVATELY OWNED
LANDS WHERE APPROPRIATE WE SEE
PRESCRIBED FIRES ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX AND THE NEED FOR
THAT WERE FEASIBLE IS
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE TACTICAL
I WANT TO SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD. COMMENT ABOUT THAT ALSO
NEEDING TO REALLY QUAN. B. R.
QUALITY.BENEFITS A PRESCRIBE
FIRE. THE CASH IN HIGH WILDFIRE
ALSO HAVE BEEN. URGING THE
STATE AIRBORNE TO QUANTIFY
THOSE EMISSIONS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT THEY
COME UP WITH PURSUANT AT THE
NINE OH ONE SO- WE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
AND- WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
STATE ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MAXWELL I TWENTY. YOU FOR.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN ON
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CAP COLOR
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS SMALL THIRTY FIVE
DISTRICTS THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING THAT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING PER YEAR FOR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT GRANTS FOR
INCREASING MONITORING A
PRESCRIBED BURNS PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND OTHER RELATED WORK
AS REQUIRED BY SB TWELVE SIXTY.
I'M NOT THAT SB TWELVE SIXTY
INCLUDED LANGUAGE REQUIRING
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT PARTICIPATION
IMPLEMENTATION COST OF THIS NEW
SB TWELVE SIXTY REQUIRED
PROGRAM IS PROVIDING CRITICAL
STATEWIDE BENEFIT. EXPANDING
PRESCRIBED FIRE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT HELP
WILL BE KEY TO MEETING THAT
GOAL OF TREATING ONE MILLION
ACRES OF VEGETATION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AS IDENTIFIED IN THE RECENTLY
SIGNED U. S. FOREST SERVICE
CALIFORNIA AND ARE YOU.
DISTRICTS PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
MONITORING PRESCRIBED FIRE ANY
PUBLIC OUTREACH IN COORDINATION
WHICH ARE CRITICAL FOR MAKING
SURE BIRDS ARE SAFE FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE BUT
ALSO IN CHANGING PUBLIC
PERCEPTION OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
EXPANSION. DURING THE FIRST
YEAR THE PROGRAM AND DISTRICTS
VERIFIED NEARLY. THIRTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PRESCRIBED FIRES. OVER
A HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND A
RICH WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE INTO
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE FIRES WERE
MONITORED WITH EBAY ANSWER
STATIONARY MONITORS USING THE
PROTOCOL DEVELOPED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND CAPCO. WHILE THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS MODEST THE INVESTMENT
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BENEFITS AND
COST SAVINGS. PRESCRIBED FIRE
HEADS OFF THE SIGNIFICANT
CRITERION TOXIC EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH WILDFIRES
INCLUDING THE INCINERATION OF
PLASTICS PESTICIDES AND OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT ARE CONTAINED
WITHIN BUILDINGS VEHICLES AND
HOMES. AS OTHER TESTIMONY NOTED
TODAY FUNDING RESOURCES IN AIR
DISTRICT CAPACITY CAPACITY ARE
OF MAJOR CONCERN. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
REGARDING THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AXOLOTL LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY TOPIC. I
DON'T THOUGH LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THE WITNESSES FOR PROVIDING
VERY HELPFUL INFORMATION TODAY
MY NAME IS PAMELA FLICK AND I'M
THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE. AND
ALSO A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
SEVEN YEAR PRESCRIBED FIRE
COUNCIL AND A LONG TIME ACTED
PARTICIPATE IN THE DQ LANDSCAPE
PREPARATION PROJECT AND ITS
FIRE POLICY WORKGROUP FOR THE
PAST DECADE ON THE THEORY
NATIONAL FOREST- I DON'T FEEL
LIKE TO ECHO A DOCTOR STEVEN
AND- COMMENT ABOUT WORKING WITH
THE MAKING PROGRESS WITH THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT YOU
THAT WORK ON THE DINKY
COLLABORATIVE. I AGREE WITH YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD IT HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY CHALLENGING
TO DO PRESCRIBED FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF THAT
CHALLENGE ORIGINATES FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR POLICIES.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST AFFORD GROWTH
ISSUE IT CHARACTERIZED EARLIER
IN THE HEARING AS WE'VE HEARD
FROM A WIDE VARIETY OF TODAY'S
WITNESSES THIS IS A COMPLEX
CHALLENGE THAT REQUIRES
POLICIES AND FUNDING THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVED ON.
COURT COMMUNITY PLANNING
DECISION A LACK OF A PROACTIVE
ACTION AND RESOURCES TO REDUCE
HAZRDOUS FUEL AFTER MORE THAN
A CENTURY OF UNSUSTAINABLE
LOGGING PRACTICES AND
AGGRESSIVE FIRE SUPPRESSION
POLICIES. LIMITED CAPACITY FOR
FIRE LIGHTING VERSUS
FIREFIGHTING AND WORKS
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
RETENTION. LACK OF SOCIAL
ACCEPTANCE OF BENEFICIAL FIRE
AND REDUCE IMPACT INCREASED
NEED FOR INCENTIVES AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR HOME
PARDONING AND MEANINGFUL
COMMUNITY PROTECTION EFFORT.
LIABILITY PROTECTION THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON WE CANNOT AFFORD
TO WAIT ANOTHER YEAR
PARTNERSHIPS AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT WILL BE KEY IN THIS
WORK AND THE POLICIES AND THE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
FURTHER WE HAVE MUCH TO LEARN
FROM NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AS
WELL AS OTHER REGIONS OF OUR
COUNTRY. AS BOTH DR STEVENSON
MISS QUINN DAVIDSON
ACKNOWLEDGED I YOU THINK
LOGICALLY. TO X. WITH THE
TORTILLA BOTH BY AND POLICY FOR
TO MORE BENEFITS FIRED OUR FIRE
ADOPTED CAUSES. AND PROTECT.
AND OUR WILDLIFE NATURAL
RESOURCE VALUES THE TIME TO ACT
IS NOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MAX THE AUTO A LOT
PLEASE WELL I HAD. YES BRIT THE
K. CATTLEMEN'S. THANK YOU
JEFFREY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HOSTING VERY AND- MEETING TODAY
AS WELL AS FOR THE EXCELLENT
SLATE OF SPEAKERS. I
PARTICULARLY WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ONE THE QUEEN DAVID
SENT TO ACTUALLY ADVISEMENT
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION'S FIRE SUBCOMMITTEE
AFFECT OVER COMMENTS REGARDING
A LIABILITY CONCERNS AND
REGULATORY HURDLES THAT PREVENT
OBSTACLES TO PRESCRIBED FIRE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA CATTLE RANCHERS
MANAGE MUCH OF THE STATE'S
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ACRES
RANGELAND. AND FOR THAT REASON
THEIR NATURAL PARTNERS FOR LAND
MANAGEMENT INCLUDING THROUGH
PRESCRIBED BURNS. UNFORTUNATELY
RANGERS HAVE ALSO BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BY THIS
YEAR'S MEGA FIRES OF ALL OF
THAT WAS FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES FOR
INSTANCE RECENTLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE CHIEF HERE'S YOUR MEDIA
PAST PRESIDENT. WHOSE PASTORS
WERE DESTROYED BY THE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE NORTH
COMPLEX FIRE. WHICH ALSO KILLED
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED OF HIS
CATTLE. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
RANCHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPTURE THIS EXPERIENCE
DEVASTATION. YOU HEARD FROM THE
QUEEN DAVID SEND THAT RANCHERS
ARE DEMANDING THAT COULD CRIED
FIRE BE BROUGHT BACK INTO THE
TOOL BOX. INDEED THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND ITS
MEMBERS WHOLEHEARTEDLY BELIEVE
THE CALIFORNIA MUST PREVENT
FUTURE MAJOR FIRES FIRST AND
FOREMOST BY SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING THE USE OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN THE STATE.
AND WE ARE TO THE CULTURAL
PRIOR SPEAKERS FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR PRESCRIBED BURNS IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PRESCRIBED BURNING
IS EFFECTIVELY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE MUST ALSO REDUCE
THE MANY REGULATORY HURDLES
THAT STYMIE PRESCRIBED BURNS
SUCH AS THE AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS AND ONEROUS CHIKORE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ONE YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER. CALIFORNIA
MUST ALSO ADDRESS LIABILITY AND
INSURANCE CONCERNS RELATED TO
PRESCRIBED FIRE. ADDITIONALLY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULDN'T
DIRECTOR PORTER BRIEFLY. THIS
TODAY CCA BELIEVES THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH INCREASED
PRESCRIBED BURNS THE STATE
SHOULD CONSIDER THE APPLICATION
OF PRESCRIBED GRAZING. WHICH
RECENT RESEARCH OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF COOPER UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION SAN BENITO. CONFIRMS
CAN REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK.
FINALLY LET ME JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. AND CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION IS
EAGER TO WORK WITH YOU IN THE
REST OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
COMING SESSION. TO ACCOMPLISH
THE PRIORITIES LAID. TO
PRESCRIBED BURNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR THE ANY
OTHER COLOR. THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH AND LIKE YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR I'LL GO
BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY LAST
COMMENTS. MISTER FLORA. WELL I
WANT TO THANK STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK FOR ALL OF THE
PANELISTS ALL OF THE SPEAKERS
FROM THE PUBLIC- WE CERTAINLY
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO THIS
YEAR TO KEEP MOVING THE STATE
INTO A BETTER DIRECTION WHEN IT
COMES TO MANAGING ITS OPEN
SPACE A WILD LANDS AND BRING
MORE FIRE BACK TO HELP BALANCE
OUR ECO SYSTEMS. THIS IS SORT
OF THE OPENING SALVO AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT ALL OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ARE GOING TO BE DOING THIS YEAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE
ADJOURNED.